THE SENATE COMMITTEE AND THAT'S
RESOURCE IN WATER WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE
TO COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY IN
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
SENATE'S MAY NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WILL BE OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE-
STREET BUILDING ALAS ALL THE
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEES NOW TO BE
PRESENT IN ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED SO WE CAN ESTABLISH OUR
CORPSMAN BEGIN OUR HEARING
ALTHOUGH WE ARE GOING TO.
SUBCOMMITTEE PRESENT PURPOSE. TO
ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS THE PUBLIC IN
THE HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT
SUCH DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOWING WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO TESTIFY
TODAY FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TESTIFIED TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
NOW POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE OF THESE DISPLAYED ON
SCREEN AND I'LL ANNOUNCE IT NOW
THE PARTICIPANT NUMBER FOR TODAY
IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO
SIX EIGHT ONE SIX THREE. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN THREE SIX
TWO EIGHT THREE THREE. ON HOW
TO. BUT HOW THE TELECONFERENCES
TO WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE ANDORRA COMMITTEE WEBSITE
WHEN WE MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT AND ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON MUTE IN YOUR NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. A PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY. AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET
THE DUDE OF. THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE.
IT'S IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. ALL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING IS CUSTOMARY.
AND ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DISRUPTIVE WHO. MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE.
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS.
NEEDED WE HAVE. ELEVEN BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA- AND- THE ONE.
ITEM ON CONSENT. ONE OF THE
ITEMS ON CAN PROPOSED CONSENT
HAS. ARE NO I'M SORRY I'M TWELVE
ONE OF MY BILLS HAVE BEEN
PULLED. AND RESET FOR. THE NEXT
HEARING AND WE HAVE THREE ITEMS
ON CONSENT- FILE ITEM TWO SB
THIRTY TWO FILE ITEM SEVEN SB
TEN TWENTY EIGHT. AND FILE ITEM
ELEVEN S. B. THIRTEEN SEVENTY
TWO- SO WE'RE GONNA WAIT TO
ESTABLISH A CORPSMAN START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE AND I KNOW. WE DO
HAVE OUR FIRST AUTHOR HERE OF SB
TWELVE NINETY FIVE THE CENTER
LIMÓN IF YOU'RE OKAY PRESENTED
TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE. WE WOULD
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND IF IT'S OKAY
WITH YOU I WILL PRESENT FROM
HERE- THANK YOU TURN SENATORS SB
TWELVE NINETY FIVE ADDRESSES A
SERIOUS PROBLEM OF DESERTED
WELDING CALIFORNIA. DESERTED
WELLS ARE YOU FINANCIAL
LIABILITY TO THE STATE AND
DANGEROUS TO THE SURROUNDING
ENVIRONMENT AND RESIDENTS. THE
WEALTH CAN LEAK IT DEGRADING AIR
QUALITY AND CONTAMINATE
AQUIFER'S HARMING THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY. ACCORDING
TO A REUTERS INVESTIGATION
ORPHANED AND ABANDONED WELLS IN
THE UNITED STATES WERE
COLLECTIVELY RESPONSIBLE FOR
EMITTING TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE.
THOUSAND TONS OF METHANE INTO
THE ATMOSPHERE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. IN MY DISTRICT WE HAVE
SEEN THE REAL IMPACT. OF THESE
OIL COMPANIES GOING BANKRUPT AND
LEAVING TAXPAYERS TO PAY THE
PRICE OF CLEANING UP AGING OIL
INFRASTRUCTURE. IT IS THE
CENTRAL FOR THE STATE TO HAVE
FUNDS TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THE MASSIVE
NEED FOR FUNDING FOR PLUGGING
AND ABANDONING THESE ORPHANED
WELLS. AND ENSURING INDUSTRY IS
ALSO PART OF THE SOLUTION AND
PLAYS A PART IN PLUGGING AND
ABANDONING THESE WELLS. SB
TWELVE NINETY FIVE WOULD REQUIRE
THAT WHEN MONEY IS ALLOCATED
THROUGH THE GENERAL FUND TO PAY
FOR PLUGGING AND ABANDONING. CAL
CHEN CAN COLLECT AND SPEND THAT
SAME AMOUNT FROM INDUSTRY. THIS
BILL WILL ALSO ALLOW CALTRAIN TO
SAVE UP TO TWO HUNDRED MILLION.
IF THEY DO NOT SPEND THEIR FULL
ANNUAL ALLOCATION. I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH OPPOSITION ON
THIS ISSUE AND REMAIN COMMITTED
TO FIND WAYS. IS SOLUTION ADDING
ALLUSION THAT CAN ADDRESS SOME
OF THEIR CONCERNS WHILE ALSO
PROTECTING TAXPAYERS. TODAY WE
HAVE. AN ALEXANDER FROM THE
NATIONAL RESOURCE DEFENSE
COUNCIL AND MELISSA ROMERO FROM
CAMP CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL.
VOTERS TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. VERY GOOD- WILL MOVE
ON TO YOUR LEAD TO YOUR LEAD
SUPPORT TESTIMONY SO I THINK
LEAD SUPPORT NUMBER ONE IS- MISS
ALEXANDER HE WITH US. YEAH GOOD
MORNING MORNING. YOUR CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- ANALYSTS AND THERE
APPEAR TREATING WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL AND
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT SB TWELVE
NINETY FIVE. L. DESIGNED DROPPED
THE WARMEST CHALLENGED
CALIFORNIA FACES AND- IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN COULD COUNCIL SCIENCE
AND TECHNOLOGY. AT THE
CALIFORNIA HAS FIVE THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY WELL OUT
BIBLE OPERATOR THAT WILL COST
MONTHLY HALF A BILLION DOLLARS
TO BE A FIGURE THAT FAR EXCEEDS
THE FEDERAL FUNDING COMING TO
CALIFORNIA FOR WORKING WELL. HOW
RECENT COST ESTIMATE COMMITTEE
WELL THE HIGHER AND WHILE I'M
READING IT IN THE NET A LARGE
VOLUME OF GREENHOUSE GASES AND
OTHER AIR POLLUTION THAT HARMS
SURROUNDING CITIES. AND THE
PROBLEM IS ONLYGOING TO GET
WORSE OVER TIME CALIFORNIA'S OIL
PRODUCTION HAS BEEN HEADING
DOWNWARDS WITH DECADES OF THE
GET HARDER AND HARDER TO EXTRACT
CRUDE FOR MARCH AGING FIELD. AS
WELL LASSEN LAST ECONOMIC
MARGINAL THEY ARE OFTEN SOLD TO
LEFT BIBLE OPERATORS WHO ARE
MORE LIKELY TO WALK AWAY FROM
THEIR OBLIGATIONS PROPERLY
PLUGGING ABANDONED THEM
ALTERNATELY IF CALIFORNIANS LOSE
OVERTIME FOR THE PLACES FILE
CLEAN ENERGY COURSES MANY MORE
WORKERS WELL I THINK YOU CAN BE
REALLY. I CHALLENGES CONFIRMED
IN WE GET STARTED NOW IMPROPERLY
. STRUCTURE SB TWO NINETY IS A
HOUSING STEP IN THAT DIRECTION
WE LOOK THINKING. COOPER EFFORT
TO CRAFTING FINAL LICENSE PLATE
. ACTUALLY URGE YOUR OUT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESS ADAM KNOW THE HOW MUCH
TIME WE HAVE LEFT BUT- ABOUT A
MINUTE A HALF MINUTES FROM.
YOU'RE A MEMBER MOLECULAR WITH.
BUYER VOTER HERE TO NEED SUPPORT
OF TWELVE NINETY FIVE. AT ME
PRODUCTION THE- IN THE STATE
MAKE THE NECKLACE SHIFT AWAY
ARTICLE ON FUEL. YOU MUST PLAN
PROPER AND COULD. AREN'T ON HOOK
BOOK YOU HI THE FIFTH SEEDED
WITH DECOMMISSIONING WELL. WE
NEED TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO
COLLECT MORE AND THE OIL. MEDIA
OF A THIRD IN ORDER TO MATCH
EXPECT BETTER AND STATE DAHLE.
THAT TO CLEAN UP OR BEEN
ABANDONED WELL OUT AT TWELVE
NINETY FIVE PROVIDE EXACT THAT.
CRITICAL THE CALIFORNIA TO
ENSURE PEOPLE PAYS PRINCIPLE BY
THE- POLICY DECISION. THAT THE
OIL AND WITH. FOR STATE THE
PARKING WELCOME AT THE WHICH
HEARD FROM PUBLIC HEALTH SAFETY
AND ENVIRONMENTAL PROBLEM IN A
TIMELY MANNER. BUT THE BIG
FEDERAL MULLIN CONSISTENT AND
BOTH LEADERSHIP HOLDING CLEARLY
CANNIBAL CAN YOU LINK TO ENSURE
THAT HELP ME TAXPAYERS. ARE NOT
LEFT BUT THE BILL FOR IT VERY
POLLUTION THAT HARMS OUR HEALTH
AND WHAT FOR CONCRETE. THAT
TODAY FOR AT THE NINETY FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MUCH- WE
WILL TURN TO WEEK SEVEN A QUORUM
WELL WE HAVE SOME MEMBER HERE
THE- I BELIEVE WE DO. HELLO SO
LET'S PAUSE FOR ONCE FOR TAKE
GENERAL SO HAS. AND ESTABLISH A
QUORUM- CHIEF CONCERN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. STERN HERE STERN
HERE JONES ALLEN EGGMAN. EGGMAN
HERE GROWS HERTZBERG- HERE HUESO
LAYERED HERE LARRY HEARING LOW
MOAN HERE MON HERE YEAH FIVE WE
HAVE A QUORUM GREAT- WE HAVE A
QUORUM- MODERATOR WE'RE DONE
WITH THE MAIN PRESENTATIONS CAN
WE TURN TO LINES AND GET A
GENERAL SUPPORT TESTIMONY IF YOU
COULD OPEN THE LINES IN. CALL
THEM INDIVIDUALLY AND WE'RE JUST
GONNA HAVE NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. THANK YOU
ARE MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWELVE NINETY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE FILED BY ZERO. TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR S. B. TWELVE NINETY
FIVE LIKE FORTY THREE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M SURE MEMBERS BRAND
ALSO SEE CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
. THANK YOU NEXT. NEXT WE WILL
GO TO ONE EIGHTY THREE YOU ARE
OPEN. THIS IS JANET TALKED FOR
THREE FIFTY DOLLARS. VALLEY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU JANET- AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
FOR S. B. TWELVE NINETY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS%
TIME FIND EIGHTY THREE. YOU ARE
UP PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE. EIGHTY
THREE WOULD YOU PRESS ONE ZERO
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY. AND ONE MOMENT WE ARE
HAVING A COUPLE MORE QUEUE UP.
ONE SIXTY FOR YOUR OPEN. I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THE A BILL- JERRY
ANDERSON WITH YOUR PRODUCTION
SOLUTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RIGHT NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS A DOCTOR WHAT
THE SCHOOL THE CHALLENGES FOR
BURIAL FOR SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY
WANT TO GIVE OUR STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
RIGHT EIGHTEEN YOUR OPEN. YEAH
LONG BEFORE WORK OKAY RIGHT
GRABBED ONE TO TWELVE ONE THANK
YOU. AND LINE ONE TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IF I'D LIKE TO
SUPPORT- FC EIGHT I AM A RETIRED
FAMILY AND WE'D LIKE TO PASS OUR
HOME ON TO OUR CHILDREN AND ALSO
WE DEFINITELY DEFINITELY SUPPORT
THE FIREFIGHTERS AND I THINK
THAT WE APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
BUT YOUR WERE ON THE FIRST
MEASURE SB TWELVE NINETY FIVE
BUT THANK YOU SO MUCH WILL MOVE
ON SB TWELVE NINETY FIVE OR X.
ON OIL AND GAS DESERTED WELLS
AND FACILITIES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I DON'T HAVE. WE LOOK
AT ONLINE OR AT LEAST BUT- AND
THE FINAL REMINDER WE WILL- GO
AHEAD HIT ONE ZERO IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. TWELVE NINETY FIVE AT THIS
TIME SB TWELVE NINETY FIVE.
MISTER CHAIR NOBODY ELSE'S
QUEUING UP. OKAY THANK YOU-
SEEING NO SUPPORT IN OUR HEARING
ROOM AT THIS POINT- WILL MOVE ON
TO OPPOSITION I BELIEVE WE HAVE
ONE LEAD OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
MISTER- WELL IN TIME IS THAT
RIGHT. OKAY ONE TIME. PLEASE A
YOU'VE GOT. TO GET THREE MINUTES
RIGHT GERMAN PERSON ONE TIME
FROM THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL ALL THIS
BILL ENDS THE PRACTICE OF CAL
JIM CREDITING PRODUCERS THEIR
UNSPENT FEES FOR THE REMEDIATION
OF ORPHAN WELLS ANNUALLY IF THE
BALANCE OF FUNDS- PRODUCERS
DEPOSIT INTO THE O. G. G. A. F.
IS NOT REFUNDED TO PRODUCERS
ANNUALLY CAL JIM HAS NO
INCENTIVE TO SPEND THE FULL
AMOUNT EACH YEAR. WE BELIEVE
PRODUCER SHOULD BE CREDITED YEAR
OVER YEAR FOR FUNDS NOT SPENT
ANNUALLY PLUGGING- ORPHAN WELLS
A SETTLEMENT SB FORTY SEVEN WAS
PASSED AND SIGNED JUST LAST YEAR
RAISING FEES ON PRODUCERS- FROM
ONE MILLION TO FIVE MILLION
ANNUALLY- WE BELIEVE THAT YOU
OUGHT TO GIVE CAL JIM SOME TIME
TO SEE IF THEY HAVE THIS PROPER
STAFFING IN PLACE TO ACTUALLY
SPEND FIVE MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR THEY'VE ACTUALLY NEVER DONE
THAT. IN A CALENDAR YEAR. THIS
BILL IT ALSO FORCED PRODUCERS TO
MATCH DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR
POTENTIALLY UP TO TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WHICH THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS PROPOSING
TO ACCELERATE. ORPHAN WELL
REMEDIATION USING GENERAL FUND
SURPLUS DOLLARS THAT'S THE
FIRST. STEP IS PRODUCER MEMBERS
CANNOT EVEN GET NEW WELL PERMITS
APPROVED BY CAL JIM TO DRILL IN
EXISTING. LONG TERM OIL FIELDS
IN ORDER TO PAY TO RE MEDIATE
OUR OWN WELL STOCK LET ALONE
PAID AN ASTRONOMICAL TWO HUNDRED
MILLION MORE SO. CURRENT FUNDING
IS AS FOLLOWS FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS INTO THE O. G. A. F.
FROM PRODUCERS AND THE PER
BARREL FEE. THERE IS ALSO
SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
HIT TO OFF. HOWEVER IN TWENTY
TWENTY DEPARTMENT FINANCE RATED
TEN MILLION DOLLARS OUT OF THE
HIP OFF- IN A SPENDING ON
GENERAL FUND PURPOSES UNRELATED
TO THE REMEDIATION OF WELLS
WHICH IS A PROBLEM FOR US
BECAUSE WE DEPOSITED THAT MONEY
IN THERE. THROUGH THE IDYLLWILD
MANAGEMENT PLAN. FINANCE CLAIMS
THEY'RE GOING TO REIMBURSE THOSE
FUNDS ABOUT TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
WE WONDER WHY NOT THIS YEAR. WHY
NOT NOW. PLUGGING HOUSE WELLS IS
SUCH A JOB PRIORITY FOR THE
STATE. THEN FINANCE SHOULD
REFUND THOSE FUNDS IMMEDIATELY-
THEN THERE'S AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY NINE THE IDYLLWILD
MANAGED PLAN REGIME WHICH WAS
ESTABLISHED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
WHICH THE OIL. THREE COOPERATED
WITH. THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ON- OIL PRODUCES
A REQUIRED TO REMEDIATE A
PERCENTAGE OF THEIR OWN WELL
STOCK EASING THEIR OWN MONEY
ANNUALLY. FOR THEIR REQUIRED TO
IDENTIFY MARGINAL WELLS AND PAY
FEES INTO THE HEAD OFFICE THAT'S
WHERE. THE SEVENTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN GROWING. IS COMING
FROM THAT IS CURRENTLY IN THE
HEAD WALK RIGHT NOW SO HERE'S
THE POINT. THE BEST WAY TO
ENSURE THE STATE DOES NOT END UP
WITH ORPHAN WELLS IS TO ALLOW
OIL PRODUCERS. TO CONTINUE
PRODUCING CRUDE OIL THE
CALIFORNIA DEMANDS EVERYDAY
USING CALIFORNIA WORKERS SO
PRODUCERS CAN PLUG THEIR OWN.
WELLS USING THEIR OWN MONEY. IN
CONCLUSION ON TOP OF ALL THIS
FUNDING THE BY THE MINISTRATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL ASCENDING
UPWARDS OF ANOTHER FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO CALIFORNIA
FOR THIS VERY SAME PURPOSE.
MEMBERS THERE IS PLENTY OF MONEY
FOR DEALING WITH ORPHAN WELLS.
THIS BILL IS PREMATURE- AT A
TIME WHEN WITH WITH COUNT WHEN
CAL JIM HAS A LARGER STAFF THAN
EVER BEFORE. WHICH IS PAID
41100% BY OUR FEES. GET CALCIUM
IS MORE DYSFUNCTIONAL ALSO THAN
EVER BEFORE THEY ARE SITTING ON
OVER ONE I COULD ASK YOU JUST TO
WRAP UP QUICKLY OKAY. THANK YOU
SIR YEP ON A THOUSAND PERMITS TO
DRILL SOME OF WHICH ARE FOUR
YEARS OLD- WE WOULD APPRECIATE
YOUR NO VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER ONE TIME- TO HAVE ANY
OTHER A GENERAL OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM.
WHO IS TESTIFIED SEEING NINE-
WILL GO TO THE LINE'S MODERATOR
WOULD YOU MIND OPENING THE LINES
IN CALLING OPPOSITION WITNESSES
JUST FOR NAME. AFFILIATION A
POSITION ON THE BILL. AS MR
GERAS STATED PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
TWELVE NINETY FIVE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONE
MOMENT STRUCTURE WE HAVE A FEW
QUEUING UP. FOR ANYBODY UP BUT
YET THAT ONE FALL BY ZERO SO THE
AT T. AFTER YOU CAN GIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER QUICKLY IN PLACE YOU
BACK INTO THE QUEUE. I WILL
BEGIN TODAY WITH LINE EIGHTY
ONE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CARING MEMBERS ALL THE EURO
REPRESENTING WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION WE
CURRENTLY HAVE A TWEENER WHICH
IS THE NO POSITION ON THE BILL.
AND MISTER CHAIR WE READ WAS
ADDRESSED AND CAL GRANT
SUBSISTING EXPENDITURE FORTY IF
THEY RECEIVE THE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND MONEY-
THE APPROPRIATION AS YOU KNOW
WAS IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
HOWEVER IF IT'S THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT TO INCREASE ASSESSMENT ON
OPERATORS WHICH BUT WOULD BE IN
OPPOSE POSITION. WHERE WE READ
THE BILL BALLOTS AT ADDRESSING
THE EXISTING EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OVER CAL JAM IF IN
FACT THEY RECEIVE GENERAL FUND
MONEY THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND WE INDULGE THAT TWEENER
POSITION WITH A LITTLE EXTENDED
TIME BUT EVERYONE ELSE WISHING
TESTIFYING OPPOSITION- JUST NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION THANK YOU.
WHY LEVIN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHEN
ELEVEN ARE YOU MUTED. HELLO
YOU'RE WITH US- WANTED CURLY
HERE I OPPOSE THIS BILL ARMENIAN
OIL AND GAS READ THE CONSULTANT
THAT HAS GROWN UP MY ENTIRE LIFE
IN CALIFORNIA THERE MUST BE
VALLEY OKAY PRESHEAF YOU THANK
YOU- NAME POSITION AND
AFFILIATION THANK YOU SO MUCH
ALL. NEXT WE WILL ALIGN FORTY
YOUR OPEN. HI MIKE NUMBER WITH
PREMIER RESOURCE MANAGEMENT I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
I AM A KERN COUNTY OPERATOR AT
THE INDIA RESIDENTS OKAY GREAT
THANKS A LOT. NEXT THE CLOVER
LINE FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. YES THIS IS MIKE BAIRD I'M A
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT SINCE
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE AND I AM-
OPPOSED TO THE MEASURE OKAY
THANK YOU SIR NEXT. AND A FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO S.
B. TWELVE NINETY FIVE I'M THIRTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT PART OF
THE OIL PRODUCERS ALLIANCE. I
OPPOSED THE BILL THANK YOU NEXT
. WHY ONE THIRTY SIX YOU ARE
OPEN. YES GEORGE FORMER GENERAL
PRODUCT AND SERVICE. I MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE EXHAUSTED THE
QUEUE OKAY VERY GOOD- SEEING NO
MORE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT I WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE MEMBERS- MEMBERS QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FOR THE AUTHOR- YES AN
EARLIER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SOME. I THINK HE HE THERE'S A
GLOBAL ISSUE HERE WHICH IS IF WE
WERE TRYING TO DEAL WITH.WHICH
ARE SHORT TERM POLLUTANTS AND
METHANE. LEAKAGE FROM EXISTING
CAP WELLS COULD ACCOUNT 49213%
OF THE STATE'S WEEK AGENTS SO IN
TERMS OF OUR CLIMATE EFFORTS
THIS IS VERY SIGNIFICANT AND I
WANT TO SALUTE THE OFFER. FOR
THE FACT THAT SHE'S WILLING TO
TAKE THIS ON I THINK THAT THE
THERE WERE SOME PEOPLE IN THE
DEBATE TALKING PAST EACH OTHER
AROUND ONE ISSUE. AND THAT WAS
THE ISSUE OF FUNDING BECAUSE
THERE WAS AN ASSUMPTION MADE.
THAT THIS JUST APPLIED TO ALL
EXISTING FUNDING BUT AT THE SAME
TIME. THERE'S FEDERAL MONEY
THAT'S BEEN ALLOCATED. AND THE
IF THERE IS A TIMING ISSUE ABOUT
WHEN THE MONEY WILL BE AVAILABLE
I WAS GONNA ASK THE AUTHOR. TO
WALK US THROUGH THAT WHAT WHAT
BECAUSE IT MAKES TOTAL SENSE TO
RAISE THE CAP BEFORE GETTING
OUTSIDE MONEY. ARE SO WALK US
THROUGH THE FUNDING ISSUES SO WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THANK YOU AND
YES SO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAS ALREADY ALLOCATED SOME
FUNDING FOR THIS AND THAT
FEDERAL MONEY HAS BEEN ALLOCATED
THROUGH THE BUDGET WHAT WILL BE
A TIMING ISSUE THAT WILL NEED TO
GET WORKED OUT IN IN IN IN A
POLICY CONVERSATION SHOULD THIS
BILL MOVE FORWARD. IS THE PIECE
FOR CAL JAM DOES AN ANNUAL
ASSESSMENT AND THE BUDGET
ALLOCATION IS ACTUALLY NOT
ALIGNED WHEN CAL JIM DOES THEIR
ASSESSMENT IS A DIFFERENT TIMING
THAN WHEN THE BUDGET- SO I WANT
TO RECOGNIZE THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WILL HAVE TO
WORK OUT AS THIS BILL
POTENTIALLY. AT MOVES FORWARD-
THAT THE REASON THAT YOU KNOW
IT'S BEEN SAID THAT TO GET YOU
KNOW CAL CHEN HAS NOT DONE MORE
THAN FIVE MILLION WHAT WE DIDN'T
AUTHORIZE THAT WE'VE NEVER
AUTHORIZED THEM TO DO MORE AND
PART OF THIS CONVERSATION IS
ABOUT AUTHORIZING TO DO MORE.
ADDITIONALLY YOU KNOW THROUGH
PASSED TALK ABOUT COLLECTING YOU
KNOW A ROLLING FUN- BECAUSE
CALTRAIN HAS TO BE SO SPECIFIC
IN HOW THEY FIX THESE- WELLS
WHEN THEY'RE ONLY CAPTIVE THEY
WERE CAPPED AT ONE MILLION THERE
NOW CAPPED AT FIVE MILLION. AT
WHERE THEY CAN ACTUALLY GO OVER
BUDGET SO THEY'VE HAD TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO ADDRESS THESE WELLS-
AND STAY UNDER BUDGET TO BE ABLE
TO DO THIS SO WHAT WE'RE ASKING
IS THAT THAT REMAINDER BECAUSE
IT'S NEVER GOING TO BE A PERFECT
NUMBER I MEAN IF YOU'VE EVER
DONE BUDGETING FOR AGENCIES JUST
NEVER PERFECT. EVEN FIVE
MILLION- THAT THAT MONEY THEN
GETS PUT INTO AN ACCOUNT WHERE
WE CAN COLLECT UP TO TWO HUNDRED
MILLION TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS-
WHERE IS ALL OF THAT YOU KNOW
THIS THIS COST COMING FROM AN
END AT WHITE SUCH HIGH NUMBERS.
WELL BECAUSE WE'VE RECEIVE
WEAVER C. AND- OF THE LAST FEW
YEARS THAT THIS CAN COST THE
STATE AND- FROM FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION TO FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
TOTALLY GET THAT THERE'S THAT'S
A BIG BIG RANGE AND THERE'S A
LOT OF DEBATE THERE. BUT ONE OF
THE THINGS I'VE BEEN DOING OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS IS TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET THAT TO A
HIGHER NUMBER WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
TO FIVE BILLION. HOW ARE WE
GOING TO GET THAT TO A HIGHER
NUMBER AND HOW ARE WE GOING TO
SHARE THE RESPONSIBILITY BETWEEN
TAXPAYERS AND- STRAIGHT. UP TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT- AND IT'S
BEEN VERY DIFFICULT WE'VE DONE
AT ONE MILLION OR FIVE MILLION
AT THE TIME. BUT AT THE RATE
WE'RE GOING I MEAN IT'S GOING TO
TAKE US IF WE'RE DOING FIVE
MILLION AT A TIME. A HUNDRED
YEARS WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
HERE- AND I THINK THAT. THE
REASON. THAT YOU KNOW I WENT
FROM A BILL LAST YEAR TO ALSO. A
BILL THIS YEAR IS BECAUSE OF.
ALLOCATION THEY ARE PUTTING
MONEY INTO THIS. AND AT LEVELS
WE HAVEN'T SEEN BEFORE WE WERE
NOT ABLE TO HAVE LEGISLATIVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WE'RE GONNA
GET TWO HUNDRED TO FOUR HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO BE ABLE TO DO
THIS. BRING A POSITION TO NOW
HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS
LEVERAGE FEDERAL LEVERAGE WHAT
WE HAVE. I'M NOT GOING TO
COMMENT ON STATE AGENCIES AND
THEIR EFFICIENCY AND WHAT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DID OR DID
NOT DO. I THINK THAT'S BEST
ADDRESSED WITH THE AGENCIES AND
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT IS
ADDRESSED THROUGH THIS
PARTICULAR POLICY BILL. THERE
ARE A AND THEN LET ME ASK A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION TO THAT.
BECAUSE ONE OF THE WITNESSES
SAID JEEZ CAL JAMISON. STAFFED
UP TO DO THIS BECAUSE- A AND
THAT'S BECAUSE THEY HAVE A FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR LIMIT IF WE
ACTUALLY GET A FEDERAL. PATIENT
AND LIST THE LIMIT TO
ACCOMMODATE FEDERAL ALLOCATION
THEN WE'RE SENDING A MESSAGE CAL
JIM THAT THEY SHOULD STAFF UP.
ACCORDINGLY AS OPPOSED TO. USING
THE FACT THAT THEY'VE STEPPED UP
FOR A CERTAIN LEVEL AT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR NOT
ACCEPTING THE FEDERAL ALLOCATION
AND STAFFING. WE GET IT IS. THAT
THE THAT'S ABSOLUTELY THE AND I
THAT THAT'S PART OF A OF THIS
CON. AS WELL I ALSO WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT THIS APPROACH- IS
AN APPROACH THAT AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
CAME OUT WITH THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE- OIL WELL
ABANDONMENT AND REMEDIATION-
ANALYSIS THAT WAS PUBLISHED IN
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY TWO SO WE-ARE A LINE WHERE WHERE THE L. A.
L. IS TELLING US. THAT WE SHOULD
BE DOING IN TERMS OF THE SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY BETWEEN INDUSTRY
AND TAXPAYERS- SO THIS IS AGAIN
AN ISSUE THAT'S BEEN WE HAVE THE
CCSD REPORT WE HAVE ELLIE- I
MEAN WE HAVE MANY WHO HAVE SAID
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY A DIRECTION-
THAT WE SHOULD BE GOING IN. AND
THEN MISTER CHAIR COMMENT OF I
THINK THAT THIS EXCHANGE ED THE
PRESENTATION AND EVEN DIFFERENT
PIECES OF THE TESTIMONY CHAU
THAT THIS IS A MOVING TARGET R.
AND THE QUESTION IS DO WE WISH
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND DO WE
WISH TO MAXIMIZE THE RESOURCES
THAT MIGHT BE COMING FROM OTHER
SOURCES AND I THINK THE ANSWER
IS YES AND- THE REAL ISSUE IS
THAT THE AUTHOR. IN TAKING THIS
ON WHICH IN SOME WAYS THANK
WORSE ARE GIVES US THE VEHICLE
TO ADDRESS THESE AS THE
DIFFERENT PIECES FALL INTO PLACE
SO AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME I
WILL BE HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL
OKAY WILL RECOGNIZE THAT IS A
MOTION- DO ANY OTHER MEMBERS
HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS-
SEEING NONE I'LL MAKE A QUICK
COMMENT THE ONE OTHER POINT I
WOULD JUST READ. IN THE IT WAS
NOT IN THE AND NOW. BUT A LITTLE
BIT OF THE BACK. IN AB ONE
REASONS I ATTENDED EMPATHIZE
SOMEWHAT WITH THE INDEPENDENT
PRODUCERS CONCERNS. IS THAT THE
INDUSTRY ITSELF. EVAN IS
STRUCTURED IN SUCH A WAY THAT.
ALL OPERATORS. LIABILITIES CEASE
PRIOR TO NINETEEN NINETY SIX
THANKS TO THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE BACK THEN- BELIEVE
IT WAS A GYM COSTABILE- NOW
CONGRESSMAN COSTA- EXEMPTING ALL
PREVIOUS OWNERS FROM LIABILITY.
AND SO THE INDEPENDENCE OF
TAKING CONTROL OF THOSE ASSETS
GOING FORWARD- END UP BEING THE
SOLE BEARS A RESPONSIBILITY- AND
IF THEY GO BANKRUPT IT'S ON THE
TAXPAYERS SO I THINK PART OF.
PART OF BEING ABLE TO LAND THIS
ISSUE IS ALSO MAKING SURE WE
HAVE AN EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION
OF RESPONSIBILITIES- BETWEEN THE
INDEPENDENCE IN THE MAJORS WHO-
EXTRACTED BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OUT OF THOSE ASSETS PARTY NINETY
SIX BUT NOW. BECAUSE OF A
UNFORTUNATE QUIRK IN CALIFORNIA
LAW- ARE THEMSELVES EXEMPTION
THAT LIABILITY GRANTED WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF PLUGGING
AND ABANDONING GOING ON WITHIN
THE MAJOR FIELDS OF THE LARGER
OPERATORS BUT- THAT DOESN'T DO
MUCH TO DEAL WITH THOSE- THE
SMALL ONES PARTICULARLY THOSE
CLOSEST TO COMMUNITIES
PARTICULARLY THOSE COME. CLOSE
TO COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND-
PLACES POVERTY- WE HAD A- WELL
JUST- GO OUT ON US A FEW WEEKS
BACK IN THE MIDDLE OF L. A.
LITERALLY BEHIND. THEM MY SISTER
IN LAWS HOUSE AND THE SHOULDER
WE GO TO EVERY WEEKEND AND- YOU
KNOW LET'S JUST SAY THERE'S A
LOT OF ALL INFRASTRUCTURE OUT
THERE AND WE ALL GOT TO
COLLECTIVELY- PITCH IN AND DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT SO I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR BRING A
BILL FORWARD IN OUR WORK WITH
THE COMMITTEE AND- WILL BE HERE
TO HELP YOU GOING FORWARD TO-
IT'S A MOTION FROM SENATOR
LAYERED- WHICH IS. DO YOU PASS
BUT- FIRST REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
A- BUT BEFORE WE TAKE THAT ON.
THE ROLL CALL WILL ALLOW
CINNAMON CLOVES. THANK YOU CHAIR
AND I DO WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND YOUR LEADERSHIP I
MEAN THIS IS A CONVERSATION THAT
WE'VE ALL BEEN HAVING FOR A VERY
LONG TIME- AND IT'S COMPLICATED
AND IT'S HARD- BUT THAT YOU KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF THESE WELLS OUT
THERE THAT HAVE BEEN SITTING
THERE THAT HAVEN'T BEEN USED-
AND THAT WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO. YOU KNOW ABANDONED AND
PROPERLY UP PLUG IT IN A WAY
THAT MAKES THE MOST SENSE AT FOR
THE HEALTH OF OUR COMMUNITIES- I
WILL CONTINUE. WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND THIS IS A
DIFFERENT AREA WHERE WE HAVE
THESE FEDERAL ALLOCATIONS AND SO
IT'S A REYES DIFFERENT. KINDS
OF. ISSUES THAT WEREN'T AROUND
IN PREVIOUS YEARS- AND I WILL DO
THE BEST TO MOVE FORWARD BUT YOU
KNOW BALANCING REALLY AS THE
INDUSTRY COMMITMENT AND
PARTNERSHIP HERE. BUT WITH
TAXPAYERS PROTECTING TAXPAYERS-
A AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I
THINK HAS BEEN AT THE CORE OF
WHAT I'M DOING SO WITH THAT- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANKS SO MUCH MOTIONS TO PASS
REFER TO COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS
SHE CONTEMPLATES COLOR. FILE
ITEM AS B. TWO NINETY. MOTIONS
PASSED APPROVE. STERN STERN HI
JONES ALLEN EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE
GROVE HERTZBERG HI HERTZBERG HI
HUESO LAYERED I LAYERED ON A
LOAN HI LIMON HI. VERY GOOD THE
MEASURES FIVE VOTES WE'LL LEAVE
IT ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MISTER CHAIR YES WE HAVE
THREE ITEMS ON PROPOSED CONSENT
LIKE TO MOVE THOSE ITEMS YES
ITEM TO S. B. EIGHT THIRTY TO
ITEM SEVEN SP TEN TWENTY EIGHT
AT ELEVEN S. B. THIRTEEN SEVENTY
TWO I WOULD MOVE THE CONSENT
ITEMS VERY GOOD IT'S A MOTION
FROM CENTER LATER ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CHIEF CONSOLE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE ITEM TO SB EIGHT
THREE TWO FILE ITEM SEVEN S. B.
TEN TWENTY EIGHT FILE ITEM
ELEVEN S. B. THIRTEEN SEVENTY
TWO STERN AYE STERN RA JONES
ALLEN EGGMAN EGGMAN I GROVE-
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG ARE WAY
WHERE HI THERE ARE YOU LIMÓN I
MON AYE. VERY GOOD FIVE VOTES
WILL EVEN CALL SEE WE HAVE A
MAJORITY LEADER READY TO PRESENT
RIGHT EARLY ON ITEM THREE. SB
TEN SIXTY TWO THE FIXING THE
FIREFIGHTER SHORTAGE ACTIVE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO MR MAJORITY.
LEADER IF YOU'RE READY FOR US.
THE TO HEAR FROM. FIGURE OUT HOW
TO GET. ALL GETTING OUT ALL
RIGHT YEAH EXACTLY WHERE TOTAL
HOSED RAFTER GOOD STUFF. A I
MISTER HERE THROUGH THE GOOD TO
SEIZE IN PERSON FROM ASIDE WANNA
A MOMENT THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
THE CHAIR CHAIR HAS BEEN DRUG
INVOLVED IN THIS BILL HE'S BEEN
DIRECTLY INVOLVED IN THIS ISSUE
FOR MANY YEARS AS WELL I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK YOUR
PARTNERSHIP. AND OF COURSE YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND ALSO WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO YOUR STAFF AS WELL
AND OF COURSE WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. AS CALIFORNIA FACES
LONGER AND LONGER FIRE SEASONS
EACH AND EVERY YEAR IT'S VITAL
THAT WE ACKNOWLEDGE AND SUPPORT
THE IMPORTANT SERVICE. WHO OF
THOSE WHO PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE
LINE EACH YEAR A YEAR AND THAT'S
CALIFORNIA FIREFIGHTERS. NOW I
WANT TO BE HONEST CALIFORNIA IS
FACING A FIREFIGHTER SHORTAGE WE
CAN'T WAIT ANOTHER YEAR TO FIX
IT THE SEVERE SHORTAGES THREATEN
THE LIVES AND HEALTH OF CAL FIRE
FIREFIGHTERS IN EVERY CORNER OF
THIS GREAT STATE. LEGISLATION
BEFORE US IT'S BIPARTISAN IN
PROPOSES A MODERN DAY STAFFING
PLAN FOR CAL FIRE THAT INCLUDES
THE FOLLOWING THE IMMEDIATE
HIRING OF ADDITIONAL. ONE
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED TWENTY FUR
FIREFIGHTERS. ENOUGH THREE SIXTY
FOR NEW FULL TIME FIREFIGHTER.
TO GET FULL STAFF UNITS ON ITS-
ENGINES WITH THREE PER RANGING A
MINIMUM. IT'S AND TO NOTE THAT
MOST LOCAL AGENCIES ALREADY HAVE
THREE OR MORE FIREFIGHTERS THE
ENGINE. FEDERAL FEDERAL AID IN
SOME PLACES HAVE FOR ON AN
ENGINE IN THE STATE. MINIMUM OF
THREE AND A HALF. IT'S CRITICAL
THAT WE MOVE FORWARD WITH CAL
FIRE AS WELL. ADVANCING THE
MANDATED MINIMUM FOR
FIREFIGHTING HAND CREWS WOULD
ALSO BE IN THE BILL. THAT WOULD
INCLUDE ALL THE ON GOING FIRE
CREWS FOR CALIFORNIA'S SIX
CONTRACT COUNTIES AS WELL. NOW
INCLUDE KERN. LOS ANGELES MARIN.
ORANGE SANTA BARBARA AND VENTURA
OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS. THIS
BILL WOULD ALSO ADVANCE A MODERN
DAY STAFFING PLAN FOR
CALIFORNIA- THAT WOULD FOCUS ON
STAFFING AND INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS IN THE MONTHS AND YEARS TO
COME. DUE TO STAFFING SHORTAGES
WHAT WERE SEEN EACH AND EVERY
YEAR. FIREFIGHTERS IN CAL FIRE
WORKING LONG OVERTIME HOURS.
MANY ARE GOING ON FIRE MISSIONS
FORTY DAYS IN A ROW WITH NO DAYS
OFF. AND WE DEPLOYED
FIREFIGHTERS AS WE ALL KNOW.
BECAUSE EACH OF YOU HAVE HAD
CATASTROPHIC FIRES IN YOUR
DISTRICT. THEY'RE WORKING
SOMATIC CONDITIONS. WORKING AWAY
FROM FAMILIES. IN ITS LEADING TO
SIGNIFICANT STRESS THE MIDDLE
HEALTH CHALLENGE. OR THE LAST
FOUR YEARS. URBAN FIFTY FOUR
THOUSAND MENTAL HEALTH CALLS
MADE BY CAL IRE FIREFIGHTERS IN
THE STATE MENTAL HEALTH HOTLINES
. FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND. WE HAVE
TO PROTECT THE MENTAL HEALTH AND
SAFETY THESE COURAGEOUS WOMEN
AND MEN. BY BUILDING A
FOUNDATION FOR ENHANCE STAFF.
BONFIRES ARE IMPACTING OUR
EVERYDAY LIFE NOW IN THE GOLDEN
STATE IMPACTING AIR QUALITY IN
CRITICAL WATERSHEDS WILDLIFE
ALONG WITH OUR VERY OWN HOMES
AND BUSINESSES AND THAT'S WHY
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY A
BROAD COALITION OF FOLKS ON THIS
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS ITS THAT
YOU'RE OVER HALF OF THE STATE
SENATE. IS SUPPORTING THIS BILL
YOUR CO AUTHORS SIXTEEN
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS ALIKE ARE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL IS CO AUTHORS I WANT
TO SAY IN PARTICULAR THANK YOU
SO MUCH TO SHARE STERN BY
TEACHER JONES SENATOR GROVE
CENTER HERTZBERG LOCAL AUTHORS
IN THE MEASURE. AND LOOK ON IT
RIGHT HERE AND SAY THIS
FIREFIGHTERS ON THE FRONT LINES
PROTECTING US IN OUR COMMUNITIES
EACH AND EVERY YEAR IT'S NOW
TIME FOR US TO BE A STAND UP FOR
THEM AND THE WELL BEING OF THEIR
FAMILIES THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED
BY OF COURSE CAL FIRE LOCAL
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY ONE AND WITH
US TODAY MISTER CHAIR WE'VE TIM
EDWARDS THE PRESIDENT OF CAL
FIRE LOCAL TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
ONE I'M GRATEFUL FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP. AS WELL AS DOUG
SUPERS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR. AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH TO LOOK
TO OUR LEAD WITNESS IN SUPPORT-
BELIEVE THEY'RE ON THE LINE FOR
ONE OF THE WITNESSES AND THEN
ONCE IN THE ROOM. SO FIRST WILL
TURN TO. TO MISTER EDWARDS-
PRISON EDWARDS THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US THIS MORNING AND FOR
YOUR SERVICE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. YES GOOD MORNING CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE GOT YOUR
LATIN CLEAR. OKAY GOOD MORNING
HEARING COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THEY'RE
MCGUIRE IS AN EXCELLENT JOB
LAYING OUT THE ISSUES SO I WILL
BE BRIEF. CAL BUYER IS AND HAS
THE STORY WE BEEN UNDERSTAFFED.
CAUSING EXTREME STRESS LOAD ON
OUR MEMBERS OF CAL FIRE
FIREFIGHTERS. THE LAST YEAR THAT
HIGHLIGHTED THE ISSUE AND PUT
OUR MEMBERS WORKING THIRTY TO
FORTY DAYS PLUS AWAY FROM HOME.
MULTIPLE TIMES A YEAR. GARDENING
EXTREME STRESS LOW CONTACTED
THEM BUT THEIR FAMILIES ALSO
PHYSICAL OR MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
ARE ON THE RISE IN HERE. BURKE
INTERMINGLE IRIS LAID IT OUT.
EMPLOYEE SUPPORT SERVICE. IT'S
NO SECRET THAT IN THE FIRE
SERVICE. TODAY THAT WILL BE
DIVORCE RATE. ANY SUICIDE THERE
ARE THE RIGHT. CAL ARE LEADING
THE WAY IN MANY WAYS READ THE
FIRED THERE WHEN IT WHOLE UNITED
AND WE EMPIRE. IT IS IN THE
RIGHT TO BRING RELIEF AND THE
BRING BACK ADDITIONAL READ TO
CAL. WE DO NOT WANT LEAD WAY AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DIVORCE RATE FOR
SUICIDE I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
FOR YOUR AYE BUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NOW TRYING TO
AND- THE SECOND LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESS BUT HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM MISTER SUBER'S
WELCOME GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SAID THAT
SHE WAS ONLY HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
MAJORITY LEADER. THE CHAIRMAN
THE COMMITTEE AND OUR BROTHERS
AND SISTERS A CAL FIRE LOCAL
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY ONE FOR
THEIR SUPPORT WORK ON THIS
MEASURE- AS MAJORITY LEADER AND
PRESIDENT EDWARDS NOTED. THE
DEMANDS ON THE FIRE SERVICE ARE
EVER INCREASING THERE ARE. TONS
OF CHALLENGES OUT THERE FROM
WILDFIRES THE DISASTERS TO
EMERGENCY MEDICAL CALLS AND IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT WE HAVE. ROBUST
AND SAFE STAFFING TO ENSURE
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT RESPONSE
TO THESE INCIDENTS IN SUPPORT OF
CALIFORNIANS. BUT ALSO HAVE SAFE
STAFFING SO THAT OUR MEMBERS-
ACROSS THE STATE YOU KNOW CAN
FOCUS ON THEIR HEALTH. THE AND-
DO THEIR JOB IN AN EFFECTIVE WAY
THAT DOESN'T CREATE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF INJURIES AND ILLNESSES
FOR THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER SUPERS I'M
WE'RE GONNA NOW TURN TO GENERAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- ANY IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SEEING NINE WILL
TURN TO THE LINE'S MODERATOR
WOULD YOU MIND OPENING THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES IT WAS TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF. SB TEN SIXTY TWO
AND JUST NAME. AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. THANK YOU
IF YOU WOULD LIKE THAT TEST.
INTO OF SB TEN SIXTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE FILE BUT HE'S
THERE ALL. AND ONE MOMENT MISTER
CHAIR. WE GET A FEW QUEUING OUT
THEY SHOULD BE WITH US
MOMENTARILY FOR ANYBODY ELSE
COULD HELP ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. FOR SB
TEN SIXTY TWO. AND WE'LL BEGIN
WITH ONE ONE A ONE YOU ARE OPEN
. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS IS JENNIFER RALLIED WITH A
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
CALLING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE WERE LINE. SHE'S
MISTER SHARE ARE ONE SIXTY FOR
YOUR OWN GOOD. SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
LET. SIXTY FOUR YOU CAN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY. NOT MOVING
ALONG WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO. HELLO
WELCOME TO HAVE A POSITION ON
THE BILL SB TEN SIXTY TWO. I
WILL I AM OF COURSE I'M FOR THE
FIREFIGHTERS HOWEVER I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK A QUESTION ABOUT I'M
SORRY. IT'S OKAY SORRY ABOUT
THAT WE DO CORPS RIGHT WE'RE
JUST DOING NAME POSITION
AFFILIATION SO WE'LL MOVE ON AND
YOU CAN SUBMIT YOUR TO YOUR
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU. MODERATOR NEXT. THANK YOU
ONE SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN
YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN. THANK YOU I
WISH TO SUPPORT IT I WAS A
FIREFIGHTER BACK IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR SERVICEMEN. NEXT AND
JUST FOUR NINE ONE PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME IF YOU CAN WHEN YOU'RE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT AT LEAST
THAT- I WILL ALIGN ONE SIXTY TO
YOUR OPEN. YES MY NAME IS TRYING
TO REVERSE AND I'M IN FAVOR OF
IT IS C. EIGHT EIGHT. OKAY
YOU'RE ON YOU'RE ON THE WRONG
BILL WILL NURTURE YOUR TESTIMONY
MYSTERIES- WILL MOVE TO SB TEN
SIXTY TWO THOSE IN SUPPORT
WISHIN TESTIFIED NAME AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. AND IS
MISTER CHAIR STATED AT THE FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ZERO ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN SIXTY TWO
SUPPORT ONLY FOR S. B. CAN SIXTY
TWO. AND NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING
UP AT THIS TIME SIR. OKAY VERY
WELL- WILL THEN MOVE TO A
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WE DON'T
HAVE ANY LISTED ON FILE- BUT
LOOK INTO THE HEARING ROOM TO
SEE IF ANYONE WISHES TESTIFIED
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE WILL TURN
TO THE LINES. ONE MODERATE JUST
Q. ANYONE UP OF YOU WOULD. HAVE
WITHIN TESTIFIED OPPOSITION TO
SB TEN SIXTY TWO FOR JUST NAME.
AND AFFILIATION POSITION. IF ANY
THANK YOU. OUR LADY DID
GOVERNMENT'S TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION FOR SB TEN SIXTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE FALL BY ZERO TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO TEN
SIXTY TWO. I AM MISTER CHAIR
NOBODY IS GIVING UP. OKAY VERY
WELL I WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
DICE THAN MEMBERS COMMENTS
QUESTIONED CENTER LAYER YES- I
HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR
AND THAT IS- THIS ALSO SEEMS TO
BE OF A REAL BUDGET ITEM IS
THEIR COMPANION BUDGET ASK THAT
GOES WITH THIS AT THE SAME TIME
IF THERE IS A BE A PARALLEL
BUDGET ASK. FOR THE COMPLETE
HIRING OF ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR FIREFIGHTERS
PLUSES STAFFING STUDY WOULD BE
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLARS. AND AT
THAT WOULD BE FIRST YEAR A
LITTLE LESS ON GOING BUT I'D-
THIS YEAR WOULD BE TOO SO
THERE'S A CHANCE WE COULD ALL
RALLY AROUND THIS IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS AND YOUR BILL WAS
FORCING THAT DECISION. IS THAT.
SAID OKAY. IT IS ENDEMIC. AND
THE CALM IS I WAS LOOKING AROUND
AT MY FELLOW MEMBERS AND ALL OF
YOU WERE SITTING IN THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE SUMMER OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- NINE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE OF MY NEIGHBORS
LOST THEIR HOMES IN THE FIRE
BURNED WITHIN TWO MILES OF US
IN. THE END IT WAS ESSENTIALLY
ON FOUGHT THE FIRST DAYS WHAT
WAS BURNING THROUGH RURAL
RESIDENTIAL AREAS AND THE BIG
ISSUE WAS IS IF THERE WERE A
MILLION ACRES OF FIRES BURNING
ACROSS CALIFORNIA TO SAME TIME
AT THEIR WORK TO RESOURCES AND
IT WAS SUCH THAT OUR CITY FIRE
DEPARTMENT CUT OFF FIREWIND CITY
LIMITS AND WAS JUST ARE FIRED
APARTMENT THERE IF THERE'D BEEN
A BIG WIND YOU WOULD COMMENT AND
I THOUGHT WERE A TEMPERATE.
COASTAL TOWN WITH FOG IN THE
SUMMER AND WE WERE PACKED AND
READY TO GO AS WORLD FOR
NEIGHBORS AND IT'D I GET ASKED
ALL THE TIME IN THE DISK WHAT
ARE YOU DOING ABOUT MAKING SURE
THEY'RE ADEQUATE FAR RESOURCES
SO THAT WE DON'T FACE EXACTLY
THE SITUATION AGAIN AND THIS
BILL ADDRESSES THAT ISSUE
PERFECTLY AND SETS IT OUT REALLY
CLEARLY AND SO I WOULD HOPE THAT
WHEN YOU TAKE AMENDMENTS LIKE.
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR AND I WOULD
BE HAPPY AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
TO MOVE THE BILL THANK YOU SIR
MR TO MOTIONS. LAYERED SAN
HERTZBERG. KNOWS WE- ENGAGE IN
THE ISSUE OF THE- WE HAVE MANY
PURPOSES IN OUR ENDEAVORS AND
THE BEST PUBLIC POLICY OF THOSE
THAT ADDRESS MANY ISSUES SYMBOL
TENUOUSLY. IN ADDITION TO THE
OBVIOUS NEED WITH RESPECT TO
RESOURCE FOR THE FIREFIGHTERS-
AN ADDITION TO THE POINTS MADE
BY. CENTER LAYERED IF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT FOR A MOMENT. THE DATA
SHOWS THAT THESE FIRES THAT KEPT
BURNING PRODUCED WHAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN TWENTY ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION AUTOMOBILES ON THE ROAD.
SO WE HAVE ALL THIS IMPISH
POLICY RELATED TO CLIMATE
CHANGE. AND YET- THAT YOU READ
THE STUDIES FROM CARBON YOU READ
WHAT HAPPENED YESTERDAY FROM THE
INTERNATIONAL. FOLKS IN THE
UNITED NATIONS WHAT THEY SAY
WHAT WE'VE DONE AND HERE'S A
HERE'S AN EXAMPLE WHERE IF WE
COULD PUT A FEW KEY- IT LOOKS
LIKE IT'S A LOT OF MONEY TO EARN
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS. BUT YOU
LOOK AT AT THIS APPROACH FROM A
POLICY PERSPECTIVE NOTCHED TWO
TERMS OF PROTECTING PROPERTY AND
LIVES IN THE ENVIRONMENT ALL THE
OTHER ISSUES. BUT CERTAINLY ON
THE ISSUE OF CLIMATE CHANGE ALL
THE EXTRAORDINARY CONSEQUENCES
SO FOR THAT AND THEN. THE ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION RETURNS I
WANT TO MOVE THE BILL. OKAY THAT
SAID SIR MOTION- FROM CENTER
HURTS- GOOD GROVE IN CENTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR RIGHT I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR VERY
MUCH FOR HIS CONSISTENT AND KIND
AND VERY THOUGHTFUL PROCESS THAT
YOU'VE GONE THROUGH THIS
LEGISLATION WE DO NEED TO MAKE
SURE FIREFIGHTERS ARE TAKING
CARE OF WE DO NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HAVE TIME HOME WITH
THEIR FAMILIES THAT THEY'RE NOT
WORKING EIGHTY DAYS IN A ROW. WE
DO NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT-
MENTAL HEALTH IS A AVAILABLE TO
THEM BECAUSE OF THE STRESSES ON
THEIR JOB AND- I APPRECIATE YOU
ALLOWING ME TO BE A CO AUTHOR ON
THIS. THANK YOU SIR AND I OVER
TO THIS BILL MOVING FORWARD.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU CENTER GROVE
CENTER EGGMAN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I'LL LET JOIN THE CHOIR
OF THINKING FOR THIS WORK I AM I
AM MAYBE THE ONLY ONE UP HERE TO
DATE HAS NOT HAD WILDFIRES IN MY
DISTRICT ALTHOUGH I DID LOSING A
CABIN IN TWENTY TWENTY- I GUESS
MY QUESTION IS AROUND. AND I
ALSO AT THE PROPER TIME LIKE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR- IT. THE
BILL AND EVERYTHING SEEMS TO
INDICATE THAT THAT FIREFIGHTERS
AND WILL BE TAKING ON MORE MORE
OF PREVENTION AND FIREBREAKS.
WHICH IS VITALLY IMPORTANT- IT
BUT- TALK TO ME A LITTLE BIT AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT ALL OF OUR
UTILITIES ARE CAL FIRE EVERYBODY
AND THE ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THAT.
FUNDING AS IT RELATES TO- REALLY
GETTING IN THERE AND CLEANING UP
AND RUNNING THE FIRES. IS THERE
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES BUILT
INTO THIS AND ANY KIND OF WAY-
FOR THE INCREASE FUNDING.
INCREASED RESOURCES TO BE ABLE
TO MATCH THAT WITH- AREAS THAT
HAVE BEEN PROTECTED OR PROJECTS
OR IS OR ARE THESE FIREFIGHTERS
MORE WHEN THE FIRES BREAK OUT
THAT'S WHEN THEY DEPLOY. IT'S A
GREAT QUESTION THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THAT. SO- ONE THESE THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY SIX AND THE ONE
HUNDRED ONE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR WE'RE GONNA BE
ADDING SO RIGHT NOW CAO FIRES
ABOUT TWO POINT SEVEN STAFFING
PRINT CHEN THE CHIEF AT THREE-
STAFFING WITH FORCED OVERTIME
THOSE ARE FULL TIME IF YOU WILL
OFFICER POSITIONS- THAT WOULD BE
ON THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS
A YEAR AND- IN THE OFFSEASON IF
THERE IS EVER AN OFFSEASON HOW
FAR FIREFIGHTERS ARE OUT DOING
THAT TYPE OF MANAGEMENT WHAT YOU
JUST SAID- I'M THESE FIRE CREWS-
THAT WOULD BE HIRED OUR TEN
MONTH TEMPORARY EMPLOYEES OR
SEASONAL FIREFIGHTERS. IN AGAIN
THE INTENT IS THERE ARE LAST IN
BACK I DO AND I AM FIGHTING FIRE
BUT WHEN TIMES ARE QUITE. I MEAN
I DID YOU TAKE MANAGE WORK.
INTERNALLY WE CAN HAVE ONE
WITHOUT THE OTHER. END THANKS TO
THE LEADERSHIP OF HIGH CHAIR OR
CASKEY INJURES SKINNER- THROUGH
THE BUDGET IN THE PRO TEMP-
WE'VE SEEN DOUBLE DOUBLE THE
AMOUNT OF VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
IN FORCE MANAGEMENT FINDING OVER
THE LAST THREE YEARS ADVANCE
FROM THIS LEGISLATURE. HOW FIRE
EMPLOYEES PEAKED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE. AND WE NEVER GOT
BACK. YET WERE NOW FROM NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE TO TODAY- WORD
WHERE THEY'RE BURNING A FEW
HUNDRED THOUSAND AS YOU ALL KNOW
WORK TWO MILLION ACRES OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS EACH YEAR.
SO THE INTENT WOULD BE- SAYS
MAJORITY LEADERS THAT YES
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE FULL TIME
FIREFIGHTERS THEY WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR FUELS MANAGEMENT
WORK IN ADDITION TO FIGHTING
FIRE- BUT I ALSO HAVE TO SAY WE
CAN'T HAVE ONE WITHOUT THE OTHER
RIGHT AND THAT'S WHY I THINK
THIS LEGISLATURE ALONG WITH THE
GOVERNOR IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO
ADVANCE. SIGNIFICANT FINDING
OTHER GOVERNORS ARE PROPOSING
ONE POINT THREE BILLION THIS
YEAR THE VAST MAJORITY OF ITS
GONNA GOING TO PAGE MANAGEMENT
WE HAVE TO GET ADDITIONAL BODIES
ARE OUT ON THE LINES NOT A
SINGLE SAY'S THIS. WHAT CENTER
LAYERED HEDGES SAID IN I GREATLY
RESPECTED HIS. OPINION IS
FORMER. SECTOR NATURI SOURCES.
JUST AS HE WAS SAYING THAT HE
WAS WAITING FOR ADDITIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS TO ARRIVE. SINCE
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN. IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT LITERALLY
HAVE BEEN CALLING. KALIFORNIA IF
THE DIRECTOR OF OFFICE EMERGENCY
SERVICES IN BEGGING FOR
RESOURCES. THANK YOU. AS
COMMUNITY AFTER COMMUNITY ON THE
NORTH COAST IS BURNED DOWN. WE
DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH MUTUAL AID
NOR CAL 5% NOW TO BE ABLE TO
COMBAT WHAT WE HAVE NOW
ESPECIALLY WHAT'S IN FRONT OF US
IN THE YEARS TO COME. SO WHAT I
WOULD HOPE IS THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE. ADVANCES ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR FIREFIGHTERS BECAUSE
WE ARE UNDERSTAFFED HE NEEDS AND
WOMEN AND MEN ARE PAYING THE
PRICE FOR THAT AND WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. THANK YOU CENTER EGGMAN- I'LL
JUST BRIEFLY THANK THE MAJORITY
LEADER FOR HIS. LEADERSHIP YEAR
AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR OF
POUNDING THE TABLE- THIS
LEGISLATION IS NOT NECESSARY
YEAH AND- YOU KNOW WE WE'VE BEEN
HAVING THE DOOR SHUT IN OUR FACE
AND IT'S NOT OUR FACE IT'S IS
THE FACE OF EVERYONE HURTING OUT
THERE WHO'S WORKING IN THE FIELD
AND IT'S ENOUGH. AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR BRAVERY IN
PUSHING THE ENVELOPE HERE AND
ASSERTING THIS LEGISLATION I
THINK YOU CAN SEE THAT ON A
BIPARTISAN BASIS THE LEGISLATURE
IS BEHIND YOU- ALSO APPRECIATE
JUST YOUR YOUR WORK IN IN
ELEVATING THE CONTRACT COUNTIES
ISSUES- THROUGH THIS LEGISLATION
AS WELL WE KNOW THAT WE RISE AND
FALL TOGETHER. AND- YOU KNOW I
SAW THAT VERY STARKLY MYSELF
DURING THE WILL THE FIRE- AND IT
WASN'T RISING TOGETHER WAS
ACTUALLY FALLING IN SOME WAYS
TOGETHER. AND TO SEE THE
RESOURCES OF L. A. COUNTY BE
DEPLOYED AWAY FROM L. A. COUNTY
UNDER THE MUTUAL AID PROGRAM
BECAUSE WE WERE SHORT UNDER THE
BROADER CORRECT IN THE BROADER
STAFFING LEVELS AND GO FIGHT A
FIRE IN PARADISE TRY TO SAVE
THAT COMMUNITY AND GO FIGHT A
FIRE IN HILL. OUT OF VENTURA
WHICH WE WANTED TO DO AND THEN
TO BE LEFT WITH NOT ENOUGH
PEOPLE TO CUT THE FUEL BREAKS
THE STOP THAT FIRED IT STARTED
UP IN THE FIELD LAB WHERE WE
COULD CUT A LINE AND WE DIDN'T.
WE LOST OVER SIXTEEN HUNDRED
HOMES I LOST MY HOME A LOT OF
PEOPLE LOST I THINK GETTING
CAUGHT. UNDER RESOURCE LIKE THAT
IS AN AVOIDABLE TRAGEDY AND
WE'RE GONNA TRY TO SOLVE THAT
HERE- AND I APPRECIATE
ESPECIALLY THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE
GONN BE LOOKING AT THAT SORT
OF. ALL IN STRATEGY WHERE WE
HAVE THE CONTRACT COUNTIES UP
AND HISTORIC STAFFING LEVELS AND
WE HAVE TWENTY EIGHTY ONE OF THE
BROADER STATEWIDE HISTORIC
STAFFING LEVELS AND WE CONSIDER
RESTORE ACROSS THE BOARD ON BOTH
ITS STAFF AND ALSO FOR-
OUTSTANDING EQUIPMENT NEEDS WE
KNOW IN PLACES LIKE KERN THE
LAND MAP IS QUITE LARGE MAYE
THAT PERSONNEL NEEDS AREN'T AS
BIG BUT THEY MAY MEET NAY DOZERS
OR- ORANGE COUNTY MEDIAN
MASTICATING. AB BUT WE'RE GOING
TO BE PURSUING AGGRESSIVELY. TO
CENTER LAIRD'S POINT ALSO- THIS
IN THE BUDGET COVER- AT HOPING
TO MAKE SOME PER- BEYOND WHAT
WE- WE MADE LAST YEAR- BUT I
JUST WOULD NOTE THAT IN THAT
JOINT OPERATION STRUCTURE. IT'S
BEEN CRUCIAL TO HAVE- THESE
CONTRACT COUNTIES IN THE SPOT
WHERE- THEY HAVE FOOTING AS WELL
BECAUSE- WE'RE MOVING A LOT OF
PEOPLE OF THE STATE DURING
CRISES AND WE SHOULD HAVE TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN. I WANT COMMUNITY
BURNING DOWN IN ANOTHER SO. TO
AVOID THAT CHOICE I'M I'M-
STRONGLY SUPPORTING THIS
LEGISLATION I THINK WE HAVE A
MOTION FOR FROM SENATOR LAYERED
SO ALL RECOGNIZED- THE CENTER
AND ALLOW MISTER WORKLOADS. THE
QUICK. I THINK YOU CAN. ENSURE
STERN FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS END
COULDN'T AGREE WITH YOU MORE
ABOUT CONTRACT COUNTIES WE ALL
WORK TOGETHER I ESPECIALLY IN
THESE CHALLENGING TIMES. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WITH A DATE- AN AWFUL
YEAR. FOR THE FIRE SERVICE. IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE MORE
FIREFIGHTERS DIED FROM SUICIDE
IN. ON THE JOB. IN IT IS EVEN
WORSE HERE IN CALIFORNIA. WE AS
STATE LEADERS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO FIX THIS
CHALLENGE IN FIX THE FIRE FIRE
SHORTAGE. I'M GRATEFUL TO THOSE
WHO WILL BE ADDED AS CO AUTHORS
TRULY GRATEFUL FOR THAT I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO EACH OF YOU
WHO ARE CO AUTHORS NOW WANTED
KNOWLEDGE- THIS GROWTH WAS THERE
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING AS WELL
AND TRULY GRATEFUL FOR THAT AND-
AT THE LAST THING ON THE STATE.
IS THIS. IS THAT WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO WORK. ON THE BUDGET
SIDE OF THIS ISSUE. TO WORK TO
SECURE THIS AND THIS LONG TERM
STACKING PLAN THAT WE
DESPERATELY NEED. NOT JUST NOW
BUT FOR A DECADE OUT BECAUSE
WHAT WE KNOW IS THE CONDITIONS
IN THE FORESTS ARE JUST GONNA
GET WORSE. AND IF WE DON'T GET
AHEAD OF THIS SHAME ON US IN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE MOTION IS
A DO PASS AS AMENDED. BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHIEF CONTEMPLATES CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM THREE S. B. TEN
SIXTY TWO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
STERN. STERN ALRIGHT JONES ALAN.
EGGMAN HI EGGMAN ARI GROWTH I
DROVE. HURTS HERTZBERG. WAYS
LAYERED ARE LAYERED A LOAN. MON
ALL RIGHT. OKAY THE MEASURE SIX
WILL WILL EVEN CALL THANK MISTER
LEADER- SO WE DO NOT HAVE OR IN
. AUTHOR HERE IN TERMS OF FILE
ORDER I DON'T THINK CENTER
CABALLERO. CENTER HER TADO BUT I
DO SEE THE DEAN OF THE SENATE
HERE- EVER READY ON ITEM SIX SO
WE'LL DEFER TO YOU SENATOR
NIELSEN. AND ALLOW YOU TO
PRESENT FILE ITEM SIX. S. C.
EIGHT EIGHT. THE END OF THE DAY
I DID. OF YOUR OWN REQUESTED BY
MY RECEIVE HER. THE NEW YORK
GOING BY VERY WELL. VERY WELL
THAT FIND THEIR WORK. WE'VE GOT
THAT GO WEALTHY ARE ALL VERY SO
ISSUES THE WE HAVE US. THE THAT
WE HAVE X. OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
HAVE BEEN UTTERLY DEVASTATING
AND I WILL ATTEST SINCE I HAVE
REPRESENTED THE OF THE MOST
AFFECTED AREAS. THE TWO AREAS.
OF GREATEST FIRES IN THE HISTORY
OF CALIFORNIA THEY'VE COME TO
VISIT THE AREA THAT I'M
PRIVILEGED TO REPRESENT. I SAY
PRIVILEGE IT IS A GREAT AREA TO
REPRESENT BUT IT'S BURNING UP.
AS IT MANY OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE. AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S DIFFERENT NOW THESE FIRES
ARE SO HUGE AND CATACLYSMIC. IT
ISN'T JUST THE RURAL AREAS THAT
ARE NOW AFFECTED. LEISURE
ENCROACHING ON OUR URBAN
COMMUNITIES. THERE'S NO SUCH
THING AS URBAN INTERFACE NOW.
THEY'RE BURNING RIGHT INTO OUR
CITIES. IN FACT I REMEMBER BACK
IN THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES THE
FIRE IN BERKELEY. DESTROYED ONE
OF- MY COLLEAGUES HOME. IN
BERKELEY GENDER NICK PETRUS. SO
WE DO HAVE A PROBLEM AND WE HAVE
A PROBLEM WITH PERSONNEL AS WELL
AS OF KNOWLEDGE IN THE LAST
HEARING BEFORE US. WE NO LONGER
HAVE IN MAKE TRUCE. BE DEPLOYED
I HAVE LONG ADVOCATED FOR
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS TO
HELP FILL THAT VOID. AND THEY
HAVE BEEN BUT WE'RE STILL SHORT
HANDED. AND WE NEED SOME
REASSURANCE THAT THOSE RESOURCES
WILL BE AVAILABLE. AS THE-
CREDIT FOR SEEING AUTHOR DID SO
WELL WITH KNOWLEDGE. WE
REPRESENT VERY SIMILAR THE
AFFECTED AREAS. AND I'VE
REPRESENTED A NUMBER OF THE
COUNTIES THAT HE NOW DOES
REPRESENT. AS WELL. SO WHAT THIS
BILL IS INTENDING TO DO IS TO
BRING SOME ASSURANCE. AND THIS
GERMAN I WOULD ACCEPT AS AUTHORS
AMENDMENT ALL THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS OF THE COMMITTEE- I
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE WORKING
WITH US IN THE SENSE AND THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL OUR TO AFFIRM THE
PURPOSE. OF ENSURING THAT
RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE. IT'S
GONNA OF REPRESENT A KIND OF A
TURNAROUND FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO
THE GOVERNOR GENEROUSLY PUT
SUBSTANTIAL MONEY AND FOR
FORCING WHILE AND MANAGEMENT.
BUT HE SUBJECTED BUT TWO OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE RATHER
DEAD. THE FINDING BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THAT WAS
QUOTE NEEDED. WE'LL HAVE DUBBED
IT. IT'S NEEDED THE LEGISLATURE
PUT IT IN THERE IT IS NEEDED NOW
THE GOVERNOR AND FINANCE ONE
INDIGO SHADE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE WITH THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. COMMITTEES THEN FINE
DO THAT BUT DON'T JUST
UNILATERALLY USURP THAT
AUTHORITY. SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO WITH THIS LEGISLATION. I
WISH TO ASSURE A REVENUE STREAM
. IT TRANSFERS 1% OF THE GENERAL
FUND AS AN ASSURANCE. THIS WOULD
BE FUNDING THE CALIFORNIA FIRE
RESPONSE FUND. AND THE SPECIAL
DISTRICT FIRE RESPONSE FUND.
BOTH OF THOSE ARE IMPORTANT AS
MINUTE KNOWLEDGE IN THE PREVIOUS
HEARING AND MANY OTHER HEARINGS
WE'VE DEALT WITH. SPECIAL
DISTRICT FOR EXAMPLE ARE
CRITICALLY. IMPORTANT TO WHAT WE
DO. THIS WOULD GUARANTEE THE
BALL FIRE FUNDS REMAIN INTACT
WITH THE STABLE YOU CAN COUNT ON
IT REVENUE SOURCE. NOT SUBJECT
TO DETERMINATION THE DEPARTMENT
FAMOUS LET US APPROPRIATE.
FUNDED BY THIS LEGISLATION. THEN
IN THIS BUDGET. THAT THAT WE
THEN CAN BE ASSURED THAT
PERSONNEL WILL BE AND RESOURCES
WILL BE AVAILABLE. FOR DOING
WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO PROTECT
THE CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA. AND
THEIR PROPERTIES. THEN
UNDERSTAND THIS ISN'T JUST LIVES
OF HUMAN BEINGS. IT'S ALMOST
NEVER MENTIONED IN OUR
DISCUSSIONS ON THE CATACLYSMIC
FIRES. THE IMPACT ON WILDLIFE.
AND THE FISHERIES AS WELL. THE
POLLUTION AND I'VE LOOKED AT. I
LIVE RIGHT ON THE RIVER AND RED
BLUFF SO I GET TO SEE FIRSTHAND
. THE POLLUTING OF OUR RIVER THE
MANY SOURCES. LOADING THE
RAVAGES OF FIRE. AND THE
SILTATION. THAT COMES FROM THE
EROSION. THE PHILS. OUR OUR VERY
VITAL. RIVERS AND AFFECTS OUR
ABILITY TO CONVEY CALIFORNIA
WATER TO OTHER AREAS FROM THE
SOURCE AREAS. TWO OTHER AREAS OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT'S
NEEDED HAVE THE LEGISLATION IS
NEEDED. TO ASSURE AND ENSURE THE
RESOURCES CAN BE THERE. IT BILLS
ON AND COMPLIMENTS THE PRECEDING
AUTHORS. LEGISLATION DOES NOT.
CONTRADICT NO HAN. I THOUGHT WE
WOULD ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER THIS
FAVORABLY. FOR THE PREPARATION I
HAVE WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
FAVOR MISTER SCOTT KAUFMAN THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS. MISTER
KAUFMAN IF WE MAY MISTER
CHAIRMAN. YES ED THANK YOU- AND
YOU ARE WELCOME TO I THINK AND
IF THAT'S YOUR ONLY LEAD WITNESS
I THINK THAT'S A FAIR OKAY GREAT
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU. OF
PROPOSITION NINETEEN PASSED
NARROWLY AFTER COSTLY AD
CAMPAIGN THAT EMPHASIZES
BENEFITS FOR SENIORS WILDFIRE
VICTIMS AND IS ABLE TO
HOMEOWNERS WHILE LARGELY
AVOIDING THE ISSUE OF THE
INTERNATIONAL TRANSFER. AS
VOTERS DISCOVER THE PROVISION
THAT REQUIRES THE ASSESSMENT
MARKET VALUE OF PROPERTIES
TRANSFERRED WITHIN FAMILIES WITH
ONLY LIMITED EXCEPTION ANGER IS
GROWING. AS WHY WE'D OUR DOORS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION IS
GATHERING SIGNATURES TO QUALIFY
AN INITIATIVE FOR THE NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY BALLOT. THAT WOULD
RESTORE THE TAXPAYER PROTECTIONS
CONTAINED IN PROPOSITION FIFTY
EIGHT AND ONE EIGHTY THREE THE
STATE CONSTITUTION. THAT'S THAT
ARE ARE A INITIATIVE ISN'T WHAT
IS BEFORE YOU TODAY WHAT IS
BEFORE YOU IS A SOLUTION TO
PROVIDE PERMANENT. FUNDING TO
UNDERSTAFFED RURAL FIREFIGHTER
DISTRICTS AS A RESULT OF THE
PASSAGE OF OUR INITIATIVE ACA
WOULD RECAST THE FUNDING
MECHANISM FOR BOTH THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE RESPONSE FUND.
AND THE SPECIAL DISTRICT FIRE
RESPONSE FUND. REQUIRING THE
TREASURY TO ANNUALLY TRANSFER AN
AMOUNT EQUAL 21% OF SPECIFIED
STATE REVENUES. FROM THE GENERAL
FUND TO THE CALIFORNIA FIRE
RESPONSE FUND. SCA EIGHT WOULD
REPLACE THE SMALL AND ON CERTAIN
SLICE OF REVENUE RAISED BY
INCREASING PROPERTY TAXES ON
CHILDREN WHO HAVE JUST LOST
PARENTS WITH A RELIABLE AND FAR
MORE GENEROUS FIRE FUNDING
SOURCE. FIREFIGHTING IS AN ISSUE
STATEWIDE CONCERN AND SHOULD BE
FINE ON THE BACKS OF CHILDREN
GRIEVING THE DEATHS OF THEIR
PARENTS. SB EIGHT RACES
FIREFIGHTING UP TO THE LEVEL OF
IMPORTANCE IT DESERVES IN THE
STATE. BUDGET AND FUNDS IT
ACCORDINGLY. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
FINISH BY SAYING THAT PROP.
EIGHT IS NOW A LOOPHOLE. IT WAS
PASSED UNANIMOUSLY BY BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND WAS BROUGH
PROVED BY 7475% OF TE
ELECTORATE. FURTHER THE MORE
THAN TEN THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
GATHERING SIGNATURES FOR
INITIATIVE SO WHAT YOU MAY HEAR
FROM TODAY. SOME FORTY HAVE
HEARD FROM TODAY- ARE NOT OUT OF
STATE MILLIONAIRES THEIR NORMAL
PEOPLE CONCERNED THAT THEIR
CHILDREN WILL BE TAXED OUT OF
THEIR ABILITY TO BUILD
INTERGENERATIONAL WEALTH AND
FINANCIAL SECURITY THROUGH
PROPERTY OWNERSHIP. I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY-
INCLUDING GENERAL- INITIAL LEAD
TESTIMONY WILL MOVE TO THE LINES
UNLESS THERE'S ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO WAS TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
SEEING NONE. MODERATOR WOULD YOU
MIND OPENING THE LINES THIS FOR
GENERAL SUPPORT TESTIMONY SO
FOLKS WHO ARE ON THE LINE IF YOU
CAN JUST SAY YOUR NAME. AND
WHERE YOU'RE FROM AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL. THAT BE
GREAT THANK YOU MISTER MODERATE
. THANK YOU TO LIKE THE- BUY. OR
FOR- AS B. ELEVEN TWENTY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE. BY ZERO THIS
TIME. WHEN FILED BY. ZERO AND WE
WILL BEGIN TODAY WITH WIND
SEVENTY YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IS THAT ME YEAH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MY NAME IS ANGELA
DORMER AND I'M THE ONE WHO WAS
FIREFIGHT BACK IN SEVENTY AND I
. SUPPORT THAT IT THANK YOU
RIDERS NEED A RIGHT THANK YOU
FOR A FIVE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'RE JUST GONNA GO NAY AND
POSITION ON THE BILL AND WHERE
YOU'RE FROM BUT THANK YOU MA'AM
. AND AGAIN A PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO TEST BY IN SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL AND LINE FIFTY THREE YOUR
OPEN. FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
MORE SHOT FIFTY THREE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TESTIFY. ARE MOVING ON
BY FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FOR BELL. THANK YOU NEXT. ONE
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS BOB DYLAN
MENDOCINO COUNTY ON STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT. OF NUMBER EIGHT- I'D
LIKE TO JUST SAY IN UNINTENDED
BENEFITS OF THIS BILL I'M SORRY
WE'RE JUST DOING NAME AND
POSITION ON THE BILL BUT I DO
APPRECIATE TESTIMONY SIR. ALL IN
SUPPORT OKAY THANKS A LOT THANKS
FOR UNDERSTANDING ALL RIGHT NEXT
. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE THIRTEEN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY. ONE
ONE THIRTY ONE MORE SHOT WOULD
YOU LIKE THE- YOU CAN YOU HEAR
ME WE CAN YES. MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH AND I'M A DALY CITY
RESIDENT AND I URGE YOU TO
STRONGLY SUPPORT S. C. A. EIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU PERFECTLY
DONE. FIND ONE TWENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ASSEMBLY FISCAL COUNTY
AND I SUPPORT- IF HE ATE ALSO
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT. ONE
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS DAVID COLLINS
NEVADA COUNTY AND I FULLY
SUPPORT FTA EIGHT EIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH NEXT. THANK YOU BYE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LET ME YES IT
IS. OKAY MY NAME IS ALEX QUAID
FROM SANTA CLARA COUNTY I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AS THE EIGHT
EIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY NEXT. WE WILL LIVE ONE
FIFTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. HI
GIVE ME. YES IT IS. IT IS THE-
SANTA CLARA COUNTY I STRONGLY S.
C. EIGHT NUMBER EIGHT OKAY GREAT
THANKS SO FOLKS IT'S YOUR NAME
AND YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL
AND WHERE YOU'RE FROM THANK YOU
THANKS EVERYBODY NEXT. TWENTY
ONE SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
YOU'RE WITH US. LET'S MOVE
HONEST MODERATOR OKAY ONE ONE
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. MY
NAME IS BECKY STEINBRUNER
CALLING FROM SANTA CRUZ COUNTY I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS FACT VERY
GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT. ONE
ONE SIXTY NINE YOU ARE OPEN. MY
ONE SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M MOVING ALONG WE WILL GO TO
ONE SEVENTY NINE YOU ARE OPEN
THAT MAY YES IT IS. YES MIKE VON
MCGUIRE- SAN FRANCISCO INTO THE
ETHICS SUPPORTER OF S. C. A.
EIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT.
ONE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
FIFTY YOU ARE OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WE CAN. I FORGOT AS B. AS
- PEOPLE WOULD SUPPORT IT THANK
YOU SO FOLKS NAME WHERE YOU'RE
FROM AND YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL NEXT. ONE FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS
MIKE AARON L. A. COUNTY I
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH PERFECTLY DONE NEXT. MY
FIFTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN. YES
DIANNE MATER LOS ANGELES COUNTY
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB EIGHT EIGHT
THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN
. YES THIS IS MARTIN OWENS FROM
BENICIA CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
SUPPORTING SB EIGHT EIGHT VERY
GOOD THANK YOU NEXT. NINE EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD HI MY NAME
IS BEVERLY LEMAY- I AM A RETIRED
PERSON. BOB FROM A RETIRED
FAMILY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AT
THE EIGHT EIGHT OKAY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT. AND
THERE ARE NO OTHER PURCHASES GET
UP THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR OKAY
VERY GOOD- SEEING NO OTHER
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM WILL NOW
TURN TO OPPOSITION- WE DON'T
HAVE ANY LIST ON FILE BUT I
THINK WE HAVE SOME LATE
OPPOSITION HERE TO TESTIFY- MR
SHIVERS. MR TERENCE CENTERS
THANK YOU DOUG SERVERS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AT THE OUTSET WE
JUST LIKE TO APOLOGIZE TO CENTER
NIELSEN AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE TIMING OF OUR OPPOSITION AND
THANK YOU ALL FOR THE DISCUSSION
AROUND APPROPRIATE STAFFING AND-
IN THE FUNDING OF THE FIRE
SERVICE WITH THAT SAID-
RESPECTFULLY WE MUST OPPOSE THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE IT IS- TIED TO A
CIRCULATING- INITIATIVE THAT
WOULD RESCIND IMPORTANT
PROVISIONS THAT WERE INCLUDED IN
PROPOSITION NINETEEN. THE CPF
WAS A PROPOSED CONSERVATION A
LEVIN WHICH ULTIMATELY BECAME
PROPOSITION NINETEEN WHICH
PASSED BY THE VOTERS IN TWENTY
TWENTY- THE CIRCULATING
INITIATIVE MEASURE WOULD RESCIND
THE INTERGENERATIONAL TRANSFER
PROVISIONS OF THE TAX CODE THAT
WOULD HAVE AN IMPACT ON NOT ONLY
THE FIRE FUND AS WE DISCUSSED
HERE TODAY BUT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
RESIDENT REVENUES AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE. THANKS VERY GOOD THANK
YOU ANY OTHERS IN THE HEARING
ROOM WISHING TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE ANYONE ON
THE LINES MISTER MODERATOR WOULD
YOU MIND QUEUING UP ANY GENERAL
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. THANK YOU.
THE TEST BY IN OPPOSITION TO S.
P. A. PREFER ONE ZERO. ONE FOUR
BY ZERO AND WE WERE LINE EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOR AGAIN
EIGHTY FOR YOUR OPEN. ONE MORE
SHOT EIGHTY FOUR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
SP EIGHT- NO I GREW UP. I
SUPPORT EIGHT SORRY THAT'S FINE
THANK SO MUCH ANY OTHERS WAS A I
. LINE NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MEMBERS BUT NOT
CHAVEZ FOR THE CALIFORNIA OF
REALTORS IN A POSITION OF
CONCERN WE WOULD LIKE THE LINER
CAL PROGRAM FIREFIGHTERS WE LOOK
FORWARD A THOUGHTFUL
CONVERSATION WITH AUTHOR IN
ORDER TO REACH IS AFFECTED THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH MANY OTHER
TUITION TESTIFYING OPPOSITION-
WITH CONCERTS. MISTER CHAIR THE
IN ORDER. WAS QUEUED UP THIS
TIME. OKAY VERY GOOD. WHAT IS
CENTER HERTZBERG FIRST. THANK
YOU VERY MR THANK YOU. CENTER
NIELSEN- YOU KNOW THE POTEMKIN
HAS- ASKED ME TO WATCH ALL OVER
ALL OF THE VARIOUS SAID BALLOT
MEASURES AND KIND OF MONITOR
THOSE THINGS ON AND I KNOW THAT
WOULD WAS MENTIONED HERE THAT
THE EFFORTS ARE VOLUNTARY AND
THEY ALSO KNOW FROM THE WORK
THAT I DID MANY YEARS AGO THAT
WE NOW REQUIRE A 25% THRESHOLD
TO GIVE NOTICE TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE. THRESHOLD FOR THIS
MEASURES NINE OR NINETY SEVEN
THOUSAND ONE AND TWENTY NINE
VOTES. AND IT'S REQUIRED TO BE
TURNED IN BY MAY THIRD TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WHICH IS LESS THAN A
MONTH AWAY. AND WE HAVEN'T SEEN
THAT A- 25% THRESHOLD LOADERS
POSTED- CERTAINLY THE OBLIGATION
OF THE SIGNATURE GATHERS IN THIS
BEING TIED TO THAT. I'D LOVE TO
ASK THE FOLKS FROM STE FROM-
HOWARD JARVIS WHETHER OR NOT.
BECAUSE AT LEAST FROM THE PAID
SIGNATURE GATHERS THAT I'VE BEEN
MONITORING YOUR YOUR CERTAIN
JUST A VOLUNTEER BASIS SO I
DON'T HAVE ANY DATA ON THAT. BUT
I WANT TO GET SOME SENSE AS TO
WHERE YOU WERE IN THAT PROCESS
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY IF YOU'RE NOT
THE 25% THRESHOLD. AT THIS POINT
AND YOU'VE GOT NEARLY A MILLION
SIGNATURES THAT HAVE TO BE
QUALIFIED WHICH MEANS YOU HAVE
TO GET THEM INTO. I JUST WANTED
THE FIRST PART OF MY INQUIRY
RELATES TO THE PROBABILITY OF
THIS EVEN BEING RELEVANT. SO I
THINK THAT'S A QUESTION OF THE
AUTHORS LEAD TESTIMONY THAT'S
CORRECT. VERY GOOD. TEARS WERE
THE PETITIONS OUT THERE RIGHT
NOW- YOU'RE CORRECT THAT WE HAVE
NOT RECEIVED 25% IN HAND I THINK
THIS AS YOU SAID VOLUNTEER
EFFORT I THINK THE MINDSET IS
DIFFERENT FROM PAID SEARCH YOUR
CAMPAIGN WORDS. THEY'RE PAID
RETURN SIGNATURE SO THE
INCENTIVES RETURN SIGNATURES I
THINK HERE THE INCENTIVE IS TO
QUALIFY FOR THE BALLOT AND WE'RE
SEEING THAT OUR OUR VOLUNTEERS
ARE HOLDING ON TO SIGNATURES FOR
AS LONG AS POSSIBLE AND SENDING
BACK IN AND GREATER. ARE COMING
BACK GREATER NOW- WE STILL
BELIEVE WE HAVE ENOUGH
SIGNATURES OTHERS QUALIFY. I
GUESS CAN PART OF THE CORE. YES
RELATED WAS ALLUDED TO BY THE
FIVE. BUT THIS MEASURE-
RECORDING TO THE REALTORS WILL
PRODUCE ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND HOUSEHOLD TRANSFERS A
YEAR. IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
. NOW THE ARGUMENT ABOUT THOSE
AS IT RELATES TO MONEY TO GROW
IN THE COUNTY I LIVE IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY USERS WILL BE A
HUGE AMOUNT OF MONEY BECAUSE
WHAT HAPPENS IS LET'S ASSUME
THAT- MRS MOSKOWITZ BOUGHT A
HOUSE IN NINETEEN SIXTY TWO AND
IT WAS PRE SEVENTY EIGHT SHE
BOUGHT THE HOUSE SAY FOR TWENTY
THOUSAND TODAY THE HOUSE IS
WORTH TWO MILLION- CERTAINLY THE
TAX BILL IS MAYBE A THOUSAND
DOLLARS IS BEST. IF SHE SELLS IT
IS WORTH TWO MILLION THE TAX
BILLS TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR THE NEW FAMILY THAT MOVES
IN. AND SO AS A CONSEQUENCE.
HUGE AMOUNTS TO REVENUES ARE
PROJECTED. I'M JUST THE- THE IN
. DEALING WITH THE ARGUMENT WAS
MADE BY MR SCHUMER'S. IS IT FOR
ALL THESE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
GOING TO HAVE THESE TURNOVERS
AND NEW FAMILIES YOU CAN HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO BUY AND MOVE
INTO THESE HOMES SO IN ADDITION
EVEN IF YOU HAVE A REVENUE
STREAM WHICH- ASK SPECIFICALLY
ANY CREATING OUT OF THE GENERAL
FUND MANY ME TAKING MONEY FROM.
FOSTER KIDS IT MEANS YOU'RE
TAKING MONEY FROM PRESCHOOL IT
MEANS YOU'RE TAKING MONEY FROM
ALL SORTS OF THINGS THAT COME ON
THE GENERAL FUND RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE MONEY BUT I'VE LIVED
THROUGH A TIME. AND HAD MONEY IN
EVERY NICKEL MAPPERS SO WHAT
YOU'RE DOING IS YOU'RE TAKING
AND IF THIS WOULD BE THE LAW THE
TWO POINTS OR REYES AND ASK YOUR
IN QUERY ON OUR ONE THE CROWDING
OUT OF THE ABILITY OF GOVERNMENT
TO PROVIDE OTHER ESSENTIAL
SERVICES DEGREE SAFETY THAT'S
WHEN BOTH OF YOU AND I HAVE BEEN
TO DOWNTURNS. AND THE SECOND IS
THE REVENUE STREAM RELATING TO A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND THE FACT
THAT THIS WAS DESIGNED IN LARGE
MEASURE SUPPORTED BY MANY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS BECAUSE IT PROVIDED
A REVENUE STREAM BY VIRTUE OF
UNLOCKING THAT THOSE TAX DOLLARS
AND THAT EQUITY IN THOSE HOMES
YOU CAN ADDRESS THOSE TWO ISSUES
AND I APPRECIATE. WELL MY
COLLEAGUE THIS IS A MATTER OF
PRIORITY EVERYTHING IS A MATTER
OF PRIORITY. AND WHAT WOULD BE
MORE OF A HIGHER PRIORITY THAN
LIFE AND PROPERTY. AND WILDLIFE.
THAT'S VERY MUCH SHIBLEY MY
ANSWER THAT THIS OUGHT TO BE
NECESSARILY WOULD BE AND WE
CAN'T JUST GRIEVE AND WRING OUR
HANDS WHEN THE FIRES HIT. THEY
WILL HIT. RECENT HEADLINE
ARTICLE IN THE- TO BE. THIS YEAR
THAT'S AN ASSURANCE THAT IS IN
THE MAY BE. AND IT IS IN THE MAY
BE EITHER THAT WE HAVE NOT
NEGLECTED WE HAVE INDEED
NEGLECTED REMOVING THE FUEL
SUPPLIES. IN A FOREST THE WILD
LANDS IN THE INTERFACE. SO I
WILL ARGUE. TO MY COLLEAGUES
THAT IS A PRIORITY OF GOVERNMENT
. AND THE ASSURANCE OF SUPPLIES
IS IMPORTANT PARTICULAR IN THIS
AREA. PERSONNEL. AND CAPITAL
RESOURCES AREN'T EASILY JAMMED
UP AND BROUGHT ONLINE.
FIREFIGHTERS AND I'M CURIOUS
ABOUT THE FIREFIGHTERS
OPPOSITION HERE I THINK THEY
HAVE OTHER MOTIVES PARTICULARLY
IN THAT THEY ONLY THIS VERY
MOMENT EGGNOG WHICH THEIR
OPPOSITION. THIS BILL HAVE BEEN
AROUND A WHILE IT SEEMED LIKE
THEY COULD HAVE SAT DOWN AND
TALKED IN THE OTHER PERSON WHO
SAID WELL LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATION. WELL AWARE OF HER
CONVERSATIONS BEEN HERE TO FOR.
I CONSIDER THAT ROUTE AND NOT
CONSISTENT WITH COURTESY AND
PROCESS. BUT BACK TO THIS IS
CENTRAL POINT MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS. I BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS A PRIORITY. NOT JUST WHEN THE
FIRES HAVE DESCENDED UPON US.
AND AS I ACKNOWLEDGE OF THAT IN
MY OPENING REMARKS. URBAN AREAS
HAVE BEEN SUBJECT TO THESE
CATACLYSMIC FIRES I MENTIONED
BERKELEY FOR EXAMPLE. AND OTHER
COMMUNITIES. THAT OTHER MEMBERS
TESTIFYING HERE TODAY HAVE
MENTIONED ONE OF WHICH I USED TO
REPRESENT. WE DIDN'T USED TO
HAVE A FIRE PROBLEMS LIKE THIS
IN SANTA ROSA. NOW WE DO. THIS
COME IN THE URBAN INTERFACE.
IT'S GOING TO BE THERE IT IS
GOING TO BE A PROBLEM. SO IF YOU
WANT TO ARGUE WITH ME THAT WE
COULD BETTER DEPLOYED FIRE
PREVENTION RESOURCES THAT'S A
CONVERSATION. THAT IS JUST. BUT
TO SAY THAT WE HAVE OTHER
PRIORITIES. I THINK THAT'S KIND
OF A HOLLOW ARGUMENT. IT DOESN'T
BEAR WEIGHT. TO THE CITIZENS WHO
LOST EVERYTHING AND I MEAN
EVERYTHING. I WAS PRESENT ON
SCENE AN ON SITE FOR THE
PARADISE FIRE. PEOPLE LOST
EVERYTHING. AND I REMEMBER
STANDING THERE ONE NIGHT. WITH
THE POLICE CHIEF. THEY SAID JIM
. MY HOME WAS BURNING AS I STAND
HERE. SO IT IS A PRIORITY AND
THAT WOULD BE MY ANSWERS CAN I
SHOULD ONE FOLLOW INSTRUMENT
SURE YEAH I JUST WANNA SAY I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU. AND
I- IT IS A PRIORITY IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. THE ONLY QUESTION I
WAS TRYING TO ASK IS WE ALREADY
HAVE PAID FOR IT. YOUR
LEGISLATION DOESN'T SAY. YOU'RE
LEGISLATION DOESN'T WE HAVE A
REVENUE STREAM YOU'RE TRYING TO
ELIMINATE THAT REVENUE STREAM OR
REPLACE IT WITH ANOTHER ONE.
BECAUSE YOU YOU KNOW THE ONES OF
PORTER'S PROPOSITION. THERE
ISN'T EVERY DOLLAR IN YOUR
PROPERTY HERE MEASURES ICS
BECAUSE YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT
ABOUT THIS MAKING A PRIORITY AND
THAT'S THE REASON WHY PROP
NINETEEN PASSED IN LARGE MEASURE
IN MY JUDGMENT I THINK YOU'RE
CORRECT. THE TEST IS NOT WHETHER
WE HAVE THE REVENUE NECESSARYTO
SUPPORT FIRE WHICH OF COURSE
THIS MEASURE DOES THAT'S THE LAW
NOW. SUPPORTED BY THE VOTERS THE
TEST IS YOU WANT TO CHANGE THE
REVENUE STREAM AND REPLACE IT
WITH GENERAL FUNDS THAT THAT HAS
AN IMPACT THAT WAS THE POINT. SO
YOU'RE A 100% RIGHT AND I
COULDN'T DISAGREE MORE IN TERMS
OF IT BEING A PRIORITY I'M JUST
LOOKING AT WHAT THE REQUIRE OUT
SHOULD BE PAID FOR. OKAY THANK
YOU- SIR ALAN. YEAH I'M I I'M
I'M OF MANY MINDS OF THIS AYE
I'M CERTAINLY OF A VERY
DIFFERENT OPINION ABOUT THE
MERITS OF PROP NINETEEN THEN MY
COLLEAGUE- BUT I THINK THAT HE
BRINGS UP A LOT OF REALLY GOOD
POINTS ABOUT HOW WE'RE BASICALLY
JUST SHIFTING CHAIRS ON THE ON
THE DECK HERE- WITH REGARDS TO
PAYMENT I'M I'M SO CAN I I'D
LIKE TO GET SOME MORE. I WAS ONE
OF YOU PEOPLE DID NOT VOTE TO
PUT PRIDE NINETEEN ON THE BALLOT
ON MY SIDE OF THE AISLE AND
BECAUSE I SAW THAT IT REALLY-
WHILE IT WAS PUSHED AS SOMETHING
TO HELP- YOU KNOW FOLKS WHO
WANTED TO. DOWNSIZE IN A
DIFFERENT COUNTY- AND THEN OF
COURSE THE ADS WERE ALL FOCUSED
ON VERY WEALTHY- INHERITORS WHO
YOU KNOW WANTED TO MAKE A BIG
INCOME OFF OF- OFF OF. RENTING
OUT A PLACE THAT THEY INHERITED.
I'M THE MEASURE ALSO HAD THE
OTHER IMPACT WHICH IS THAT- YOU
KNOW FOLKS WHO INHERITED THEIR
PROPERTIES WHO WANTED TO MOVE
INTO THE PROPERTIES OF THEIR
PARENTS. WE'RE WE'RE SCREWED
FIVE FIVE BECAUSE YOU KNOW. THE
PROPERTY VALUES HAVE INCREASED
SO SIGNIFICANTLY SO THAT'S- THAT
YEAH THAT THAT WAS. IT I WAS MY-
PROBLEM WITH WITH THE WAY WAS
FRAME UNFORTUNATELY- THAT THAT
PIECE OF THE STORY WAS NEVER
REALLY GOING TO AMPLY DISCUSSED
AND- IT'S TRUE DID PASSED. THE
ELECTORATE BUT IT WAS A VERY
SLIM MAJORITY I MEAN FIFTY ONE
TO FORTY NINE. SO 'D LIKE TO
GET A BETTER SENSE THOUGH AS TO
WHAT EXACTLY THE PROPOSAL IS I
MEAN I HAVEN'T BEEN MADE AWARE
I'D LOVE TO ASK- OUR FRIEND FROM
THE JARVIS'S ASSOCIATION- IT
SAYS THE ANNOUNCES THAT. THE
REPEAL THE DEATH TAX ACT APPEARS
TO REPEAL MUCH OF PROP NINETEEN.
BUT IT IS IT DOESN'T REPEAL ALL
AGES REVEALS SOME. AND THEN I
THINK IF THAT'S THE CASE THEN
IT'S POTENTIALLY VERY
PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE IT REALLY
DOES START TO GET US INTO A- UP.
A REVENUE. PROBLEM I GUESS IS
THAT IS THAT CORRECT. WE ARE
REALLY TO INTERRACIAL. BURKE IT
REMOVE THAT IN DOING SO IT.
FOR. THAT RICK. A YOU TO THE OF
CALCULATION THE PORTABILITY
ASPECT. ASPECT ANY IF THERE'S A
COST SAVINGS TO THE STATE THAT
COST SAVINGS GOES IN THE
WILDFIRE FUND OUT
INTERGENERATIONAL TRANSFER THAT
CALCULATION CAN'T BE MADE. SO
OUR BILL WHICH IS WHAT YOU DO IN
THAT INSTANCE STORY PLACING ONE
TWENTY THREE WITH ANOTHER. I
WOULD SAY THE PORTABILITY PART A
BIT BUSY MAYBE SAVE YOUR
PLACEMENT FINISHING ANOTHER.
IT'S NOT CREATING NEW REVENUE TO
PAY FOR. RIGHT SO YOU'RE JUST
TAKING. MONEY OUT OF THE GENERAL
FUND. OKAY SERVICES THAT HURTS
CONCERNS WERE OUT WORK I'M NOT
ISSUE WORKER YOU OVERSEE. PHONE
CORRECT GOTCHA OKAY AND I'M
SIDING. BUT I- IN THE AND THEN
AND I IF THERE IS ANY LOSSES IN
REVENUE TO COUNTIES- HER DRIVING
FROM IN OUR INITIATIVE
OBVIOUSLY- IN OR IF YOU HAVE ANY
LOSSES OF THE COUNTIES. DRIVING
FROM THE PORTABILITY ASPECT THAT
WOULD BE ALSO BACKED UP BY STATE
BUT OBVIOUSLY THAT'S INITIATIVE
THAT'S NOT. WHAT'S BEFORE YOU
TODAY. I MEAN OLD ULTIMATELY THE
INITIATIVE IS IN THE HANDS OF
THE VOTERS RIGHT NOW WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT A FUNDING.
FORMULA FR. THE FIREFIGHTERS.
SHOULD OUR INITIATIVE PASS AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT THE
DISCUSSION BUT NO WHY DO WE NEED
I MEAN IF WE FUND. FIREFIGHTING
EFFORTS. ALREADY WHY WOULD WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO GET
GUARANTEED CONTINUES A
PREPARATION WHEN. THAT'S A BUT
WHEN WE FIND FIREFIGHTING
EFFORTS AS A MATTER OF COURSE.
THE WHITE WHITE WHY IS THIS
NECESSARY. WELL IT. FROM
NINETEEN CREATED DEDICATED
FUNDING STREAM CONTINUES
DEDICATED FUNDING STREAMS WE
FOUND ANOTHER CONTINUOUS
DEDICATED FUNDING STREAM THAT'S
ONE PERCENTAGE- FUND IT'S
CONSIDERABLY MORE THAN WHAT PROP
NINETEEN IS THE WHAT WHY WOULD
THIS HAVE TO IT WHY WOULD HAVE
TO BE IN THE CONSTITUTION AT A
DEDICATED CONNECTION IN THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY ARE THE WILD
FIRE RESPONSE FUNDS IN THE
CONSTITUTION. NINETEEN CREATED
THAT HAS A PROMINENT TEAM THOSE
ARE IN THE CONSTITUTION. OF WELL
OKAY I'M. I WAS SKEPTICAL
NINETEEN I'M SKEPTICAL OFTHIS-
I'M SUPPORT OF SOME PARTS OF
YOUR INITIATIVE AND SKEPTICAL
ABOUT OTHER PARTS OF YOUR
INITIATIVE- BECAUSE IT SEEMS AS
THOUGH YOU'RE I MEAN I
PRESUMABLY YOUR YOUR INITIATIVE
IS NOT JUST FOCUSED ON. WE ARE
LET ME ASK YOU ON YOUR
INITIATIVE. ARE YOU JUST FOCUSED
ON THOSE FOLKS WHO ARE WHO
INHERIT A PROPERTY AND THEN THEY
GO AND OCCUPY THE PROPERTY OR
ARE YOU ALSO CARVING OUT FOLKS.
WHO INHERITED PROPERTY- BUT THEN
WANT TO RENT IT OUT IT WOULD
JUST BE RESTORE PROPOSITION
FIFTY EIGHT TOOK ABOUT TWO IT
WAS. HARD WITH AREA. WITH A I'M
SORRY A- IN INFLATION
CALCULATION ADJUSTED FOR THE
OTHER PROPERTIES AT YOUR WHY
DON'T YOU FOCUS ON THE MOST
SYMPATHETIC. VICTIMS A PROP
NINETEEN WHO ARE THE FOLKS WHO
INHERIT THE PROPERTY AND THEN
OCCUPY THE PARENTS THE PARENTS
PROPERTY THE PROPERTY WHERE THE
PRISON WHERE THEY GREW UP AS
OPPOSED TO THOSE FOLKS. WHO I
THINK WERE EFFECTIVELY AND MAYBE
JUSTIFIABLY VILIFIED IN THE YES
I NINETEEN CAMPAIGN FOR
INHERITING PROPERTY RENTING IT
OUT MAKING A TON OF MONEY- BUT
BUT THEY'RE NOT YEAH BUT BUT IT
DOESN'T ABIDE BY THE SPIRIT OF
PROP THIRTEEN WHICH INVOLVES. BE
ABLE TO LIVE IN THE HOME WHERE
YOU GREW UP I SAID THAT. I WE
JUST FELT THAT THAT THE CLEAN
RESTORE WAS CLEANER- BUT WE'RE
OBVIOUSLY HAPPY TO DISCUSS
CHANGES I MEAN OBVIOUSLY YOU
KNOW IF I INITIATIVE DOES NOT
SUCCEED THIS THIS INITIATIVE YES
I CA EIGHT WOULD HAVE TO CHANGE.
THE DISCIPLINE ON OUR INITIATIVE
PASADENA IT DOESN'T REACH THE
VOTERS THEN WE HAVE. TO
RECONSIDER AND WHAT WE WHAT WE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO. UP WITH YOU
ABOUT WAY THAT WE CAN MAKE PROP
NINETEEN MCCOLLUM FOR PEOPLE. I
MEAN I THINK ABSENT ABSENT A
CLEAN REPEAL WHICH IS OUR GOAL.
OF MAKING THIS EASIER FOR THE
FOLKS THAT YOU DESCRIBED IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO US. YEAH OKAY I
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH YOU- YOU KNOW
I THINK PROP NINETEEN WAS A BIG
SPECIAL INTERESTS PLAY
ULTIMATELY BUT I ALSO DON'T KNOW
THAT. THAT WE SHOULD DOUBLE DOWN
ON THE LOGIC BY PUTTING. A
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION
ALTERNATIVE IN THE CONSTITUTION
I YOU KNOW SO I'M I'M- YEAH I
WOULD I WAS THERE ARE TROUBLING
YOUR BIGGEST CONCERNS ARE
OBVIOUSLY THAT THE PEOPLE YOU
MENTIONED. ON THE LOW INCOME
FOLKS ARE NOT TO BE ABLE TO PAYS
PROPERTY TAXES BUT ALSO THE
OTHER CONCERN IS. EVEN FOR THE
FOLKS WHO CAN'T JUST THE CLIP
BECAUSE IT. IT GOES IT. CHANGED
OWNERSHIP TIME OF DATE OF DEATH
IT'S JUST. THERE HI JOE MCCARTHY
SAYS HIS PROTECTION THE SIXTEEN
THOUSAND YOUR MOVES IN TWENTY
SIX HE DOESN'T. DOESN'T EVEN PAY
FOR IT EITHER WAY- I UNDERSTAND
IT BUT THAT IS A DOESN'T THIS I
SEE. DOZENS THAT. IT DOESN'T.
YEAH BUT WE HAVE TO DISCUSS IT
OKAY THANK YOU. TO GROVE DIGITAL
QUESTION NO I JUST LIKE TO MOVE
THE AND I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
GOOD SENATOR FOR AND AGAIN AS
THOUGHTFULLY IN CONSIDERING THIS
BILL AND- WHAT IT HAD THE IMPACT
IT HAS ON OUR FAMILIES IN THE
RURAL AREAS AND I'D BE HONORED
TO MOVE THE BALL. BILL WELL I'M
OPEN ON THE SOURCE BOOK WITH ME
BUT- MY OWN INDUSTRY.
AGRICULTURE SUPPORTED THE
MEASURE. THAT LIMITS THE ABILITY. THE PARENTS HAVE TO TRANSFER
IF THEY HAVE MORE THAN ONE CHILD
. FIRST CHILD. IT'S A TRANSFER
OTHERS DO NOT. THE A COMMUNITY
WHO SAID OH WELL WE SUPPORT THIS
AND I SAID WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT
WELL THAT'S THE BEST WE CAN GET
. ALL OF THE OTHER SIBLINGS. GET
IT TO. WHERE THEY SHOULDN'T GET
IT. I DON'T LIKE THAT. WELL OUR
BOARD VOTED I SAID FINE YOUR
BOARD BOARD BOARD OTED BUT I'M
GONNA LET YOUR MEMBERSHIP NO.
WHAT'S YOUR VOTED. AND WHO GETS
HURT. THE GENERATIONS GET HURT
THIS IS A DELICATE AREA FOLKS.
THANKS FOR THAT- YOU KNOW JUST
MAKE A BRIEF COMMENT AS WELL I
SHARE- THE CONCERNS OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA MONICA
ABOUT. THE MECHANICS OF PROP
NINETEEN AND EVEN BEYOND THE
EQUITY IN- RACIAL JUSTICE ISSUES
THAT WE'RE SEEING FROM. THIS
INTERGENERATIONAL TRANSFER TAX-
FOR BUILDING INTERGENERATIONAL
WEALTH WHICH I'VE HEARD A LOT
ABOUT FROM THE DISTRICT FROM
WORKING PEOPLE- AND FRANKLY- I
SHOULD'VE DONE MORE HOMEWORK-
WHEN VOTING ON THIS A. C. A.
WHEN I WAS MOVING THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE WAS A- LATE DEAL AND
CAME TOGETHER AND- I'M- AND IT
WAS SOLD A CERTAIN WAY TO THE
VOTERS AND YOU KNOW I'M ALWAYS A
LITTLE SKEPTICAL WHEN. WE USE
THE POLITICS OF FIRE. AND THE
SACRED DUTY THAT WE HAVE TO.
FULFILL OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
OUR FIREFIGHTERS- AND USE THAT
AS A SALES PITCH TO VOTERS- YOU
KNOW I IN TERMS OF THIS MEASURE
WE TRIED TO IN THE AMENDMENTS AT
LEAST MATCH EXACTLY HOW PROP
NINETEEN WAS WORK FOR THE
FIREFIGHTERS SO THAT THERE WOULD
BE. NO CONSEQUENCE IN INACTION
IN IN ACTUALITY THIS IT ACTUALLY
COULD BE A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
IN IN WHAT'S EXPECTED FROM PROP
NINETEEN I'M FOR THOSE FUNDS I
WAS WONDERING I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER THE AUTHOR OR THE
SPONSOR HAVE ANY INFORMATION OR
I THINK CAL FIRE CHIEFS ARE ALSO
IN SUPPORT THE FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION OF FIRE DISTRICTS AS
ASIAN CALIFORNIA GIVE A SENSE OF
HOW THE 1% NUMBER OF CORRELATES
TO THE ANTICIPATED I KNOW IT'S
NOT YET KNOWN HOW HOW MUCH THAT
INTERGENERATIONAL TAX WOULD
RESULT IN BUT THERE ANY GENERAL
ESTIMATES RIGHT NOW IS THERE A
WAY TO SORT OF. TAYLOR THIS BILL
A LITTLE MORE NARROWLY SO THAT
IT DOESN'T FEEL. SO OPEN ENDED
AND MAYBE AN OVER ALLOCATION OR
TYING THE HANDS OF THE
LEGISLATURE BUT SOME WAY TO. TO
MAKE THE AMOUNT SORT OF
PROPORTIONAL TO THE ANTICIPATED
LOSS FROM THE REPEAL. THE L. A.
I BELIEVE ESTIMATED AT TENS OF
MILLIONS UPWARDS OF A HUNDRED
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS ON THIS
OBVIOUSLY BE MORE THAN A BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR 1% AT CURRENT
RATES- WE YEP WE WOULD BE HAVING
WE ARE OPEN TO. ALL
CONVERSATIONS ON THIS. SO I
THINK I'M MOST ASSURED THEM TO
MR MR OKAY WELL THAT THAT
ACTUALLY THAT'S QUITE HELPFUL
BECAUSE IF THERE'S AT LEAST A
WAY TO DEAL WITH- THE TAILORING
OF WHAT WHAT WE MAY CALL THE
BACK. FROM OF A MORE NARROW
REPEAL. AND I THINKTHAT COULD
HELP POTENTIALLY WITH. THE SWORD
ON THE ONGOING QUESTION OF ARE
WE LOCKING OURSELVES INTO THE
RIGHT STRUCTURE FUNDS. I WILL
NOTE HOWEVER WE JUST VOTED ON A
MEASURE THAT WOULD LOCK IN
SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS OF FUND FOR
ON A CONTINUOUS BASIS THAT I WAS
VERY PROUD TO HELP. WITH AND
CRUCIAL THAT WE DO TO MAKE THAT
FUNDING SO IN SOME WAYS THIS
MEASURE COULD WORK IN CONCERT
WITH THE MAJORITY LEADER'S BILL-
AS AN ONGOING SOURCE- BUT- THE
ONE OTHER QUESTION I HAD SO. WE
WE'VE MIRRORED- THE PROP
NINETEEN FIRE MECHANICS IN IN
THE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU AGREED
TO- BUT I'M WONDERING IF THERE'S
A WAY TO- TO SORT OF LET THE-
SIGNATURE GATHERING PLAY OUT AND
NOT NECESSARILY AT THIS POINT.
LINK THE MEASURE. TO THAT BALLOT
PROPOSITION I HEARD THE CONCERNS
OF. THE PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND ALL THE
KNOWLEDGE THE LATE HOUR ON THOSE
THOSE- THOSE CONCERNS REYES AND
DUE RESPECT TO THE AUTHOR- FOR
HIS FRUSTRATION WITH THAT. BUT-
BUT I WONDER IF WE WERE ABLE TO
FOR THE TIME BEING- D. LINK
THESE TWO SO- D. LINK. S. C.
EIGHT EIGHT FROM THE SIGNATURE
GATHERING EFFORT I'M LOOKING I
THINK SPECIFICALLY AT SECTION.
TWO OF THE BILL WHICH HAS A
BLANK IN IT RIGHT NOW IT SAYS
THIS MEASURE SHALL ONLY TAKE
EFFECT IF BOTH THIS MEASURE AND
PROPOSITION BLANK- ARE APPROVED
BY THE VOTERS AT THE BLANK
STATEWIDE GENERAL ELECTION.
BECAUSE THAT IS SORT OF A
HYPOTHETICAL AT THIS POINT AND
MAYBE YOU COULD ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS OF THE FIREFIGHTERS
WELL WE SORT OF WORK THROUGH
SOME OF THESE OTHER MECHANICS
AND MAYBE FIND A WAY TO BACK
FILL THIS INTERGENERATIONAL TAX
ISSUE IN A MORE SORT OF TAILORED
WAY- WHETHER IT MIGHT MAKE
SENSE. TO STRIKE SECTION TO- AND
THEN THE MOVIE. SECTION ONE AND
SECTION THREE. FORWARD I KNOW WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE CURRENT
BILLS AMENDED FROM CENTER GROVE
BUT- BUT I WOULD BE OPEN TO A-
TO A MOTION ON ON THAT MAYBE
COMPROMISED POSITION I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT. DOES THAT HELP-
CAN I ASK ONLY TO PUT HIM ON THE
SPOT BUT COMMIT PASSER
FIREFIGHTERS REPRESENTATIVE FROM
C. P. F. IF WE WERE ABLE TO
STRIKE THE LINK TO THIS REPEAL.
AND I SUPPOSE IT'S THE REALTORS
ON THE LINE TOO BUT IF THIS WERE
NOT IN OTHER WORDS CONNECTED TO
THAT BALLOT PROPOSITION EFFORT
IF THAT CAME TO QUALIFY WE COULD
REVISIT THAT PROVISION
POTENTIALLY BUT WANT TO GET
YOUR- PERSPECTIVE ON. JUST
STRIKING SECTION TO- AND LEAVING
SETTING ASIDE MAYBE THIS REPEAL
QUESTION AND THEN FOCUSING
SPECIFICALLY ON TAILORING THE
MECHANICS YEAH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR DOUG TO RESUME HAVE A
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS WE HAVE TO TAKE
THAT CHANGE IN THE MEASURE BACK
TO OUR LEADERSHIP AND HAVE A
DISCUSSION ABOUT IT. I DIDN'T-
NOT TO GET INTO ALL THE NUANCES
OF THE TAX POLICY BUT THE
IMPLICATIONS OF. REPEALING THE
INTERGENERATIONALTRANSFER
ELEMENTS OF PROPOSITION NINETEEN
WILL NOT ONLY HAVE AN IMPACT ON
THE FIRE FUNDS AS ITS STRUCTURED
IN THIS MEASURE BUT ALSO HAVE AN
IMPACT ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT
REVENUES. IN A IN A SENSE. THE
FIRE FUND WILL BE FUNDED BECAUSE
THERE WILL BE INCREASES IN LOCAL
PROPERTY TAX REVENUES THAT ARE
IMPORTANT FOR A SUITE OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SERVICES INCLUDING-
LOCAL FIRE DEPARTMENTS AND THE
SAVINGS. RELATED TO PROP NINETY
EIGHT THAT ARE GENERATED LOCALLY
IS WHAT WILL HELP SUPPORT THE
FIRE FUND SO THERE ARE SOME.
TECHNICAL IMPLICATIONS OF.
TRYING TO WORK THROUGH
STRUCTURING- PROPOSAL TO.
BACKFILL THE LOSSES AND THE
LOCAL REVENUES. THE WELL OUR
MEMBERS- HAVE A SEPARATE
COLLOQUY- APPRECIATE THAT
FEEDBACK- THERE'S NO MOTION ON
THAT BY THE WAY SO IN MAY- BUT
BUT I AM. LOOKING CENTER LAYERED
PERHAPS FOR SOME. I DON'T KNOW
IF I CAN OFFER IMPROVEMENT HERE
BECAUSE I THINK THE DIFFICULTY
OF THIS IS ALL THE CONFLICTING
THINGS THE LINK. TO THE BALLOT
MEASURE AND THE LOSS OF FUNDS
DELAYED OPPOSITION AND I ALWAYS
WANT TO RESPECT THE SENATOR DEBT
IS TRYING TO WORK THINGS OUT AND
GET TOO LATE IN THE A. N.
THERE'S ONE ISSUE THIS IS SCOTT
SUCH A LIFE OF ITS OWN FROM THE
PROPOSITION AND NOW TO THIS.
THAT THERE'S THIS OVERARCHING
QUESTION THAT HAS NOT BEEN
MENTIONED IN THE OVER ARCHING
QUESTION IS THAT IF YOU LOOK AT
WHO BENEFITED FROM OUR
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN AND I
BOUGHT MY HOUSE IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX I AM A GROSS
BENEFICIARY OF THAT IT IS
OVERWHELMINGLY. BOND NOT
REPRESENTING THE DIVERSITY OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
CONTINUE TO TAKE ACTIONS THAT
WALK IN- OF THAT TO A CERTAIN
GROUP OF PEOPLE AND IT DOESN'T
REPRESENT PEOPLE OF COLOR WOMEN
OR THE PEOPLE THAT ARE STRONGLY
IN THE MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA
AND IT KEEPS THEM OUT OF ASSESS
ABILITY TO HOUSING B. BECAUSE OF
THAT. HAT HAVING SAID THAT THIS
IS SO COMPLEX AND IT GETS MORE
COMPLEX WITH EVERYTHING THAT I
WAS PREPARED TO VOTE FOR THIS I
HAVE TO BE THAT WAY AT LEAST THE
ONE PERSON MAYBE THERE'S ANOTHER
AND I'M NOT RECOGNIZING IT WHO'S
ON APPROPRIATIONS AND THIS IS
GOING ON TO APPROPRIATIONS AN
AND I WOULD JUST ASK THAT ALL
THESE ISSUES. A BE ADDRESSED AND
SOME OF US WILL LOOK AT IT AGAIN
AND APPROPRIATIONS TO DECIDE. IF
THEY BEEN ADDRESSED IN THE RIGHT
WAY. GOOD SUGGESTION THANKS FOR
CALLING GOT SURE WOULD WORK YOU
ON THE- OKAY. BUT WE DO AGREE ON
SOMETHING SHE CENTER CINDY- ANY
OTHER KERR OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
DICE AND WE DON'T HAVE OUR FULL
MEMBERSHIP HERE- THERE IS A
MOTION ON THE BILL AND JUST TO
BE CLEAR WITH YOU ALL ABOUT WHAT
THE MOTION IS IT IS JUST ON THE
BILL. AS AMENDED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. IT DOES NOT
STRIKE THE LINK TO THIS PENDING
PROPOSITION- BUT WE CAN VOTE ON
THAT FIRST- CENTER GUYS WAS THE
I SHARE OUTSIDE ONE'S REITERATE
I SHARE SOME BUT NOT ALL. OF THE
AUTHOR AND THE PROPONENTS
CONCERNS ABOUT PROP NINETEEN AND
I JUST DON'T KNOW THAT THIS
PARTICULAR- S. C. A. ADDRESSES
THOSE CONCERNS. I ALSO THINK
THAT- YOU KNOW THIRD PLENTY WAYS
TO FIND FIRE JUST AS WE
DISCUSSED- DON'T INVOLVE.
PUTTING IN A MINUTE TO THE
CONSTITUTION SO THIS IS THE IS
THE STRUGGLE I'M HAVING HERE.
OKAY HELLO MISTER I'M NOT HAVING
TROUBLE REALTORS TO. I FIND THEM
NOT TO BE CREDIBLE ANYMORE FOR
SEVERAL YEARS ACTUALLY. AND THEY
DON'T EVEN HAVE THE COURAGE TO
SHOW UP. THAT'S INTERESTING.
WHAT HAVE WE BECOME. WHAT HAVE
WE BECOME. THANK YOU SO WITH
THAT COLLOQUY- SERIGNE WE ARE ON
S. C. EIGHT EIGHT- WHICH IS FILE
ITEM SIX. AND THERE'S A MOTION
FROM SENATOR GROVE- WE'LL VOTE
ON THAT MOTION. AS I MENTIONED
I'D BE AN ENTERTAINING ANOTHER
MOTION TO IS TO STRIKE SECTION
TWO AND DELINK IT FROM THE
BALLOT PROPOSITION WHILE WE WORK
THROUGH THE REST- BUT AT PRESENT
UNLESS SIGNIFICANT. WELL SO DID
TRY TO ADDRESS THE PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS CONCERNS THAT THIS
BILL THIS BILL OR THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL THEM IS LINKED TO
THE REPEAL OF PROP NINETEEN- AND
THAT WE MAY NOT AGREE ON WHAT
EXACTLY THAT REPEAL LOOKS LIKE
MAYBE IT'S TOO BROAD OF A
PROPOSAL THAT WE WOULD SET ASIDE
THAT ISSUE BY STRIKING SECTION
TWO AND MOVE FORWARD ON THE
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION- WHILE
WE- SORT OF LOOK TO. A
COMMITMENT FROM THE AUTHOR TO
TAILOR THAT CONTINUES TO
PROCREATION AS HE AS HE
MENTIONED- TO THE ACTUAL. UNMET
NEED- SO DID TO SCALE IT DOWN IT
IN THEORY NOT JUST A PERCENTAGE
BASIS BUT MAYBE SOME OTHER SORT
OF PROPORTIONAL BUT IT'S GONNA
AND THAT'LL TAKE SOME WORK AND
THAT'LL TAKE TIME FOR
APPROPRIATIONS BUT I DO TRUST
IN. CENTER NIELSEN'S COMMITMENTS
ALWAYS HERE SO- BUT THAT WOULD
REQUIRE A SEPARATE MOTIONS I
THINK WE'RE FIRST GOING AFTER
VOTE ON- JUST THE STREET- BILL
IS BEFORE YOU AND- WE CAN. OKAY
THE OTHER OPTION MISTER CHAIR-
SO I MEAN YOU CAN IN YOUR BOOK
IN A MAJOR MOTION. I THINK THE
BILL. WITH THE ACCEPTED A
COMMITMENT FROM THE AUTHOR TO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS AND TO
SEPARATE- THE PROPOSITION AND
APPEASE- OR MEET THE NEEDS THAT
THE FIREFIGHTERS HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH. OKAY VERY GOOD YES SO AND
SO TO BE CLEAR I WANT TO MAKE
CHOCOLATE MY CHIEF CONSULTANT
HERE SO THAT YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE MOTION WOULD BE. I THINK THE
MOTION IS- TO PASS TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. TO STRIKE
SECTION TO. SO WOULD NOT BE
LINKED TO THE PENDING BALLOT
PROPOSITION AND THEN- COMMITMENT
TO WORK ON REFINING THE FORMULA
IN SECTION ONE TO PRINT TO
TAILOR IT TO THE ACTUAL UNMET
NEED IN THAT AREA. BEFORE
PROCREATION WE NOTE ONE NOTE
ALSO THIS IS DOUBLE REFERRED BUT
TWENTY CHECK WITH THE CHIEF
CONSULTANT OF THIS IS ENOUGH TO
. AT LEAST TRANSMIT IN VOTE ON.
OKAY THIS YEAR YES SIR JOHN CAN
WE JUST GET CLARIFICATION FROM
THE AUTHOR THAT HE'S OKAY WITH
THAT MOTION YES YES YES I AM.
THANK YOU CENTER GROVE YEP AND
SO. YES N. AND SO BEFORE VOTING
ON IT I GUESS. I LIKE THE CLOSE
UNLESS THERE'S ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. OR QUESTIONS- FROM ALL
SIDES. HELLO ONE SECOND.
OKAY SO- THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED WITH THE AUTHORS
COMMITMENTS- AND REFER SORRY
WE'RE GONNA RE REFER TO
ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS. OUR SOLUTIONS FROM
CENTER GROVE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM SIX IS CA EIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED- BUT FIRST REFER TO
ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS STERN STERN ALL RIGHT
JONES JONES HI ALAN. EGGMAN
EGGMAN HI GROVE GROVE I
HERTZBERG. HUESO WHERE'D WHERE'D
ALL RIGHT LOAN. THANK YOU JOHN
WILL WORK WITH. OKAY THAT
MEASURES FIVE VOTE TO LEAVE AN
ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS. OKAY THANK YOU ALL FOR
WORKING THROUGH THAT WITH US- WE
ARE GOING TO TRY TO STAY ON
TRACK NOW I THINK WE HAVE
SENATOR HER TADO UP- THE- SORRY
DID NOT SEE CENTER COVER EUROPE
APOLOGIES. SO WE'LL GO WITH
STAND FILE ORDER HERE WE'RE
GONNA FILE ITEM FOR. SB ELEVEN
TWENTY THREE CENTER CABALLERO
WELCOME. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT SB
ELEVEN TWENTY THREE WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE INTER AGENCY STRATEGIES
TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO GRANT AND
LOAN PROGRAMS AND ESTABLISH
REPORTING AND EVALUATION
REQUIREMENTS OF STATE ENTITIES
THAT OFFER CLIMATE RELATED GRANT
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS TO BUT TO
DEVELOP. MECHANISMS FOR UNDER
RESOURCE COMMUNITIES TO IDENTIFY
AND FIND CLIMATE CHANGE BECAUSE
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF FUNDS THAT
ARE IN DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS-
THAT PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
COMMUNITIES TO ACCESS RESOURCES
TO COMBAT CLIMATE CHANGE. I
WOULD LIKE TO START BY THANKING
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON
THE BILL TO CLARIFY THE INTENT
AND I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS CLIMATE
CHANGE CONTINUES TO THREATEN
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITIES WITH
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES EXTREME
HEAT FLOODS DROUGHT AND SEA
LEVEL RISE COMMUNITIES NEED
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AND
CAPACITY TO PLAN FOR AND ADDRESS
THE RISKS HOLISTICALLY AND LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET PROVIDED FOR
PROGRAMS ACROSS A NUMBER OF
DEPARTMENTS AGENCY INC AGENCIES
INCLUDING THE OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH. THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL THE DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
AGENCIES AND OTHERS EACH OF
THESE PROGRAMS ADDRESSES
SPECIFIC COMMUNITY A REGIONAL
RESILIENCE NEEDS TO ENSURE THE
CONTINUED SUCCESS OF THE STATE'S
EFFORTS TO WORK CLIMATE
RESILIENCE IS CRITICAL OF THE
PROGRAM'S REMAIN ACCESSIBLE
COORDINATED TRANSPARENT AND
ACCOUNTABLE TO MEASURES OF
SUCCESS. TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO A
VARIETY OF CLIMATE RESILIENT
PROGRAM RESILIENCY PROGRAMS SB
ELEVEN TWENTY THREE DIRECTS THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
TO DEVELOP A WEB BASED RESOURCE
TO IDENTIFY ALL STATE FUNDED
RESILIENCE FUNDING PROGRAMS AND
PROVIDE HELPFUL INFORMATION AND
ASSISTANCE TO COMMUNITIES AND
OTHER ENTITIES SEEKING STATE
FUNDING WHICH WILL INCLUDE
TARGETED OUTREACH TO UNDER
RESOURCE COMMUNITIES THE BILL
ALSO REQUIRES THE IMPLEMENTING
AGENCIES TO DEVELOP A
COORDINATED APPROACH. FOR CAN
UNITS COMMUTE WHERE AND HOW
THESE COLLECTIVE FUNDS ARE BEING
SPENT AND APPROACHES TO MEASURE
SUCCESS IN CLIMATE RESILIENCE
AGAINST MEASURES ADAPTED FROM
EXISTING STATE STRATEGIES. AS
CLIMATE RESILIENCY RELATED
PROGRAMS DEVELOP ACROSS STATE
AGENCIES IT'S CRITICAL THAT THE
PUBLIC. AS WELL AS THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE IMPLEMENT
IMPLEMENTING AGENCIES NO CHOIR
AND HOW THESE FUNDS ARE BEING
SPENT. THE HOPE IS THAT MORE
RESOURCES WILL BE AVAILABLE TO
ENSURE THE COMMUNITIES THAT NEED
ASSISTANCE IN ACCESSING CLIMATE
RELATED GRANT PROGRAMS ARE
BETTER EQUIPPED TO DO SO. MY
DISTRICT HAS TWENTY SEVEN CITIES
ON TWENTY FOUR OF THEM ARE UNDER
THIRTY THOUSAND IN POPULATION
AND FOR THEM TO ACCESS CLIMATE-
FUNDING- IS WAY BEYOND THEIR AT
THE CAPACITY OF THEIR STAFF
QUITE FRANKLY THEY DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES. TO BE ABLE TO
HIRE PEOPLE TO COME AND DO GRANT
SEARCHES AND- GRANT WRITING
WRITING SERVICES AND SO THIS
BECOMES REALLY CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT PARTICULARLY SINCE A
MAJORITY OF THOSE COMMUNITIES
ARE LOCATED IN THE SET AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WHERE THE AIR
QUALITY AND THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE- BY DROUGHT
RELATED IMPACTS AND HE RELATED
IMPACTS ARE THE MOST SEVERE. SO
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY AND TESTIFYING
REMOTELY IN SUPPORT IS EVAN
JOHNSON SENIOR POLICY DIRECTOR
FOR THE OFFICE OF STATE
CONTROLLER CONTROLLER BETTY.
GREAT THANK YOU CENTER CARILLO-
MR JOHNSON ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
YES I'M HERE PLEASE PROCEED. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS EVAN JOHNSON AND THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY BEFORE YOU TODAY
HONESTLY ELEVEN TWENTY THREE
IMPORTANT BUILT THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S PLEASED TO SPONSOR
. AT ELEVEN TWENTY THREE WILL
SUPPORT COMMUNITIES IN THEIR
EFFORT TO BE MORE CLIMATE
RESILIENT AND HELP IF THEY ARE
TIED TO INVESTMENT IN THESE
COMMUNITIES. SENATOR MENTIONED
CALIFORNIANS ARE ALREADY
SUFFERING IMPACT OF CLIMATE
CHANGE ON THE COAST THE FEEL OF
A RISING LEVEL HAS BEGUN TO RISE
CAUSING SO WATER INFILTRATION
INTO AQUIFERS. ASIAN THIS YEAR
IS IT BECOME LESS AS DISCUSSED
EARLIER IN THIS HEARING.
CONTRIBUTING TO MORE SEVERE
WILDFIRES EIGHT TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WATER YEAR
WITH THE SECOND DRIEST TWO YEAR
PERIOD ON RECORD. ALONE
RESULTING IN ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC
COSTS. A LOT TO NEARLY FIFTEEN
THOUSAND JOBS ACROSS THE
AGRICULTURAL SECTOR. AND THE
AVERAGE ANNUAL TEMPERATURES HAVE
INCREASED ALREADY INCREASED
1 DEGREES FAHRENHEIT THE SUMMARY
TO CALIFORNIA EXCEEDING TWO
DEGREES. ACCORDING TO HE CRISIS
AND A MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. THE COMING YEARS
WILL ONLY BE WORSE. THERE IS
REVENUE THE CHALLENGES OF CA.
FOR A WIDE OF ON A THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR COMMITMENT TO
DRAFT THE GREATEST RISK OF
EXTREME HEAT HI HUNDRED MILLION
COMMITMENT FOR COASTAL
RESILIENCE. BILLION TO SUPPORT
OF DROUGHT RESILIENCE INCLUDING
PROGRAMS TO HELP COMMUNITIES
PLAN FOR INGRESS WATER SCARCITY.
IT'S PAST THE BUILDING FUNDS
THROUGH THE REGIONAL CLIMATE
RESILIENCE PROGRAMME ANOTHER'S.
LIST GOES ON THANKFULLY. IN
ADDITION RESEARCH RESOURCES THEY
USUALLY JUST ECHOING UPDATE TO
THE- CLIMATE ADVOCATE STRETCH.
THIS BILL AIMS TO STRENGTHEN
THESE EFFORTS BY SUPPORTING
GREATER ACCESS TO THESE PROGRAMS
AND IMPROVING TRANSPARENCY
EFFECTIVE. IT DOESN'T TO WAYS.
IT AIMS TO PROVIDE GREATER
ACCESS TO A WIDE VARIETY OF
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO COMMUNITY
SERVICE JOINT NAVIGATORS PROGRAM
HOSTED BY THE- INTEGRATED
CLIMATE ADAPTATION RESILIENCE
PROGRAM. TO COMMUNITY IF YOU CAN
SUPPORT BELT WILDFIRES GOING
THROUGH A VARIETY OF MEASURES
INCLUDING STATE DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY GENERATION. HOME
COMMUNITY HARDEN ESTABLISHING A
RESILIENT. COMMUNITY INGRESS AND
EGRESS. NAVIGATORS PROGRAM WILL
HELP IDENTIFY THE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE FROM THE STATE. BANK
CONNECT THOSE COMMUNITIES WITH
THE CORRECT CONTACT AT THE
RESOURCES OF THE IMPLEMENTING
AGENCIES FOR EACH PROGRAM. THE
PROGRAM ALSO CONDUCT OUT RESTORE. MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
YEAH IN FACT. AIRPORT
TRANSPARENCY IN ACCOUNTING FOR
ALL BEANS AND TO OF RESILIENCE
TO CLIMATE RESILIENCE. DAY AND
IMPROVE CORE OR IN A YOU TO
COMMUTE AND STAKE UNDER WHERE
FUNDS BEING. IN HAVE A GREAT THE
MOST NEED AND HOW THESE PRO CAN
ULTIMATELY BE IMPROVED TIME. SO
I STAYED UNDER TEMPERATURES THAT
TO HELP PROTECT ME AND WORK FROM
THE WORST IMPACT CLIMATE.
IMPORTANT MAINTAIN EQUITY AND
ACCESS KEEP. NO WE HAVEN'T OF
NOT ONLY FOR THE TO UNDERSTAND
INVESTMENTS ARE BEING MADE. ALSO
FOR OWN AGENCIES TO ASSESS AND
ADAPT THEIR PROGRAMS. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO AYE
TESTIFIED TODAY AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER. THANK YOU SO MUCH- SO
MODERATE WILL TURN TO- I DON'T
SEE. SUPPORT IN THE HEARING ROOM
AND WHICH TESTAMENT ROOMS. A
MODERATE LET'S TURN THE PHONE ON
AND- IF THERE GENERAL WOULD IN
SUPPORT JUST FOR NAME
AFFILIATION. AND POSITION ON THE
BILL. SHE COULD OPEN THAT UP.
THANK YOU I TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT FOR S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME WHEN FILED
BY ZERO. TESTIFIED SUPPORT FOR
SB ELEVEN TWENTY THREE. MISTER
CHAIR NOBODY IS QUEUING UP OKAY
VERY GOOD I WILL TURN OUT TO A
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THAT WE
HAVE NONE LIST ON FILE SEEING
NONE IN THE HEARING ROOM LET'S
TURN TO THE LINES ANYONE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION-
MODERATE POLICE OPEN LINE. THANK
YOU I DETEST BY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE SP ELEVEN TWENTY THREE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD YEP ONE ZERO
ARE. STARFALL BY ZERO AT THE
START OF A YEAR TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY THREE THANK YOU. AMATEUR
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP OKAY VERY
GOOD I WILL BRING BACK TO THE
DICE AND TAILORED I MOVED THE
BILL THAT'S A MOTION FOR CENTER
LAYERED- ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS PRESHEAF WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE STANDING UP FOR
ALL THE SMALL COMMUNITIES OUT
THERE TO GET INTO THESE VERY BIG
POTS AND- YEAH THANKS FOR
WORKING WITH US EIGHT. RIGHT
JUST BILL AND LOOK FOR SEEM TO
MOVE FORWARD- THAT'S MOTIONS
CENTER LAYERED YOU WANNA CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS OKAY- CHIEF CONSULTANT IS
CALDERON- I'M SORRY THE MOTION
IS. TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
A MINUTE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. FILE ITEM FOR S. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY THREE WITH MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY STERN. I
DON'T TURN ON A JONES JONES HI
ALLEN. ALLEN ALL RIGHT EGGMAN
GROVE HI GROUP ARE YOU HERTZBERG
HUESO LAYERED HI LAYERED ALL
RIGHT LOAN. LEAVE A MEASURE ON
CALL THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATE
CAREER THANK YOU SEE IT YOU-
AND- FOR.
COME BACK. CENTER DADDO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. YOUR MIKE
COME ON UP- FILE ITEM FIVE S. B.
TWELVE NINETEEN. YOU CAN OF THE
PODIUM AS WELL AND OUR ATTENTION
THANK YOU I HOPE SO. IT'S
TUESDAY RIGHT. OKAY WELL GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. I'M HERE TO OUR PRESENT
SENATE BILL TWELVE NINETEEN-
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME I HAVE
PARTNERED UP WITH- A MEMBER OF
THE LEGISLATURE OF THE
LEGISLATURE ON WATER THAT IS NOT
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY. I AND
THAT IS BECAUSE WATER SECURITY
IS NOT JUST. ABOUT THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IT'S NOT JUST AT THE
CALIFORNIA ISSUE IT'S A GLOBAL
ISSUE. AND REPORT AFTER REPORT
TELLS US THAT WATER SCARCITY
NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT IN A NEXUS
FRAMEWORK WITH FOOD HEALTH
ENERGY AND SECURITY ALL PART OF
IT. EIGHT TWENTY TWELVE A
COMMUNITY INTELLIGENCE
ASSESSMENT REPORT ON THE STATE
OF GLOBAL WATER SECURITY
INDICATED. THAT BETWEEN TWENTY
TWELVE AND TWENTY FORTY FRESH
WATER AVAILABILITY WILL NOT KEEP
UP WITH DEMAND ABSENT MORE
EFFECTIVE MANAGEMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES. THE REPORT ALSO
STATED THAT DURING THE NEXT TEN
YEARS SO BETWEEN DID THAT TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND MOVING FORWARD
THE DEPLETION OF GROUNDWATER
SUPPLIES AND SOME AGRICULTURAL
AREAS OWING TO POOR WATER
MANAGEMENT WILL POSE A RISK TO
BOTH NATIONAL. AND GLOBAL FOOD
MARKETS. IT ALSO POINTED TO
WATER INSURED BASINS WILL
INCREASINGLY BE USED AS LEVERAGE
THE USE OF WATER AS A WEAPON OR
TO FURTHER AT TERRORIST
OBJECTIVES ALSO WILL BECOME MORE
LIKELY BEYOND THE TEN YEARS.
THIS LEVERAGE WILL BE APPLIED IN
INTERNATIONAL FORUMS AND ALSO
INCLUDE PRESSURING INVESTORS NGO
ORGANIZATIONS. AND DONOR
COUNTRIES TO SUPPORT OR HOT OR
HOT WATER INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS. IN PART THIS IS WHY I
HAVE BEEN SO PERSISTENT IN
FIGHTING BACK ON MISINFORMATION
ABOUT SENATE BILL FIVE FIVE NINE
. AND THIS YEAR MARKS MY THIRD
EFFORT TO PROVIDE CRITICAL
FUNDING. FOR THESE CONVEYANCE
PROJECTS THAT DELIVER WATER TO
FARMS AND SERVE THIRTY ONE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS. BUT I
BELIEVE MORE MUST BE DONE TO
SECURE OUR FUTURE IN CALIFORNIA
WE BELIEVE THAT WATER IN
CALIFORNIA. CENTER CORTESE AND
I'VE- MUST BE MODERNIZED. ANY
WEIGHT THAT WE I JUST SPOKE TO
IN THAT CONTEXT. AND I WANT TO
GIVE YOU ANOTHER EXAMPLE WE TOOK
OUT THE CONCERN OF CYBER ATTACKS
ON OUR WATER AND FOOD SECTORS TO
THE ALLEY GOES OFFICE LAST YEAR.
AND THE RESEARCH THAT BE FOUND-
BE CONCLUDED THAT IT THERE WAS A
LACK OF DEDICATED CYBERSECURITY
FUNDING AND STAFF LIMITS A
PREPARED IT'S OF CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE SECTOR ENTITIES.
ARE THEY ALSO NOTED AN
INCREASING NUMBER OF CYBER
ATTACKS. ON AND VARIATION IN
CYBER SECURITY PREPAREDNESS OF
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE SECTOR
ENTITIES. THE FREQUENCY OF CYBER
ATTACKS AGAINST CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE ENTITIES
INCLUDING THE WATER AND
WASTEWATER SYSTEMS SECTOR. AND
OF COURSE THE FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE SECTOR ARE
INCREASING. IN TWENTY TWENTY
ALONE OUT THERE WERE AN
ESTIMATED FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND
CYBER ATTACKS WITH PAYOUTS
TOTALING ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS. HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ACROSS ALL ENTITIES
INSTRUCTORS. IN THE FIRST SIX
MONTHS OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THE
WE WERE ALREADY OUTPACING TWENTY
TWENTY WITH THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND CYBER ATTACKS. REPORTED
IN THE STATE WHAT THE TOTAL
AMOUNT OF PAYOUTS BEING UNKNOWN
REPRESENTING AN ANNUAL INCREASE
OF 62% THERE HAVE BEEN GREAT
INCREASES IN ATTEMPTED ATTACKS
ON OUR CYBER NETWORKS THAT MANY
OF OUR UTILITIES AND WE KNOW
THAT ONE OCCURRED JUST LAST YEAR
AND IT WAS MADE EVIDENT THAT OUR
WATER AND WASTEWATER TREATMENT
PLANTS FOR AT RISK. AND THIS
ATTACK THE HACKERS TARGETED THE
CHEMICAL TREATMENT OF YOU
DRINKING WATER PIPE AND THE BAY
ARE RAISING THE CHEMICALS TO
DANGEROUS LEVELS. FORTUNATELY
STAFF AT THE PLANT NOTICED THE
INCREASES AND MANAGE TO REVERSE
THEM BEFORE WAS TOO LATE FOR IT
TO CAUSE ANY HARM. BUT THEY'RE
STILL- MANY OF OUR FULL SALARIES
COULD ARE STILL AT RISK FROM
SUCH ATTACKS AND MANY YOU KNOW
OF THESE ATTACKS ARE DONE- OF
COURSE AT THE WORK IS DONE
REMOTELY SO TO COMBAT A
DIFFERENT TIME OF UNCERTAINTY US
SENATOR CORTEZ UNITE. YOU KNOW
WE'RE WORKING TO IMPROVE THE
TRANSPARENCY OF HOW DECISIONS
SURROUNDING WATER ARE MADE AND
THOSE THAT MAKE THEM. WE
INTRODUCED SENATE BILL TWELVE
NINETEEN ALSO KNOWN AS A STATE
WATER RESIDENCIA MODERNIZATION
ACT TO PRIORITIZE PRESERVATION
AND SUSTAINABILITY OF WATER
USAGE AND ENSURE THE WATER IS
PROTECTED FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS
OF USE. IT IS NOT ENDED IT'S NOT
INTENDED TO BE AN INSULT TO. YOU
KNOW THE MEMBERS OF THE OF THE
WATER BOARD OR ANYTHING OF THAT
SORT BUT REALLY IT'S TO SPEAK TO
THE URGENCY OF THE WATER ISSUES
IN THE STATE AND THEY'RE ONLY
GROWING AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING. TO MODERNIZE IT. IT'S
MANAGEMENT. MODERNIZING IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWO
MEANS INCREASING TRANSPARENCY
ANNEXED ANYWAYS FOR PEOPLE TO
NAVIGATE PROCESSES AND
PROCEDURES ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO WATER. CURTAILMENTS AND
WHAT A HOLISTIC VISION FOR WATER
IN CALIFORNIA LOOKS LIKE. AND AS
YOU JUST MENTIONED FROM- YOUR
COLLEAGUE CENTER COUPLE YET
EITHER THERE'S AN ISSUE HERE AT
HAND THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS
PEOPLE HAVE TROUBLE WITH
ACCESSING FUNDING FOR- A CLEAN
SAFE DRINKING WATER. LIVING
WITHOUT WATER ESPECIALLY IN A
STATE WHERE IT IS IT RIGHT. TO
WATER. AT WE CAN LOOK AT A
PARENT'S INABILITY TO FEED OR
BAIT THEIR CHILD WITH WATER FROM
THE TAP. A SENIOR WHO CANNOT
AFFORD TO BUY WATER TO LIVE ON
OR IF FORMER HAVING TO FALLOW
LAND. ALL OF THESE BEINGS
THREATEN OUR HUMAN SECURITY AND
ALL OF THEM COME BACK TO OUR
CHANGING CLIMATE. WE MUST WORK
TIRES TIRELESSLY TO FIND
SOLUTIONS TO PROTECT OUR WATER.
WHICH BY DEFAULT WILL PROTECT
OUR FOOD SUPPLY CHAIN AND I
REALLY WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE
FOOD SUPPLY CHAIN AS WELL
BECAUSE- I BELIEVE IT WAS JUST
LAST WEEK. THE PRESIDENT WAS
TRAVELING ABROAD AND HE SAID
THERE WILL BE SHORTAGES THIS IS
THIS IS JUST A REALITY AND NOT
JUST IN EUROPE AND UKRAINE OR IN
THE MIDDLE EAST. BUT HERE IN THE
US AS WELL AND SO OUT WE
DEFINITELY DON'T WANT TO- ADD TO
THAT. ARE GIVEN THAT. UP IN LAND
WILL BE VALID FOR BASED ON THE
DISK YOU KNOW DECISIONS THAT WE
MAKE OR WE DON'T MAKE. AN
INCREASINGLY OUR FOOD IS BEING
IMPORTED AS WELL SO JUST WANTED
TO POINT POINT THAT OUT WITHOUT
SAID. I AM WILLING AND HAPPY TO
TAKE AMENDMENTS TO SECTION- ONE
OF MY BILL AYE. AYE AS OUTLINED
ON PAGES SIX THROUGH TEN AS THE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS ARE WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE I FEEL LIKE
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO CRAFT THESE
AMENDMENTS. THE DIG DEEPER INTO
THE CHANGES WE NEED TO MAKE TO
MODERNIZE WATER MANAGEMENT OUR
STATE. OUT AND I REALLY WANT TO
THINK- THE CONSULTANT THAT
DENNIS FOR. ARE REALLY JUST
TAKING THE THROUGH THE VISION
THAT CENTER CORTEZ AND I. HAD
AND A PUTTING IT INTO INTO-
LANGUAGE AND IN THE FIRST
SECTION THERE WE APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU- BUT I CANNOT TAKE IT
WILL NOT TAKE THE AMENDMENTS TO
SECTIONS TWO AND THREE AND ON
PAGE ELEVEN REMOVING THE
PROVISIONS ELIMINATE THE WATER
BOARD AND TRANSFER ITS
RESPONSIBILITIES.TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES.
THE AMENDMENTS TO SECTION ONE
MAKE THIS BILL STRONGER. TH
MEMBERS TO SECTIONS TWO AND
THREE MAKE IT WEAKER. MY
DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA NEEDS
REAL CHANGE THAT'S WHAT SECTIONS
TWO AND THREE GIVE THEM. SO I
ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
THAT FORM. AND I HAVE TO
WITNESSES HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE NINETEEN
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT YOU TO JUST
TAKE MY WORD FOR IT I WANT YOU
TO HEAR FROM PEOPLE. ARE YOU
KNOW IN MY DISTRICT FIRST HAND.
AND HAVE SCOTT TAYLOR A GENERAL
MANAGER OF THE LAMONT PUBLI
UTILITY DISTRICT AND I ALSO HAVE
A FRIEND CAL GALVIS A COMMUNITY
MEMBER FROM TO THE STAND. UP AND
MIGHT END IN MY DISTRICT HE TOLD
THE ONE TRIED JUST LAST YEAR.
THANK YOU CENTERTIDO UM WILL
TURN YOUR LEAD WITNESSES- ON THE
LINE. I THINK IT'S MISTER TAYLOR
FIRST. CAN YOU GUYS HAVE
COLLECTIVELY THREE MINUTES. HI
MY NAME IS SCOTT TAYLOR CAN YOU
FOLKS HEAR ME OKAY YEAH WE GOT
YOU I'M CLICK. OKAY EXCELLENT
I'LL BE I'LL BE A BRIEF AND
CLEAR. I WOULD ASK WHILE LACED I
ASKED MEMBERS COMMITTEE THE
PLEASE LISTEN. AND PAY ATTENTION
TO WHAT I HAVE TO SAY BECAUSE
pYOU'RE BUSY READING OTHER THINGS
BUT JUST GIVE ME NINETY SECONDS
AND I'M OUT OF HERE. MY SPEECH
IS A CHOREOGRAPHED I DIDN'T
WRITE A BIG LONG THING I'M JUST
GOING TO GIVE IT TO YOU FROM THE
GUT AND THE REALITY. AS SENATOR
HOT HER TADO JUST MENTIONED.
HERE'S THE REALITY OF IT I WORK
FOR A SEVERELY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY WE PROVIDE WATER AND
WASTEWATER. THE REALITY IS THAT
THE WATER BOARD AS A WHOLE.
NEEDS TO BE REVAMPED. NOW I'M
NOT HERE TO THROW ROCKS AT
PEOPLE OR BASH OR ANYTHING BUT I
CAN TELL YOU AND YOU'VE HEARD
THIS PHRASE BEFORE. IF WE
CONTINUE TO DO THINGS WITH THE
WAY WE'VE ALWAYS DONE THEM WE'RE. ALWAYS GOING TO GET THE SAME
RESULT. S. IN SOUTH. CAN AGREE
WE DO NOT WANT THE SAME RESULT
IN THE WATER ENVIRONMENT. SO I
WOULD ASK THAT THIS BOARD IN
THIS PANEL ON THIS COMMITTEE
VOTE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
FOR JUST THOSE REASONS SOMETHING
NEEDS TO CHANGE. THE PROCESSES
FOR GETTING GRANTS IT'S
COMPLICATED IT'S LABORIOUS IT
TAKES YEARS. LONGER THAN YOU'VE
BEEN IN THE SENATE IT TAKES
LONGER THAN THAT JUST TO GET A
DECENT GRANT. YES THERE HAVE
BEEN CHANGES IN THE WATER BOARDS
TRYING TO MAKE THOSE CHANGES SO
I HAVE TO GIVE PROPS WORDS.
WHERE IT'S NECESSARY HOWEVER. IT
SHOULDN'T TAKE TWENTY YEARS TO
MAKE A ONE YEAR CHANGE SO. THESE
ARE SOME OF THE THINGS THAT I
THINK MISTER TOTAL- SENATOR HER
TADO IS TRYING TO PRESENT. IT'S
TIME TO RE VAMP. JUST LIKE THE
PREVIOUS BILLS WERE THEY TALK
ABOUT WE HAVE TO REDO THINGS IN
WILD FIRES AND FIRE PREVENTION
ECCENTRIC. FOR TOO LONG IT'S
BEEN IN A PARTICULAR WAY. TRULY
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT BECAUSE COMMUNITIES
LIKE MINE. ARE DIæN ON THE VINE.
WE NEED TO HELP. THE FUNDING. IS
THERE BUT WE CAN'T GET TO IT.
OKAY IT'S THE IT. THERE'S TO BE
STE NO THE KEEPERS OF THE KEYS
HAVE LOST THE KEYS WE NEED NEW
KEEPERS TO FIND THOSE KEYS OR RE
KEY THE LOCKSSO WE CAN PROVIDE
WATER. TO PEOPLE. OF YOUR STATE
YOUR COMMUNITY. I MEAN THIS IS A
REAL LIFE PEOPLE THEY'RE NOT
FIGMENTS OF OUR IMAGINATION SO I
WOULD JUST ASK THIS COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL- IN ITS AS
PRESENTED. FOR JUST ALL THE
REASONS THAT I'VE I'VE JUST
PRESENTED TO YOU I'M HAPPY TO
RESPOND IN ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE BRIEFLY. BUT THE LONG AND
SHORT OF IT IS. CHANGE NEEDS TO
HAPPEN. OKAY JAMES NEEDS TO
HAPPEN WE HEARD YOU LOUD AND
CLEAR AND WENT BEYOND NINETY
SECONDS OF LISTENING ACTUALLY TO
THREE THREE FULL MINUTES SO
YOU'VE TAKEN UP ALL THE TIME FOR
LEAD TEST MONEY BUT OUT OF.
DEFERENCE TO THE AUTHOR I DO
WANNA LET- WHOEVER WHAT DOES
YOUR SECOND WIND IS JUST MAKE A
BRIEF COMMENT IF YOU COULD. I'M
LIMITED TO FIFTEEN SECONDS IF
YOU DON'T MIND YOUR YOUR EAD
WITNESS AT YOUR FIRST WITNESS
WENT WENT OVER. AT I'M SORRY ME
THE- THIS IS MISTER EVAN. MEANT
GALVIS. MY MAKING A BRIEF BRIEF
COMMENT. YOUR LINE IS OPEN OKAY. CALPERS WOULD YOU LIKE THIS
PART YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
THANK YOU AND BECAUSE THE OTHER
WITNESS WENT LONG IF YOU MIND
MAKING IT SHORT WE APPRECIATE IT
THEY ARE LITTLE. OUR OUR WILL-
ARE WE NEED TO MAKE WATER
RETENTION THE NUMBER ONE GOAL
FOR CALIFORNIA- BECAUSE WATER
OUT WE ALL SUFFER THE
CONSEQUENCES NO WATER TO FEED
THE CHILDREN THE WASH CLOTHES
BRUSH OUR TEETH AND FORCED
TOWARDS. SO YOU KNOW WATER
RETENTION BUILDING DAMS.
PROVIDING- FORTY FOR THE
INTEREST. OF THE OF THE
WATERWAYS IS VERY CRUCIAL. TO
OUR EXISTENCE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND WE
HEAR YOU LOUD AND CLEAR- OTHER
ANY OTHER WITNESSES NOW THEY
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN GENERAL
SUPPORT- EITHER IN THE HEARING
ROOM SEEING NONE BUT OR ON THE
LINES. OF GENERAL SUPPORT FOR SB
TWELVE NINETEEN JUST YOUR NAME
AND WHERE YOU'RE FROM AND YOUR
POSITION IF YOU DON'T MIND. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
FOR S. B. TWELVE NINETEEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE ONE SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES AGAIN THIS
IS FRANK GALLAGHER I'M IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE TWO ONE NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND FOR
ANYBODY ELSE BUT IT ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE TWO
ZERO SEVEN TWO OH SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TWO OR SEVEN YOU ARE
OPEN. ONE MORE TRY TWO OR SEVEN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
ON YOU. OKAY WE'LL MOVE FORWARD. ALL RIGHT NEXT WE WILL GO TO
LINE. TWO THIRTY NINE TO THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE TO
THIRTY NINE YOU ARE OPEN. YOU
CAN HEAR THEM BUT THAT'S OKAY
LET'S GET YOU IN FOR THAT'S ALL
RIGHT THAT'S THE MOVE THERE'S
NOBODY ELSE THINK YOU AT THIS
TIME OKAY AND ANYONE WHO DOES
HAVE QUESTIONS COMMENTS ALSO IN
SUPPORT IS FREE TO- WEIGH IN
WITH THE COMMITTEE AS WELL- OKAY
SO WE'LL MOVE NOW TO. LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES I BELIEVE
WE HAVE TWO AND A ONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ONE ON THE LINE
IS THAT RIGHT- SO MISTER
SULLIVAN ARE AND THEN MISTER OBG
. I THINK WE'RE GONNA MISTER
SOUTH OF OUR FIRST. WELCOME GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN BIRDS ARE MY
NAME IS WOULD IT TELL ME ABOUT
AND I'M WITH THE COMMITTEE WATER
CENTER AND WE ARE A COMMUNITY
BASED ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
NONPROFIT THAT WORKS ALONGSIDE
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE WITH THE MOST DIRE WATER
NEEDS AND REALLY WHAT I FIRST
WANT TO SAY APPRECIATE THAT
COMMITTEES WORK ON THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS- BUT WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE BILL AND ESPECIALLY
AND IT'S PROPOSED FORM TO
DISSOLVE THE STATE WATER BOARD-
AS WE FEEL THAT IT WILL ONLY
EXACERBATE MOST PRESSING WATER
NEEDS IN THE STATE WHICH
INCLUDES HAVING A MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT ACCESS TO
SAFE DRINKING WATER- SINCE
TWENTY TWELVE WHEN CALIFORNIA
DOCTOR THE HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER
THE STATE WATER BOARD HAS
ACTUALLY. BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN
ADOPTING AND PUSHING VERY
CRITICAL WATER PROGRAMS
INCLUDING SPEARHEADING THE
STATE'S DRINKING WATER PROGRAM
FOR ADOPTING CONTAMINATION
PROTECTIONS BEGINNING TO
ADMINISTER THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FIND
OUT ALONG WITH ROBUST COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT FOR RURAL AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THROUGH THE SAFE ADVISORY GROUP
AND ADOPTING A VERY DETAILED AND
ROBUST RACIAL EQUITY POLICY-
WHILE THE- BOOK. PROPOSED RIBBON
COMMISSION ON CONTAINS AN
UNDEMOCRATIC PROCESS TO PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS. FOR THE
LEGISLATURE- WHICH WOULD BE.
SEVERAL YEARS BEFORE I CAME
THROUGH- TO THE LEGISLATURE TO
BEGIN TO ADDRESS THE WATER
INEQUITIES. THE- THE LACK OF-
ADOPTING THE MINUTES WHO-
RELATING TO THE DISSOLUTION OF
THE BOARD AS- OF PARTICULAR
IMPORTANCE AND- PROBLEMATIC FROM
OUR POINT OF VIEW. ESPECIALLY AS
PROXIMA AGENCIES SUCH AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER ARE NOT
PROPERLY EQUIPPED OR- AND STAFF
TO RESOURCE TO ADOPT THESE
CRITICAL WATER PROGRAMS. I IN
THE MIDDLE. OF DROUGHT AND
CLIMATE CHANGE WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE SIGNIFICANT WORK TO.
BOLSTER AND PROTECTING THE WATER
FOR THE ENTIRE STATE- AND IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT NOTE THAT WHILE
THERE ARE BOTTLENECKS AT THE
STATE WATER BOARD THE- HOUSE THE
WATER BOARD HAS PROVEN TO BE
RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS OF THE
STATE INCLUDING. OF DELIVERING
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS AND WATER
DEBT RELIEF THROUGH THE WATER
WITH RE REACH PROGRAM JUST THIS
LAST YEAR RELATED TO THE
CODEPENDENT MAKE- SO. WE WOULD
WE HAVE SEEN THIS BODY
INTENTIONALLY- BEGIN TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE KNOWN BY MAKES OUT
OF THE WATER BOARD AND INSTEAD
OF ADOPTING SB TWELVE NINETEEN
EVEN WITH THE- PROPOSED-
AMENDMENTS WE- FOR EXAMPLE. OF
OUR FIRST THE CONSIDERATION OF
ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND
ALLOCATIONS TO ADDRESS SOME OF.
THE CRITICAL WORK AND
BOTTLENECKS- IF SO THAT WE CAN
BEGIN ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
ISSUES RELATED TO WATER QUALITY
AND- APPLICATION- FOR THESE
REASONS WE OPPOSE AND
RESPECTFULLY URGE FOR YOUR NOVEL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- WILL NOT
TURN THE SECOND THE WITNESS I
THINK YOU'VE GOT ABOUT A MINUTE
LEFT OUT OF THE THREE MINUTES
ALTHOUGH. BECAUSE WE GAVE THE
OTHER WITNESS ABOUT FIFTEEN
SECONDS AS EXTRA KALIDA A MINUTE
FIFTEEN MISTER OBG. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN GOOD MORNING WBG ON
BEHALF OF THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL I'VE ALSO BEEN
ASKED TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL ON BEHALF OF
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE- ENERGY
SEEN DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE NO ON THE
BILL- WE APPRECIATE THE WORK BY
COMMITTEE STAFF BUT
UNFORTUNATELY. THE PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE THE STATE WATER BOARD
AND TRANSFER AUTHORITIES TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
THIS IS UNWORKABLE. UNDERMINES
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IN
DECISIONS OVER THE WATER- YOU
WATER PROJECT DOES HOLD WATER
RIGHTS AND SO EFFECTIVELY AS THE
MANAGER OF THE WATERING SYSTEM
IT WOULD BE REGULATING ITSELF
CREATING AN ENTIRE CLIP IT. OF
INTEREST FOR EVERY OTHER WATER
RIGHTS HOLDER AND ALL OF US WHO
DON'T HOLD WATER RIGHTS BUT WHO-
THE CONDITIONS ON WATER RIGHTS
PROTECT THE PUBLIC AND OTHER
USERS. SECOND THE WATER BOARD
AND THE REGIONAL SPORTS HAVE AN
EXTENSIVE PROCESS FOR. PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION BEFORE DECISIONS
ARE MADE INCLUDING A BOARD THAT
IS APPOINTED. BY THE GOVERNOR
AND APPROVED BY THE SENATE- THAT
REPRESENTS A BROAD RANGE OF
INTERESTS. AND YOU TO BE OUR
LACKS THAT STRUCTURE- WE ARE
ALSO CONCERNED THAT ESTABLISHING
A BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION COULD
DELAY MUCH NEEDED REFORMS TO OUR
NETBALL WATER RIGHTS SYSTEM. FOR
ALL THESE REASONS WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE NOW THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE- JUST
GENERAL WITNESSES ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM SEEING NONE. ANYONE
ON THE LINES- JUST. NAME
AFFILIATION A POSITION ON THE
BILL PLEASE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR TO TESTIFY IN OP. TO SB
TWELVE NINETEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE ZERO AND
WE WOULD LIKE. I TWO SEVENTY YOU
ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING DANIEL
BROWN ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT. X. WE WILL
GO TO LYING TO NINETY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CASH JACKPOT. THINKING
FOR MYSELF AND NOT FOR THREE
FIFTY DOLLARS IN VALUE THIS IS A
DIRECT THEIR CLIMATE BILL BUT I
AM AND STRAW OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE WILL ALIGN ONE SEVENTY
THREE YOU ARE OPEN. THIS IS
SANTIAGO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTING IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU NEXT. TWO
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING MICHAEL CLAIBORNE WITH
THE LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR
JUSTICE AND COUNT ABILITY ALSO-
OFFERING COMMENTS FROM WATER
OUNDATION A CLEAN WATER ACT AND
IN STRONG OPPOSITION OKAY THANK
YOU. WHY DO EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TWO EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN
IS THAT ME YES IT IS. I'M SORRY
I THOUGHT I ALREADY DID IT- MY
NAME IS INTOLERANCE AND DORMER
I'M A MONTEREY COUNTY AND WE I'M
IN OPPOSITION WE NEED THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT. THANK YOU EIGHTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S ASHLEY OVER
HOUSE AND RESILIENT REVERSE
DIRECTORS ON FOREVER AND WE ARE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB TWELVE
NINETEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE TO NINETY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO PETER DIRECTOR WITH
THE TWELVE ME RIVER TRUST THE
VAULTING THE STATE WATER BOARD
THE TERRIBLE IDEA BY THE TO
REGISTER OUR STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AN ONLINE
FORTY EIGHT YOUR OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS CODY PHILLIPS I'M WITH
CALIFORNIA GO DEEPER LAN JOHN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. SURE THERE
ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED
UP. OKAY I'M SEEING THAT WE'VE
HEARD. ALL SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION- I MAKE A BRIEF
COMMENT AND BRING IT BACK TO THE
DICE- YOU KNOW IT WHEN IT COMES
TO POLITICS OF WATER AND ARE
LEGISLATIVE SOLUTIONS IT'S- THE
WATER BOARD IS ALWAYS AN EASY
TARGET. AND AS SOMEONE WHO HAS
FAMILY IN AGRICULTURE AND
FARMING AND RANCHING- I KNOW
THAT'S THE COMMON GREAT BUT- I
THINK THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION ON THIS DISSOLUTION
NOT JUST RUN CONFLICT OF
INTEREST BUT AROUND- SOME OF THE
MAJOR EQUITY AND
INTEGRITY ISSUES AROUND THE
DELTA AND MORE BROADLY- TO ME.
MAKES THIS THAT THE DISSOLUTION
PORTION OF THIS BILL- INCREDIBLY
PROBLEMATIC AND THAT'S WHY THE
COMMITTEE DID PROPOSE- TO STRIKE
OUT- THOSE SECTIONS BUT I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE STAFFS
HARD WORK AND THE AUTHORS HARD
WORK. ON TRYING TO PUT A GOOD
FOOT FORWARD HERE ON A BROADER
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION THAT THAT
HOPEFULLY WOULD IDENTIFY A LOT
OF THE NEEDS EVEN IF THE
OPPOSITION THEMSELVES REYES- AND
I WOULD I WOULD ASSUME. THAT
THIS WILL NOT IN ANY WAY IMPEDE
OR SLOW DOWN- THE DELIBERATE
PROCESS THAT'S BEEN GOING ON TO
DELIVER JUSTICE ALL THOSE
COMMUNITIES- SO I'D I'D BRING IT
BACK TO THE DICE WITH WITH THOSE
COMMENTS IN MIND. I RECOGNIZE
SENATOR HERTZBERG PERFECT- THANK
YOU STRIVE A REALLY ON ECHO YOUR
COMMENTS IN THE WORK OF. YOUR
GOOD STAFF WHO I HOLD IN THE
HIGHEST REGARD AND SO I'D LIKE
TO AYE I'D HEARD I AM FORTUNATE
TO RACE UPSTAIRS AND WASN'T SURE
I CLEARLY HEARD. BY THE AUTHOR'S
THOUGHTS ON THIS BUT TO MAKE IT
CLEAR I WON'T MISS YOU CHERYL AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME MAYBE IF
IT'S NOW IS THAT OKAY. I'D LIKE
TO MOVE THAT WE PASS THIS
MEASURE SB TWELVE NINETEEN AS
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED BY THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. AND NOT IN
ANYTHING LESS THAN THAT WHICH
INCLUDES THE NEW FINDINGS YOU
WOULD BE AFFECTED. REWORKING
RIBBON SHE'S A REWORKED BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION AND STRIKE THE
TWO PROVISIONS THAT ELIMINATE
THE STATE WATER BOARD IF THAT'S
OKAY THAT'S MY MOTION. OKAY SAID
TO MOTION FROM SENATOR FOR ITS
BERG- SO JUST TO BE CLEAR WILL
BE VOTING ON THE BILL WITH ALL
THE AMENDMENTS- IN THE COMMITTEE
IN OUR RIGHTS. SO THAT MOTION IS
A DO PASS AS A MAN BUT FIRST A
MINUTE RE REFER TO ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. I WOULD ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
MEMBERS I'D ENTERTAIN THEM BUT
WE CAN ALSO COME BACK TO THE
AUTHOR FOR. CLOTHES YES SIR HE I
FEEL LIKE. I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
THE MOTION I THINK THAT'S THE
RIGHT DIRECTION BUT- I FEEL THAT
SINCE THERE WAS AN ANIMATED
DEBATE. A LITTLE OF IT SHOULD BE
COMMENTED ON AND- OF. THE EASE
THE DENTURE STING THING HERE'S
THIS. IF I WERE STILL NEED
MINISTRATION THIS WOULD BE
TRANSFERRED FROM THE WATER BOARD
TO ME. AND THE- OF. IT IN. HER I
WOULD OPPOSE THAT. IT EXCEPT FOR
THEIR THERE IS AN ORGANIZATIONAL
AND HISTORICAL REASON FOR DOING
IT AND THAT IS THE ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY WAS SET UP. TO
HANDLE AGENCIES THAT REGULATE.
AND THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY
WAS SET UP TO MANAGE NATURAL
RESOURCES. AND THERE IS A
REGULATION OF THE WATER RIGHTS
SYSTEM. AND THERE'S A MANAGEMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES AND THAT IS A
PRO PRICKLY SEPARATE AND THERE
WAS A TIME I WAS IN THE MIDDLE
OF IT I WAS A WASTE BOARD MEMBER
IN THE LEGISLATURE ABOLISHED THE
WHITES BOARD AND IMMEDIATELY
SENT AWAY SUPPORT FROM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
TO RESOURCE. ONE OF THE FIRST
THINGS I ADVOCATED THE SECRETARY
OF RESOURCES WAS REORGANIZING
AND MOVING IT BACK WHICH WE DID
BECAUSE IT WAS A REGULATORY.
AGENCY AND IT BELONGED IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL AGENCY THAT DID
REGULATION. AND IN THE TESTIMONY
I TOOK SOME NOTES. WHAT ONE OF
THE ADVOCATES FOR THE BILL ON
AMENDED SAID WE NEED TO BE
BUILDING DAM WE NEED TO BE
FUNDING MONEY FOR MORE
INFRASTRUCTURE. NONE OF THAT IS
WITHIN THE PURVIEW OF THE AGENCY
WHETHER IT'S MOVED OR NOT BUT
THAT SHOULD NOT BE AN ARGUMENT.
FOR BLOWING IT UP THERE WAS
ANOTHER COMMENT THAT. WHAT
REGARD TO WATER GRANTS AND CLEAN
WATER GRANTS THAT IT TOOK TWENTY
YEARS WHILE THE CLEAN WATER
PROGRAM IS ONLY BEEN IN THE
WATER BOARD FOR THREE OR FOUR
YEARS. OF SO IT WAS SORT OF THAT
WAS THE REASON IT WAS MOVED IS
THE PREVIOUS LOCATION OF THAT
GRANTS PROGRAM WAS NOT GETTING
THE MONEY OUT THE DOOR AND THE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT SHOWS.
THAT THAT HAS BEEN ADDRESSED
SUBSTANTIALLY IN THE MOVE
BETWEEN THE AGENCIES. AND I
THINK WHAT'S AT THE ROOT OF THIS
IS THE VERY DIFFICULT QUESTION.
THAT HELLO I HAVE RIGHTS TO MORE
WATER IN CALIFORNIA THAT EXISTS
AND THEN WE GIVE AN AGENCY THE
OBLIGATION TO MEDIATE THAT
SITUATION. AND IN AUSTRALIA WHEN
THEY HAVE THE NINE YEAR DROUGHT.
THEY ACTUALLY REVAMPED THE WATER
RIGHTS SYSTEM. AND THEY DECIDED
THEY WOULD ASSIGN A CERTAIN
AMOUNT TO AGRICULTURE A CERTAIN
AMOUNT TO MUNICIPAL A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF THE ENVIRONMENT AND
HAVE IT MATCH WHAT THE NEEDS
WERE AND WHERE THE WATER WAS.
AND WE HAVE AN ANTIQUATED SYSTEM
THAT DOESN'T GIVE OF RIGHTS TO
PEOPLE IN A WAY THAT THEY WANT
TO CONSERVE OR THAT THEY CAN
TAKE MORE THAN MIGHT BE
AVAILABLE FOR THE ENVIRONMENT
AND OTHER THINGS AND SO. I THINK
THAT THE PROPER LEGISLATIVE WAY
TO GO IS WHAT IN THIS MOTION
BECAUSE IT IS WE SHOULD STAND
BACK FROM JUST ASSUMING THAT
BLOWING UP AN AGENCY IS THE
ANSWER TO ALL OUR- OUR CONCERNS.
BUT TO HAVE A CONVERSATION TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS AND THEN
DECIDE WHAT THE NEXT STEP IS AND
THAT'S WHY I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS MOTION. THANK YOU THE
CONTEXT AND THE COMMENTARY- SO
THE MOTION. IS A IS TO PASS AS
AS AMENDED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS BUT FIRST AMEND RE
REFER TO THE ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY COMMITTEE SEEING NO
FURTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
SANATANA WOULD LIKE CLOSE. ONCE
AGAIN EMPHASIZE REITERATE THAT-
I REALLY STRUGGLE I FEEL STRONG
ABOUT THIS BECAUSE OF THE ISSUES
AND CHALLENGES THAT I SEE IN MY
DISTRICT THAT CHALLENGES. AND
THE FRUSTRATIONS THAT THEY THAT
THEY FEEL AND THIS BILL AGAIN
THIS IS NOT TO THROW ANYONE
REALLY UNDER THE BUS IT'S JUST
THAT. WHEN WE TALK ABOUT WATER
WE NEED TO DO IT IN A WAY THAT
WE NEED TO MODERNIZE IT I MEAN
LOOK THESE. THE LAWS THAT PUT
THAT THE WATER CONTROL BOARD
LIKE BOOK IN NINETEEN SIXTY
SEVEN WAS WHEN THE WATER AT THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD. WHAT WAS RELEVANT THEN IS
NOT RELEVANT NOW. RIGHT WERE
LIVING IN A DIFFERENT TIME AND
THAT'S WHAT I WAS TRYING TO. PUT
ACROSS IN MY IN MY IN MY TALKING
POINTS IS THAT NOW WE HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT CYBERATTACKS WILL
WHO'S GOING TO DEAL WITH THAT
WHO THAT WHO HAS TO REGULATE
THAT WHO'S OVERSEEING THAT
NOBODY. NOBODY'S OVERSEEING THAT
OUR WATER SYSTEMS ARE AT RISK WE
NEED TO MODERNIZE AND SO- IT
THIS WEEK YOU KNOW ALSO I WANT
TO YOU KNOW. POINT OUT THAT THE
RESPONSIBILITIES WOULD PPULUM
UNAIDED I MEAN I'M NOT SAYING
HEY LOOK WE GOT ELIMINATE THE
RESPONSIBILITIES I. SIMPLY- JUST
. THINK THAT THIS IS A GOOD
START RIGHT- I KNOW THERE'S ALSO
MENTION ABOUT THE SAFE ADVISORY
BOARD. AND FUNDING FOR CLEAN
WATER PROJECTS WILL. I'M A PART
OF MY PART OF MY CHALLENGE YOU
KNOW AFTER THE SIGNAL FOR WILL
DRINKING FUND ACT HAPPENED WAS
MAKING SURE THAT THE- FUNDING
ACTUALLY WENT TO PROJECTS AND
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE WHAT WAS
HAPPENING IS THAT A LOT OF IT
WAS BEING SPENT ON. ON OVERHEAD
- IT YOU KNOW IT IT DOES IT'S
TAKEN COMMUNITIES HERE'S AND
THERE'S ALL THESE OTHER. HURDLES
AND CHALLENGES THAT THEY HAVE TO
OVERCOME TO BE ABLE TO GET.
PROJECTS MOVING AND MOVING
FORWARD AND- AND THAT'S WHY I
HAVE TO REALLY YOU KNOW ONCE
AGAIN THANK- THE CONSULTANT FOR
THIS COMMITTEE DENNIS BECAUSE-
IN A PART OF HIS COMMENTS IN
INDIA ANALYSIS IS THAT. I MAY
WANT TO BROADEN IT AND YES THAT
WOULD THAT I. THAT'S THE WHOLE
POINT OF. A PUTTING FORWARD THIS
THIS- THIS POLICY IDEAS TO
REALLY BROADEN IT BECAUSE WE
HAVE. TWENTY FOUR- AB STATE
ENTITIES THAT GOVERN WATER ONE
WHAT SMEHOW OR SOMEWAY TWENTY
FOUR. IMAGINE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES HAVING TO DEAL WITH
THE TRYING TO GET CLEAN WATER
AND HAVING TO NAVIGATE ALL THESE
DIFFERENT ENTITIES. I DON'T I. I
DON'T KNOW HOW TO DO IT I MEAN.
I DON'T I DON'T KNOW IF ANY ONE
OF US WOULD KNOW HOW TO DO THAT-
DEFECATE THIS THIS COMPLICATED
OUR- SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE BEEN IN
PLACE- AND I AGREE THAT IT
LOOKED THERE'S THE- PROPS
DEFINITIONS MAYBE THAT'S
PERHAPS. WHY WERE SEEN INCREASES
IN FREEZE TO WITHIN THE STATE
WATER BOARD. THERE WAS SOME LAST
YEAR THERE'S PROPOSALS THIS
YEAR. R. I MEAN I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S GOT BE LOOKED OUT WE GOT
TO HAVE. SOME SORT OF
TRANSPARENCY OR- OVERSIGHT OVER
OVER THE SPORT OVER THE SPORT AT
MINIMUM I THINK IN MY OPINION.
AND WHILE I'VE GOT YOU I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE- YOU'RE A
CONSULTANT IN THE COMMITTEE
MOVING THIS BILL FORWARD- I
STILL THINK THAT THIS SECTION
ONE IS JUST. REALLY MUCH NEEDED
R. AND WHILE I KNOW THAT.
PERHAPS THE SUPPORT MAY NOT BE
THERE IN TERMS OF ELIMINATING
THE WATER BOARD- I'D I'D STILL
LIKE TO SEE THAT THAT THAT
PROVISION AT MINIMUM BE ABLE TO
MOVE FORWARD. AND SO- I JUST
WANTED JUST ALSO. I SAY TO
ADDITIONAL THINGS ON PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION. ATTEND A WATER
BOARD MEETING MEETING YOU'LL
KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE
PARTICIPATE. NOT MANY NOT MANY
CONSTITUENTS NOT MANY PEOPLE
FROM THE STATE CALIFORNIA THE
OTHER THING WATER RIGHTS SYSTEMS
OUR WATER RIGHTS SYSTEM WE HAVE
TO BE REALLY CAREFUL ABOUT HOW
WE APPROACH IT AND MAKING SURE
THAT. WE JUST DON'T JUMP THE GUN
UNTIL WE GOT TO DO THIS AND EXT
YOU KNOW CHANGE AT ALL AND- WE
HAVE TO BE VERY CAUTIOUS ABOUT
THE WAY WE DO NOT SEE THAT WE
DON'T NEED REFORM TO SAYING
THAT. WE HAVE TO BE CAUTIOUS
ABOUT IT BECAUSE THIS IS A
NATURAL RESOURCE THAT IS VERY
PRECIOUS AND VERY. MUCH SCARCE
AT THIS POINT I THINK- SO- WITH
THAT- I WILL. I WILL. HAVE
RESPECTFULLY CLOSE AND THANK YOU
ALL AND DENNIS FOR WORKING WITH
ME ON ON THE- FIRST SECTION-
AND- HOPEFULLY. YOU CAN SUPPORT
THE BILL. OKAY THANK YOU. SORRY
MR CARE CAN GET A POINT OF
CLARIFICATION SURE BOUNCING
BETWEEN YES ON THE MOTION YES
THANK YOU SO THE MOTION IS. TO
AMEND THE BILL WITH ALL THE
PROVISIONS IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS SO THAT INCLUDES THE
CHANGE TO SECTION ONE BUT ALSO-
THE STRIKING OUT OF THE
DISSOLUTION OF THE WATER BOARD
SAID SO THE MOTION MADE BY
CENTER HERTZBERG. WOULD BE THE
INTO ALL THE MOMENT SUGGEST. AND
THAT IS BEFORE US SO WE'VE HAD A
CLOSE THAN OF CLARIFICATION
OKAY- CHIEF CONSULT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL FILE ITEM FIVE S. B.
TWELVE NINETEEN THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY STERN STERN ALRIGHT
JONES. ALAN EGGMAN. GROVE
HERTZBERG. HUESO LAYERED HI
LAYERED ON A LOAN. IT'S YOUR
MOTION MR KELBERG. WE CAN HELP
OKAY. OKAY WE WILL SO JONES
ALLEN EGGMAN GROVETON HERTZBERG
RIGHT HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT HUESO
LA ON LIMÓN ALL RIGHT THAT HAS
OKAY. THANK YOU KNOW IF THERE'S
A LOT OF MULTI TASKING IT'S OKAY
OF THAT MEASURE IS FOR VOTES WE
WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU CENTER
TADO PREACHING- WE'LL KEEP CAN
WE KEEP IT MOVIN HERE TO BE OF
ANY OTHER AUTHORS THE OKAY.
WHAT'S THE ORDER THAT. NO NO ALL
THREE OF THE REAL HARM ALL
REMAINING ON OKAY STAY IN. TO
HEARING GO TO CENTER EGGMAN.
UNLESS THEY WANT TO NEGOTIATE
AWAY. OKAY PROBLEM- ALL RIGHT
GOES OVER TO CENTER HURTS.
LANDED THE SEVEN FILE ITEM NINE.
NUMBER ONE THAT'S ABOUT THE BEST. HI- SOME. THANK YOU- SPEAKING
OF WATER. SPEAKING OF CHALLENGES
RELATED TO WATER. THE BOTTOM
LINE IS WE GET LESS OF IT. AND
LOTS OF CHALLENGES RELATED TO IT
AND I JUST WANT TO OPEN MY
COMMENTS WITH RESPECT TO THIS
MEASURE BY READING JUST A COUPLE
OF HEADLINES. IN VARIOUS MEDIA
OUTLETS THAT I THINK FORM THE
BASIS OF ME DOING THIS BILL.
SIERRA SNOWPACK FAILS TO FALLS
TO ONE OF ITS LOWEST LEVELS IN
SEVENTY YEARS THE MERCURY NEWS.
DATA SHOWS THE DRIEST YEAR.
DRIES JANUARY THROUGH MARCH IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY AB SEVEN
NEWS. LAKE POWELL IS ABOUT TO
DROP BELOW CRITICAL LEVEL
REACHED. A NEVER REACHED BEFORE
IS DROUGHTS RAGES ON CNN AND
LASTLY WESTERN. MEGA DROUGHT IS
WORST IN TWELVE HUNDRED YEARS
AND I KNOW YOU AROUND SENATOR. A
LAYERED BUT IT'S A LONG TIME AGO
. IT INTENSIFIED BY CLIMATE
CHANGE STUDY FINDS. WITH THAT
BEING SAID MEMBERS AND I'LL TRY
TO MAKE THIS AS FAST AS I CAN
BECAUSE IS A LOT OF OPPOSITION.
WE'VE GOT A SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM.
IN SO WHAT HAPPENED A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO. INSTEAD OF ALLOWING
THE GOVERNOR BROWN TO DO A- A
TRAILER BILL. ASSEMBLY WHAT A
WOMAN- FRIEDMAN AND I PUT
TOGETHER TO BILLS. PACKAGE OF
BILLS DEALING WITH- WATER
CHANGING CONSERVING WATER AS WE
KNOW IT. IN PART OF THAT
ENDEAVOR OF WHAT WE DID TO SOME
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO AS WE ASK-
THE D. W. R. A. TO. TO TAKE A
LOOK AT AT INDOOR STANDARDS. AND
THEY COME BACK AND REPORT AND
THAT'S WHAT THEY'VE DONE. AND SO
WHAT WE WHAT WE HAVE HERE IN
TERMS OF THIS BILL IS TO TRY TO
SET THOSE STANDARDS. ARE ARMED
AND IF YOU LOOK FOR EXAMPLE JUST
LAST WEEK'S EXECUTIVE ORDER BY
GOVERNOR NEWSOM. THERE'S ANOTHER
STARK WARNING IS I SUGGEST TO
THE TO WHAT I TALKED ABOUT ABOUT
THE HEADLINES DEALING WITH THE
WORST DROUGHT. THE WORST OF THE
DROUGHT HAS YET TO ARRIVE. AND
WHAT I GOT TO SAY IS THAT THIS
IS ABOUT EFFICIENCY AND WE AS A
STATE. HAVE ALWAYS BEEN ON THE
FOREFRONT OF EFFICIENCY I
REMEMBER WHEN WE WERE DEALING
WITH WITH THE ELECTRIQUE
ELECTRICITY STANDARDS AND FOR
APPLIANCES BACK WHEN GOVERNOR
BROWN THE FIRST GOVERNOR. THE
SECOND GOVERNOR BROWN THE FIRST
JERRY BROWN. DID THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION'S IT IS
IMPOSSIBLE TO MEET THE STANDARDS
FOR APPLIANCES WILL GUESS WHAT.
NOW THE WHOLE COUNTRY HAS AT THE
R. P. S. THE RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO
STANDARDS A 20% IMPOSSIBLE TO
MEET. SAME THING EXIT EXAMPLE
AFTER EXAMPLE TAIL PIPE
EMISSIONS WITH CENTER PAVLEY.
THAT WE WORKED ON WHEN I SERVED
IN GOVERNMENT LAST TIME. AND SO
NOW WE'RE IN A SITUATION WHERE
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS TO SET THE
INDOOR STANDARDS OF WATER- WHICH
IS REQUIRED STATUTORILY IS
RESULT OF OUR LEGISLATION.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN FRIEDMAN AND MY
AND MY OWN. ARM AND THERE'S BEEN
A TWO YEAR EFFORT IN WHICH THIS
IN WHICH WE'VE HELD HEARINGS
SOLICITED INPUT. AND FEEDBACK
FROM DOZENS OF ORGANIZATIONS TO
TRY TO DEAL WITH THIS LARGER
ISSUE. AS WE FACE THIS
EXTRAORDINARY DROUGHT AND I. I
ALWAYS LOOK AT THE ISSUE WATER
FOR A COUPLE MORE POINTS BEFORE
I. OPEN IT UP TO THE- SO PORTERS
A THIS. IS THAT YOU KNOW IS WE
THINK ALL OF US FROM DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE STATE THE CENTRAL
VALLEY NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. A
SUCH A YOU KNOW SAN DIEGO ON THE
LIKE. YOU ALWAYS SEE THESE
HORRIBLE CHALLENGES OVER WATER
BUT THE FARMERS NEEDED OF COURSE
TO PRODUCE EXTRAORDINARY CROPS
THAT THEY GROW- ENVIRONMENT
NEEDS IT BECAUSE THE CHALLENGING
ENVIRONMENT FACES. WE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WHEN I WENT
DOWN TO. TO IMPERIAL COUNTY THEY
CALL THIS THE COASTAL'S AND WE
HAVE YOU KNOW IRRIGATION AND
SWIMMING POOLS AND GOLF COURSES.
AND SO WE HAVE TO CHANGE YOUR
PATTERN GIVEN THE FACT THAT
CLIMATE CHANGE IS REALLY
IMPACTING THIS WE'VE HAD A HUGE
FIGHT. I JUST GOT ANOTHER EMAIL
FROM SOMEBODY FROM ANOTHER STATE
YESTERDAY BETWEEN THE ALLOCATION
OF THE COLORADO RIVER. YOU KNOW
THAT WE WERE OVER DRAFTING
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE CALIFORNIA
VERSUS ARIZONA NINE HER THOUSAND
ACRE FEET. I WORKED ON THE
QUANTIFICATION SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT NOW THAT- IS OWNERS
GOING NOW THAT LAS VEGAS IS
GOING SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
SOMEBODY IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
RESEARCH. YOU KNOW RESEARCHERS
MIGHT KNOW SOMETHING ABOUT THAT
I GOT SO SURE BUT MAYBE. SO
WHAT'S HAPPENING IS THE ISSUE IS
NOW THE- THE STATE LACK THE DATA
TO DEAL WITH THE INDOOR WATER
USAGE NOW WE'VE HIT THAT. WEEK
WE'VE HAD THE STATE MAKE THOSE
DETERMINATIONS AND SO NOW. ON
WHERE WE AT AND WHAT WE TRYING
TO DO WITH THIS BILL WE'RE
CHANGING THOSE INDOOR NUMBERS
NOW THERE'S SOME CRITICISM THAT
PEOPLE ARE SAYING. WELL YOU KNOW
YOU CAN'T FLUSH THE TOILET TAKE
A SHOWER BUT ONCE A MONTH. IT
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS A GREAT SOUND BITE BUT IT'S
NOT TRUE. AND I KNOW THAT THEIR
SOMETIMES TO STILL MATTERS IN
THIS BUSINESS WHAT IT DOES IS WE
ALREADY EXCEEDING SOME OF THOSE
STANDARDS AND IT'S SUCH A- IT'S
SUCH A BROAD STANDARD OF WHAT
INTO IT WOULD YOU SHOULD SHOULD
BE NOT. INDIVIDUALLY BUT SYSTEM
WIDE IN BUILT FLEXIBILITY FOR
POTABLE REUSE AND ALL SORTS OF
THINGS LIKE THAT. IS IT GONNA BE
MORE EXPENSIVE SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION SAID NOTHING'S LESS
EXPENSIVE THAN CONSERVATION. YOU
KNOW WHAT MAKES AN ASSUMPTION IT
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO HAVE
WATER IF WE AS A STATE DON'T SET
THAT POLICY C. NG. CON AS A WAY
OF LIFE AND SHE HOW. COMPORT
OURSELVES. CLIENT THIS IS A HUGE
ELEMENT OF CLIMATE CHANGE THOSE
HEADLIGHTS TWELVE HUNDRED YEARS
CENTER LET WILL TELL YOU WHAT IT
WAS LIKE BACK THEN. AND SO ALL I
CAN TELL YOU IS THAT. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WAS DONE AS A
RESULT OF. STATE WATER BOARD
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES.
AND WE'RE TRYING TO TAKE IT TO
THE NEXT STEP IN WITH THAT- WE
HAVE TWO WITNESSES SUPPORT
HEATHER COOLEY FOR THE PACIFIC
INSTITUTE AND LAUREN UP FROM THE
LOS ANGELES ALLIANCE FOR NEW
ECONOMY. I ASK YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG MODERATOR LET'S MOVE
TO THE PHONE LINES AND BRING ON
HEATHER COOLEY FROM PACIFIC
INSTITUTE AS THE CO HOST. FOR
THE CO SPONSOR THIS BILL.
BECAUSE AT. MY NAME IS HEATHER
COOLEY ON BEHALF OF PACIFIC
INSTITUTE I'M CALLING TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL ONE ONE
FIVE SEVEN. A SENATOR HERTZBERG
WRECK THE REFERENCE EIGHTY
FIFTEEN FIFTY EIGHT AND SET
SENATE BILL FIFTY SIX. OFF RIGHT
IF YOU ARE IN THE STATE WATER
BOARD TO CONDUCT. AND TO STUDY
SEES ME INDOOR WATER USE AND
JOINTLY RECOMMEND UPDATED INDOOR
STANDARD. IN RESPONSE TO THE
STATE AGENCIES CONDUCTED AN
EXTENSIVE ANALYSIS ON INDOOR
WATER USE THAT INCLUDED DATA
FROM A MILLION CUSTOMER ACCOUNTS
IN NEARLY A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
URBAN WATER SUPPLIERS. THE STUDY
FOUND THAT MEDIAN INDOOR WATER
USE WAS FORTY EIGHT GALLONS PER
PERSON PER DAY BETWEEN. TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN TO TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. THE SHELTER
IN PLACE ORDERS- IN RESPONSE TO
THAT CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
NATIONALLY INCREASED WATER USE
BUT RECENT DATA SHOW THAT THE
INITIAL BECAUSE THAT CITED AN
INDOOR WATER USE IS WELL BELOW
PRE PANDEMIC LEVELS. INDOOR
WATER USE IS DECLINING DUE IN
LARGE PART TO CALIFORNIA'S
STANDARDS IMPOSED THE GERMAN THE
BEST IN THE COUNTRY. THE IDEA
YOU ARE STUDY FOUND THAT BY
TWENTY THIRTY ABOUT 3039% OF
SUPPLIERS WOULD BE BELOW THAT
RECOMMENDED TWENTY THIRTY
STANDARD. WITH HALF OF
CONSERVATION ALONE THAT MEANS
WITH JUST THE AFFECT OF
STANDARDS AND CODES. ACTIVE
CONSERVATION PROGRAMS RUN BY THE
UTILITY THE NUMBER OF SUPPLIERS
BELOW THE STANDARD WOULD BE.
EVEN HIGHER. SOME OF THE
EXPRESSED CONCERN ABOUT THE
EFFECTS ON A STANDARD ON
RECYCLED WATER AND WASTEWATER
SYSTEM. LAST YEAR THE STATE
BOARD PRESENTED ITS METHODOLOGY
FOR AN ASSESSMENT OF THE EFFECT
OF THE STANDARD AND THOSE
FINDINGS WILL BE INTEGRATED INTO
THE RULE MAKING PROCESS THE
TICKET AND TAKE THAT INTO
ACCOUNT. IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT THERE'S
SIGNIFICANT FLEXIBILITY
INTEGRATED INTO A FRAMEWORK TO
HELP SQUIRES MEET THEIR
OBJECTIVES. FIRST QUARTER TO NOT
HAVE TO MEET THE INDIVIDUAL
STANDARDS THAT MAKE UP THEIR
OVERALL OBJECTIVE MISCARRY
IRIZARRY TENERIFE BINGE YOU HAVE
EXCEEDED YOUR THREE MINUTES AND
SO WOULD ASK YOU TO WRAP IT
AFTER EIGHTEEN MINUTES. YES I'M
TO MIDDLETON I FINALLY AND
THERE'S ANOTHER THERE IS A
NOTHER- LEAD WITNESS- MISS
HAKEEM SO IF YOU COULD WRAP UP
YOUR COMMENTS. WOULD BE GREATLY
APPRECIATED. YES HOW DEFENDER
FEATHER SIGNIFICANT FLEXIBILITY
THAT ACCOUNTS FOR THIS AND WITH
RESERVOIRS NOW LOW OUR SNOW PACK
AT 38% WE MUST TAKE PROACTIVE
STEPS. TO MAKE CONSERVATION A
CALIFORNIA WAY OF LIFE AND I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
SENATE BILL ONE ONE I THANK
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS COOLEY-
LET'S MODERATOR LET'S GO TO A
LAUREN ACT KEEN I BELIEVE. AND
YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE MA'AM. THANK
YOU FOR CAMDEN TESTIFYING TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
ALLIANCE FOR A NEW ECONOMY WHERE
WE'VE BEEN WORKING TOWARDS
ENVIRONMENTAL ECONOMIC AND
RACIAL JUSTICE SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY THREE. AND WHILE NEARLY
HALF OF WATER AGENCIES WANT NEED
TO IMPLEMENT THE- WATER
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS TO MEET
THESE TARGETS THOSE THAT DO WILL
BE ALSO HELPING TO ADDRESS
EQUITY AND AFFORDABILITY OF
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT MOST
URBAN WATER CONSERVATION AND
EFFICIENCY MEASURES ARE LESS
EXPENSIVE THAN OTHER WATER
SUPPLY OPTIONS AND ARE A COST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO MEET CURRENT
AND FUTURE WATER NEEDS. AND A
STUDY BY THE ALLIANCEFOR WATER
EFFICIENCY FOUND THAT LADWP
CONSERVATION PROGRAMS HAVE
HELPED AVOID ELEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN WATER COSTS AND SAVE
CUSTOMERS TWENTY SEVEN PERCENT-
THAN WHAT THEY OTHERWISE WOULD
HAVE PAID AND WE NEED DEEP WATER
EFFICIENCY IMPROVEMENTS NOW MORE
THAN EVER FOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE STRUGGLING
WITH CODE RELATED THAT. TO HELP. IMPROVE THE AFFORDABILITY OF
THEIR WATER. ON AS WELL AS- THE
POTENTIAL FOR SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING MADE AVAILABLE TO WATER
AND AGENCIES TO HELP INVEST IN
WATER EFFICIENCY IMPROVEMENTS.
SHOULD DRAFT. AND ADVANCED
EQUITY AND LONG TERM WEIGHT
WATER IMPACT BIKE. THAT HE IN
IRAQ SHARE COMMENTS. I AM VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. LET'S MODERATOR
MOVED TO OUR EXCUSE ME MODERATE
WILL COME RIGHT BACK TO YOU WILL
MOVE TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN
THE COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM. C.
NINE MISS A MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE QUEUE UP THE FIRST
WITNESS IN SUPPORT- ON THE ON
THE PHONE LINE LET ME REMIND ALL
WITNESSES THAT THIS IS STATING
YOUR NAME. AND YOUR SUPPORT OUR
POSITION ON THE BILL. THANK YOU
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OUT WE ARE
IN SB ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN CORRECT
YES SIR SB ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH-
PLEASE PRESS ZERO. FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME SHE ABOUT. AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO SEVENTY YOU
ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING DANIEL
BROWN ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA AND- THANK YOU SIR
NEXT LINE MODERATOR. THANK YOU
WILL ALIGN ONE SEVENTY THREE YOU
ARE OPEN. WELL SANTIAGO WITH
CALIFORNIA'S VIVUS LOADERS AND
FORKLIFTS THANK YOU NEXT RIGHT.
WE WILL GO TO Y. FORTY- THE OKAY
BAKER THREE YOUR PHONES WHEN
SPEAK IT'S GOING OVER THE WILL
GO FOR EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS CODY PHILLIPS
CALIFORNIA CODE PEOPLE ALLIANCE
IN SUPPORT AND GIVE. THANK YOU
NEXT. THANK YOU LINE THREE OH
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME'S ASHLEY OVER HELP ON
BEHALF OF FRIENDS OF THE RIVER
AND WE SUPPORT SB ELEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT.
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY YOU ARE OPEN.
LIKE TO EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
HELLO RENDON DORMER MONTEREY
COUNTY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
YEAH WE'LL GO TO LINE A ONE
SEVENTY YOU ARE OPEN. HI THIS IS
TRACY QUINN WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
REGISTER SUPPORT FOR THE MONO
LAKE COMMITTEE THANK YOU. FIGURE
MUCH NEXT. TWENTY TWO NINETY ONE
STORY AT. ALL. REP MARK WALL ME
RIVER TRUST IN THE FOURTH. THANK
YOU NEXT. AND WE HAVE A
EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME
OKAY VERY WELL- WE'LL TURN NOW
TO OPPOSITION I DO HAVE A
LISTING ON. ANY IN THE HEARING
ROOM I BELIEVE WE HAVE TO LEAD
WITNESSES- MISS HALL AND- NO
WELL MATIC AND- THE THERE ON THE
LINE MAYBE COULD START AT THIS
TIME MODERATOR. SO YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES COLLECTIVELY. YES
THE MORNING CARE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JULIA HALL THAT THE PHYSICIAN
OF CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY ON AT ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN
RESPECTFULLY HAVE POSITION OF
OPPOSING WITH AMENDED ON THIS
BILL AND I WANT TO THANK SENATOR
HERTZBERG AND HIS STAFF FOR THE
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND OUR CONCERNS. AND
HOPEFULLY ADDRESS THEM THIS BILL
IMPLEMENTS THE JOINT
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES IN
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD ON AN INDOOR
RESIDENTIAL WATER USE STANDARD.
BILL WOULD REDUCE INTEREST UNDER
TO FORTY SEVEN GALLONS PER
CAPITA DAILY IN TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE AND FURTHER REDUCE THE
STANDARD TO FORTY TWO GALLONS
PER CAPITA DAILY TWENTY THIRTY
THE FOCUS OF OUR PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS THAT ADDITIONAL
THIRTY OF AN APPROPRIATE COST
EFFECTIVE STANDARD FOR TWENTY
THIRTY. AWKWARD COMMITTED TO
LONG TERM WATER EFFICIENCY BUT
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THIS BILL
WOULD IMPLEMENT COULD NOT
QUANTIFY IMPACTS TO WATER
WASTEWATER AND RECYCLED WATER
THE REPORT IDENTIFIED A NUMBER
OF SERIOUS IMPACT BUT THEY WERE
NOT QUANTIFY IT AND THEY DID NOT
INFORM THE FINAL RECOMMENDATION.
FOR A THIRD THE COST OF MEETING
THE TWENTY THIRTY STANDARD WAS
NOT CONSIDERED AN INDEPENDENT
ECONOMIC ANALYSIS BY THE
CALIFORNIA WATER EFFICIENCY
PARTNERSHIP FOUND THAT THE COST
TO WATER SUPPLIES TO MEET THE
TWENTY THIRTY WATER SUPPLIERS TO
MEET THE TWENTY THIRTY STANDARD
WOULD BE BETWEEN TWO POINT EIGHT
AND FOUR POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS. THIS ESTIMATE DOES NOT
INCLUDE COST IMPACT TO WASTE
WATER AND RECYCLED WATER
CUSTOMERS AND SUPPLIERS FINALLY
THE STUDY DID NOT INCLUDE A
COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT THE IMPACT
OF THE COCA NINETEEN PANDEMIC
AND THE LONG TERM IMPACT OF
MILLIONS OF MORE PEOPLE WORKING
FROM HOME. FOR THESE REASONS WE
URGE THE COMMITTEE. TO CONSIDER
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
WITNESS IN OPPOSITE. NEXT WE'LL
BOTH WANT I'M I'M SORRY ONE MORE
LEAD OPPOSITION I BELIEVE. AND
WITH THE VERY. JERRY GOOD
MORNING KAREN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MILAN ATTIC AND I AM THE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
ADMINISTRATOR FOR THE CITY OF
ROSWELL WE ARE FULL SERVICE CITY
PROVIDING WATER WASTEWATER
RECYCLED WATER SOLID WASTE AND
ENERGY SERVICES TO A GROWING
COMMUNITY I THINK HER WITH JULIA
COMMENT ON THE IMPACT TO WATER
AND WILL FOCUS MY COMMENTS ON
IMPACT TO OUR WASTE WATER AND
RECYCLED WATER UTILITIES. FIRST
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
HERTZBERG FOR ITS WORK ON THE
CONSERVATION LEGISLATION AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT ROOSEVELT
ALTERNATELY SUPPORTED WE BELIEVE
THAT LEGISLATION PROVIDED AN
APPROACH THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO
BALANCE THE BENEFITS OF
EFFICIENT WATER USE ANY IMPACT
TO OUR SYSTEM AND OUR RATE.
HOWEVER AS SECTION SEVEN POINT
ONE SEVEN POINT FOUR OF THE W.
R. REPORTS STATE THE RECOMMENDED
ENDORSED STANDARDS WHAT HAVE I
KNOWN THE FACT ON AFFORDABILITY
BECAUSE THE STUDY DID NOT
ANALYZE THE POTENTIAL. ECONOMIC
IMPACT- IN THE HEIGHT OF THE
DRAW INTO FOURTEEN. IS WHEN.
CAME BECAUSE THIS TO THE TWENTY
FIVE AND AREN'T. AT JUST. OF OUR
WAY WATER STREET PLANT WITH FIVE
SIX PERFECT COSTLY FROM A
DROUGHT YEAR THREE NINE DROPPED
HERE. THE LONG TERM IF. WOULD BE
EVEN MORE TO AND NEEDED A-
UPGRADES AND THEIR MAKE AND-
LASTLY THE LOWER. WITH ALL.
LIMIT HE POTENTIAL BENEFICIAL
USES OF RECYCLED WATER SYSTEM WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
SENATOR ON THIS LEGISLATION. AND
HELP WE WILL AGAIN BE ABLE TO
FIND A POLICY THAT STRIKES A
BALANCE BETWEEN COSTS AND
BENEFITS. AND ULTIMATELY BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT HIS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY. THANK YOU TURN TO.
WITNESSES AND- SO MODERATE IF
YOU COULD JUST OPEN THE LINES
I'M SORRY. IN THE HEARING ROOM-
WE HAVE FEW. WE'LL START HEARING
HEARING OUR MODERATOR THEY'LL
TURN THE LIGHTS OF RHINO JACKING
WITH THE REGIONAL WATER
AUTHORITY AND AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION LOOKING FORWARD
TO CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JASON I CAN
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
WILL ECHO THE COMMENTS ALREADY
MADE INCLUDING OUR GREAT RESPECT
FOR THE SENATOR. AND OUR
WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH AND TALK WITH THAT OKAY
THANKS SO MUCH. WE'LL TURN THE
LINES NOW. HE WOULD LIKE THAT
THAT'S THE PRICE. ON SB ELEVEN
FIFTY SEVEN AND OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE
OH SEVEN FIVE. AND IF YOU'RE
HEARING MEMBERS THIS IS JEFF AND
DAUGHTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SANITATION
AGENCIES WITH AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION IN LINE WITH
THE COMMENTS FROM AQUA. NEXT
LINE THREE TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR HEARING CENTERS IN
THREE MILLION ON BEHALF MAKES
THE WATER DISTRICT WAS UNLESS
AMENDED OUR COMMENTS ARE ALSO A
LOT OF TALK BUT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ONE FORTY ONE YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR. MISTER TERM MEMBERS
THAT'S A LOSS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA WATER REUSE INLAND
EMPIRE UTILITIES AGENCY AND
CUCAMONGA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT.
ALL OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED AT THE
LINE ARE COMMON WITH MATH HELP
FROM AQUA THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES CAN LEARN YOUR
THINKING PARA ON BEHALF OF THE
IRVINE RANCH WATER DISTRICT AND
EAST VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED CONSISTENT
WITH AWKWARD COMMENT AS WELL.
THANK YOU. ONE ONE FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN
BIRDS ERIC TURNER WOULD NEED A
LOT OF THE THINGS THAT IT ON
BEHALF OF EASTERN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT. BUT RESPECTFULLY
WITH AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ALIGNER ON THAT FROM
OCTOBER THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE THREE HUNDRED YOU ARE OPEN
. IF YOU'RE A MEMBER YEAH. OF
HIGH WATER DISTRICT WE ALIGN
SOME OF OUR CLIENTS NOT BUT IT'S
NOT AT THIS STAGE HE. THANK YOU
NEXT. X. LEVINE THIRTY ONE THESE
AHEAD. YES THIS IS GREG MORRISON
WITH ALPHA VALLEY MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT WITH AN IMPOSING
MUCH MEN AND IN A LINE OUR
COMMENTS WITH MISS HALL FROM
AWKWARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE THREE OH FOUR YOU ARE OPEN
. GOOD AFTERNOON REALLY LOPEZ ON
BEHALF OF WALNUT VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU SO MUCH NEXT. NINE THREE
SIXTEEN EUROPE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI PAUL HAVE OCCURRED WITHIN ONE
WATER DISTRICT WE ARE OFF OF
BOTH THE LEFT AND ENDED WITH
AQUA. NEXT THANK YOU BYE THREE
OH FIVE YOUR OPEN. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
INSURANCE AND ALL THOSE WITH THE
RUNNING PUBLIC POLICY GROUP ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA ROSA
I'M IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL
FOR THE REASONS STATED IN OUR
LETTER THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS
ERICA DONALD WE HAVE TO THE EAST
ORANGE COUNTY WATER DISTRICT AND
THE YORBA LINDA WATER DISTRICT
AS WELL AS THE ORANGE COUNTY
SANITATION DISTRICT IN AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED STAND. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU. NOBODY ELSE NOBODY
ELSE IS QUEUED UP THE SPANISH
CARE OKAY- SPORT IN OPPOSITION
BEING COMPLETED WILL BRING BACK
TO THE DIE ES DE OF IT COMING
FROM CENTER HUESO- THEN CENTER
LET. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A
CENTER HERTZBERG AYE AND- I
SUPPORT GENERALLY THE CONCEPT
OF- WATER CONSERVATION I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY.
NOW IN THE LAST TWENTY YEARS I
THINK CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA'S
EXPERIENCED- A NEXUS OF TWELVE
OF THOSE IN THE NEXT LAST TWENTY
YEARS AT LEAST TWELVE OF IN
DROUGHT YEARS. AND MEMBERS
DEFINITELY- SOME NEED TO
CONSERVE BUT I'M I JUST WANTED
TO EXPRESS MY COMMENTS AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF SAN DIEGO
IMPERIAL COUNTIES SENDIC YOU'RE
SENDING ONE IN PARTICULAR I WANT
TO STATE THAT EVEN PRIOR TO THE
BEGINNING IN THE NINETIES- WHEN
THERE WAS- MASSIVE- TRANSFER
WATER THAT WAS THAT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN DESTINED FOR SAN DIEGO BUT
METRO DECIDED TO KEEP THAT THE
LA AREA. IT FOR SAN DIEGO TO
CONSERVE IN WAYS THAT OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE. HAVE NOT
CONSERVED AND AS FAR SAN DIEGO
THEY HAVE TAKEN ON VERY
AGGRESSIVE CONSERVATION POLICIES
THROUGH. THE THROUGH THE DROUGHT
SENEGAL FARED FAIRLY WELL IN
COMPARISON TO THE WRIST REST OF
THE STATE. IN ALL THE YEARS I'VE
SERVED IN GOVERNMENT- I'M VERY
PROUD OF THE FACT THAT WE WORKED
ON- MAKING IN SAN DIEGO A CITY
THAT RECYCLES ITS WATER. SO NOW
SAN DIEGO IS UNDERTAKING-
SUBSTANTIAL WATER RECYCLING
THAT'S A AND RE USE. AND WE HAVE
SEVERAL- WATER DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY THAT ARE
NOW ENGAGING IN WATER REUSE WE
HAVE PURPLE PIPE THAT'S BEEN
INSTALLED AND IN THE LAST
FIFTEEN YEARS WE'VE ALSO CREATED
A T. CELL FACILITY- IN THE
CARLSBAD AREA THAT'S PROVIDING
QUITE A SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF
WATER TO SAN DIEGO SO. AT AS WE
STAND IN SAN DIEGO THE SEWER
SYSTEM AND IT IS IT'S AT ITS-
POINT OF IF WE REDUCE WATER
FLOWS LITERALLY THE US THE
SEWAGE THAT OUR PIPES KERRY WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO MAKE IT TO THEIR
DESTINATION. AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS A CRITICAL
ISSUE FOR SAN DIEGO AS WELL
IT'LL INCREASE MAINTENANCE COSTS
RE RECORD REGARDING OUR OUR
SEWAGE TREATMENT PLANTS. SO SEND
YOU HAS REACHED A BALANCE IN
TERMS OF HOW IT MANAGES ITS
SEWAGE HOW IT SOURCES ITS WATER
IN AN ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY
WAY AND IT'S- STILL. UNDERTAKING
A VERY AGGRESSIVE CONSERVATION
STRATEGIES SO- YOU KNOW I'M I'M
CONCERNED THAT THIS BILL. WILL
HAVE SOME UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF SAN DIEGO OF
AFFECTING OUR OUR WASTEWATER.
FLOWS AND UPSET THE BALANCE THAT
WE'VE ACHIEVED IN SAN DIEGO TO
ENSURE OUR OUR OUR OUR DAMS ARE
- THE ARE NOT TO THE POINT OF
DEPLETION LIKE OTHER PARTS OF
THE STATE- SENEGAL DAMS ARE WRIT
REGULAR HEALTHY AND WE HAVE
ESTABLISH CONNECTION POINTS
BETWEEN A RECYCLING WATER
RECYCLING PLANTS AND OUR DIESEL
PLANTS TO THE FOUR POINT THAT
THE YOUR YOUR BILL WOULD HAVE A
DETRIMENTAL EFFECT ON SAN DIEGO
AND IMPERIAL COUNTY SO I HAVE TO
FEEL OBLIGATED TO STAY OFF OF
YOUR BILL TODAY. AND I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE WORKING
ON AND HOPEFULLY. BOB YOU
CONSIDER OUR SITUATION IN SAN
DIEGO ON HOW. OF THIS BILL WOULD
ADVERSELY AFFECT US. THANKS FOR
THE COMMENT- I'M GONNA CENTER
LAYERED YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY I DID A SERIES OF BILLS
ON OUTDOOR URBAN LANDSCAPE
IRRIGATION THAT SET UP THE
CURRENT SCHEME. AND IT WHAT ONE
WE DID IT WE HAD DOUBLE WORKING
GROUP IT WAS OVER THREE YEARS WE
DID A MODEL ORDINANCE WITH WHAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DECIDE TO TAKE
THEIR OWN ACTION AND IF THEY
DIDN'T AFTER TWO OR THREE YEARS
THE MODEL ORDINANCE WAS IMPOSED
ON THEM. THERE WAS A WAY TO MAKE
SURE THERE WAS LOCAL CONTROL AND
A PROCESS WHERE EVERYBODY TALKED
AND GOT TO THE AGREEMENT THAT
ALLOWED TO HAPPEN. AND WHAT'S
HAPPENED HERE IS THE AUTHOR AS
IDENTIFIED INDOOR WATER USE AND
YOU CAN SEE FROM THE TESTIMONY
THAT EVERYBODY'S COME OUT OF THE
WOODWORK WITH WHAT THE ISSUES
ARE. AND THE THING I APPRECIATED
IS TO PEOPLE THAT OPPOSE SAID WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO WORK WE WANT
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS SO WHAT WE'RE
REALLY DOING. IS THIS ISSUE'S
BEEN IDENTIFIED AND WERE JUST AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE PROCESS AND
EVEN THE COMMENTS IT JUST MADE
DONE FIVE PROBLEMS AND SO I WANT
TO GIVE THE AUTHOR THE CHANCE.
TO MEET HIS GOAL WITH ALL THE
IDENTIFIED ISSUES AND WORK
THROUGH THEM AND GIVE US A
PRODUCT THAT THAT DOES THIS
BECAUSE INDOOR WATER USE IS
REALLY SIGNIFICANT AND THERE ARE
STILL MANY PLACES FOR
CONSERVATION AND WE DO NEED
CONSERVATION AS A WAY OF LIFE AS
PART OF OUR ALL OF THE ABOVE
WATER STRATEGY WITH THAT IN MIND
I WOULD MOVE THE BILL. OKAY
THAT'S A MOTION FROM CENTER
LAYERED- COMING FROM SALEM THANK
YOU JUST REAL QUICK YOU KNOW AS
AS SOMEONE WHO REPRESENTS A
DISTRICT THAT HAS CONTINUED IN
STATE IN THE DROUGHT DESPITE.
SOME OF THE YOU KNOW. THE PEAKS
- THIS IS. SOMETHING I'M
WATCHING. BUT ALSO I AGREE THAT.
I MEAN IF THERE'S NOT A BILL IS
ON THE CONVERSATION AND SO WE
HAVE TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT THIS- BUT CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THAT. OUR REGIONS ARE
ALL VERY DIFFERENT ARE ADAPTING-
IN TRYING TO ADAPT AND MOVE
FORWARD IN DIFFERENT WAYS
POSSIBLE- BUT CERTAINLY- YOU
KNOW NOT ALL DISTRICTS ARE THE
SAME IN TERMS OF EVEN. ACCESS TO
WATER AND SO- SO HOPEFULLY THAT
WILL ALSO BE PART OF THE
CONVERSATION YOU KNOW HOW THESE
REGIONAL DIFFERENCES KIND OF WAY
IN- BUT I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL TODAY. AND LOOK
FORWARD TO ONGOING CONVERSATION
. VERY OOD- SO THE MOTION FROM
CENTER LAYERED IS DELAYED. AND I
FORGOT TO SAY ONE THING YES WHEN
I WAS HERE TWELVE HUNDRED YEARS
AGO I WENT TO SENATOR HERTZBERG
SCHEME SENIOR. JUST FOR THE
RECORD. OKAY NOW. UPDATED HIM-
BUT YOU HAVE MADE A MOTION AT
THE SAME TIME WHICH IS DUE
PASSED BUT FIRST BE RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP ON ON
THIS ISSUE SENATOR HERTZBERG-
AND NOT JUST FOR INITIATING
CONVERSATION BUT FOR INSISTING-
ON MAKING GOOD ON YOUR YOUR PASS
REFORMS WAS SENT THE SOME MEMBER
FRIEDMAN. ALSO JUST NOTEWORTHY
I'M GLAD TO SEE THAT A LOT OF
OUR LOCAL WATER AGENCIES ARE
ACTUALLY- STILL HOLDING OUT ON
ST OPPOSING THIS BILL AND TRYING
TO WORK THROUGH THIS AS WELL SO.
HAPPY TO SEE THAT- FOLKS ARE IN
A CONSTRUCTIVE PLACE- DID YOU
WANT TO MAKE A QUICK COMMENT.
SURE CENTER GROVE AND THEN IT
WILL- CENTER HERTZBERG CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I DO HAVE
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS SIR IF YOU
DON'T MIND FIRST AND- OBVIOUSLY
THE REDUCTION FROM FIFTY TWO
POINT FIVE GALLONS PER PERSON
PER DAY TOUGH- FORTY TWO
BEGINNING IN TWENTY THIRTY- I
THINK IS DIFFICULT TO ADDRESS.
ESPECIALLY FOR IN HOUSE WATER
USE OU MADE A COMMENT ABOUT- IN
YOUR OPENING STATEMENT YOU MADE
A COMMENT THAT SAID THAT PEOPLE
WERE OVER EXAGGERATING AND THAT
THAT'S NOT WHAT THE CASE WAS IN
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
FLUSH YOUR TOILETS AND ALL OF
THAT. AND I KNOW THAT THERE ARE
A LOT OF- THERE ARE SEVERAL
WATER AGENCIES IN THE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL AND- MMHM
EVEN MORE. THAT ARE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED- OBVIOUSLY DEEP
RESPECT FOR THE CENTER HAS SOME
OF THAT AND MY GUESS YOU WOULD
CALL THEM TWEETERS- WERE
ADDRESSED. ARE YOU CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THOSE INDIVIDUALS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEIR CONCERNS
ARE MET IN THIS BILL OR IS THIS
BILL JUST MOVING FORWARD WITHOUT
ADDRESSING THEIR CONCERNS ALWAYS
TALKED TO. HAVE BEEN WORKING AS
WATER STUFF FOR. TWELVE HUNDRED
YEARS AND OF AND WORK WITH
AUCKLAND SO MANY THE FOLKS ON
BILLS FOR. AN OPERATOR HUNDRED
AMONG A LOT OF OVER THE YEARS I
CERTAINLY KNOW THE PLAYERS AND
WHAT'S GOING ON. I JUST WANT TO
SAY IF I COULD COME TO TERMS IN
THE ANSWER THE QUESTIONS
CHAIRMAN THE CLOTHES. IS LOOK.
THIS ISN'T DONE IN THE BACK THIS
IS IN A BILL THAT I. CAME FROM
NO WHERE THIS IS WATER WHICH-
COULD BOARD DEPARTMENT WATER
RESOURCES THEY SPENT TWO YEARS.
THEY WENT AND BE VIEWED CON
MILLION CUSTOMER RECORDS. ARE
PROVIDED BY THE D. W. R. HIM TO
WATER SUPPLIES. THE SUBMITTED IN
FOR COPART COMMENTS OVER A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY WATER SUPPLY.
AGENCIES IN THE REGULAR
REPORTING AGENCIES THERE'S BEEN
EXTRAORDINARY OUTREACH IN THAT
REGARD OKAY. SO THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT NO ONE'S TALKED
ANYBODY THIS WAS THE AGENCIES
COMING TO ME SAYING OKAY.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN FRIEDMAN YOU DID
THIS CHANGE YOU KNOW
CONSERVATION IS A WAY OF LIFE.
YOU'RE SEEING ON THE ONE HAND.
SENATE HUESO YOU CAN SAY WHAT
YOU WANT ABOUT HOW MUCH WATER IS
GOING TO FLOW BUT IF GOD TELLS
YOU THERE'S NOT ENOUGH WATER.
YOU DO THE BETTER WITH THERE'S A
STANDARD OR NOT. THERE WILL BE A
FLOW SO WE HAVE TO GET AHEAD OF
IT I THINK. AS POLICY MAKERS. IN
AND THE QUESTION THEN BECOMES
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT THE D. W.
R. DID. AND WHAT. STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD DID. THE
ELECTRONIC ANALYZING ELECTRONIC
ANGLE REPORTS FROM SEVENTEEN TO
NINETEEN AGAIN THIS IS NOT IN
THE VACUUM. 78% OF WATER
SUPPLIES ARE ALREADY BELOW THEIR
CURRENT INDOOR STANDARDS OF
FIFTY FIVE GALLONS- RIGHT. AND
LIKE WAS 56% WE'RE TO BLOW THEIR
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
OF FORTY SEVEN GALLONS AND
THIRTY SEVEN ALREADY A HEAD OF
THEIR PROPOSED. TWENTY THIRTY SO
THE EXTENT THAT PEOPLE ARE DOING
REALLY GOOD STUFF IT'S REALLY
HAPPENING. THE LAST THING I
WOULD SHARE IN GOING TO THE
POINT ABOUT FLUSHING YOUR TOILET
TAKING A SHOWER. IS THIS IS NOT
ANALYZED ON ONE INDIVIDUAL
CONSUMER ALL MY GOT USUAL WATER
BILL WHOSE WHICH ALLOCATIONS
GOING TO BE. SPACED ABOUT WATER
DISTRICT. SO SOME PEOPLE HAVE
PURPLE PIPE. GUESS WHAT THE
BENEFITS. SOME PEOPLE ORANGE
COUNTY WATER DISTRICT. BECAUSE
STANDARD IN TERMS OF HUNDRED
THIRTY THOUSAND EIGHT BE
DIVERSE. THEY GET A- AND A
BENEFIT SO IT'S TRYING TO. DEAL
WITH ON THE ONE HAND ALIGNING
POLICY WITH THE HEADLINES I READ
TO YOU ABOUT THE WORLD CHANGING
AND WEVE GOT A PROBLEM. AND WE
HAVE TO GET AHEAD OF IT AND
THERE'S A LOT OF GOVERNMENT
FOLKS OF THE STILL THE STUDY
WITH THE UC AND STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEMS UNDERGOING IT ALL
CERTAINLY CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
EVERYBODY IF ANY NEW DATA ON
ECONOMICS AND STUFF OF COURSE I
WILL. AYE I'M AN IDEOLOGUE ON
THIS I'M JUST TRYING TO DEAL
WITH A VERY SIGNIFICANT.
ENVIRONMENTAL CHALLENGE THAT
WE'RE FACING AND TRYING TO
ALIGN. OUR POLICY IN THE WAY TO
GET AHEAD OF IT SO THAT. YOU
KNOW I LIVED THROUGH THE LIGHTS
GOING OFF THAT WAS PRETTY BAD
WAIT TO TURN YOUR TAP. AND
THERE'S NO WATER WHAT THAT'S
GONNA LOOK LIKE INTO WHETHER WE
CAN SURVIVE THAT. SO WE HAVE TO
BE PRETTY THOUGHTFUL AND WITH
THAT. MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR INDULGENCE I ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE. I THINK YOU FOR
THAT RESPONSE. MY CONSTITUENTS
DON'T HAVE TO WAIT TILL THEY
TURN THE TAP ON NIGHT OF
CONSTITUENTS IN THE PORTABLE
AREA IN THE CENTRAL AREA. THAT
TURNED THEIR TAP WATER FAUCETS
ON EVERY DAY. AND NOTHING COMES
OUT. AND SO AS WE GO- I. LIKE IT
. I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WITH ALL THE OPPOSITION IN
THE WATER AGENCIES WHO ARE
PEOPLE ON THE GROUND THAT ARE
NAVIGATING THIS IS STEPHEN EVEN
THOUGH BOTH OF YOU HAVE BEEN
HERE FOR TWELVE HUNDRED YEARS.
AND I WOULD JUST APPRECIATE IT
IF YOU WOULD CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH PEOPLE ON THE GROUND THAT
ADMINISTER THESE PROGRAMS AND
MAKE SURE. THAT CONSTITUENTS
HAVE WATER AND THAT WAS MY
QUESTION THANK YOU SIR. VERY
GOOD THANKS FOR THE COMMENTS
THANK FOR CLOSING- THE MOTION
IS. DUE PASS BUT FIRST RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATION CHIEF CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
NINE S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS STERN HI. STERN
ALRIGHT JONES. JONES NO ALLEN.
ALLEN ALL RIGHT EGGMAN. EGGMAN
ARI GROWTH NO GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG HIGHWAY SO
. BETTER WORK ON SOMETHING. OKAY
IT WAS HUESO I'D WEAR LAYERED I
MONNING LOW ALL RIGHT. SEVENTY
TWO WITHOUT. OKAY THEN THE BILL
IS OUT WE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE- WE HAVE TWO ITEMS LEFT
AND WE HAVE BEEN INSTRUCTED BY-
YEAH SENATE RULES TO BE COMPLETE
IN THE NEXT FIFTEEN MINUTES SO
WE WILL TRY TO GET THROUGH THESE
B. AS BRIEF AS POSSIBLE WITH
RESPECT TO THE AUTHORS THOUGH-
SO FIRST UP IS FILE ITEM EIGHT
CENTER EGGMAN ARE YOU UP FOR
PRESENTING COMMITTEE RIGHT HERE
OKAY WE'LL GO FOR ALL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE SENATORS OKAY AND
THIS BILL SIMPLY YOU ALL TALK
ABOUT WATER THIS TAKES CARE OF
THE WATER WE HAVE BUY OR
CREATING A COUNCIL THAT WILL
TAKE CARE OF THE DERELICT AND
ABANDONED COMMERCIAL VESSELS
THAT ARE IN THE DELTA AND OUR
PUBLIC WATERWAYS I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE I HAVE TWO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
EGGMAN- EXCELLENT OPENING.
WITNESS IN SUPPORT YOU ARE NOT
OBLIGATED TO TAKE UP THE FULL
THREE MINUTES IF YOU DO NOT WISH
THERE IS ALREADY A MOTION BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE BUT- IF YOU DO
WISH TO TESTIFY YOU MAY YOU CAN
ALSO OBVIATE YOUR TESTIMONY AND
GO WITH THE WILL OF THE
COMMITTEE BUT WE HAVE SERGEANT
AARON APPERSON AND ATTACH A
DRAIN HERE. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
COMMENT. HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON THE
TASHA DURING THE GOVERNOR
RELATIONS AND LEGISLATIVE
OFFICER SACRAMENTO COUNTY HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AS THE SPONSORED SB
TEN SIXTY FIVE. I JUST LIKE THAT
I THINK IT'S UNDER A MEMBER FOR
OFFERING THE BILL AND FOR GREAT
LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUE. A WITH
THAT ALL OUT WE MIGHT DIRECT THE
COMMENTS TO ADD SERGEANT
PEPPER'S AND- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SURGEON AT PERCENT. YEAH
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE OF THE
BRIEFLY STATED- THIS BILL. IS
ADDRESSING A GAP. IN ABILITY TO-
TO ADDRESS ABANDONED DERELICT
VESSELS WE HAVE A RECREATIONAL
PROGRAM WE DON'T HAVE A
COMMERCIAL PROGRAMS AND
COMMERCIAL VESSELS ARE THE SAME
MUSCLE THEY'RE GOING WORKING ON
THE WATER WHICH IS LESS THAN
FIVE YEARS BUILDING. THE
INSTRUCTION ECONOMY THAT WE HAVE
BUT WE DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
GET RID OF ONE THEIR LEFT IN THE
BAND AND PUT IN OUR WATERWAYS.
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR GUYS
CONSIDERATION OF THIS AND HOPE
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU FAVOR
MY SURGEON- OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM HERE
WAS TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE WELCOME I ENERGY I CAN
THANK YOU SENATOR- WITH THE
REGIONAL WATER. AUTHORITY AND
SUPPORT THANKS SO MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON LUCIA MUCH SIR ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
VERY GOOD THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ENTRY AND TWEE
ON BEHALF OF SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
THANK THE AUTHORED THE CARE
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MANY OTHERS
SEEING NONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WILL TURN TO THE LINE'S
MODERATOR. ANYONE WISHING THIS
MY IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
JUST NAME YOU LIKE IDLE AND THE
POSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU'D
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE FILED BY
ZERO TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR
SB TEN SIXTY FIVE. AND WE WILL
LINE TWO EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ROTH BUCKLEY ON BEHALF
OF CS SACRAMENTO OR- THANK YOU
NEXT. ONE ONE EIGHTY EIGHT YOU
ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS BATTLING COOPER NIELSEN
LOOKS MORE ON BEHALF OF YELLOW
COUNTY IN SUPPORT. WILL NEXT TO
FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU FIFTY TO
FIFTY SOME PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU JERRY MEMBERS JERRY
DESMOND WITH RECREATIONAL
BOATERS OF CALIFORNIA SUPPORTING
CONCEPT OF WITH THE CONDITION AS
WE DISCUSSED WITH THE AUTHOR THE
TO ENSURE THAT THE RECREATIONAL
BOATING A BAD OF FUND AND THE
SOURCES OF REVENUES INTO THAT
FUND OR NOT TAPPED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT. AND IT'S FINAL
WRITER PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO
FIND SUPPORT FOR SB TEN SIXTY
FIVE. AND NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUING
UP AT THIS TIME. OKAY I WOULD
TURNED OPPOSITION ANY OPPOSITION
IN THE TEST IN A HEARING ROOM.
SEEING NONE ANYONE THE LINES. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO A SB TEN SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE FALL BY ZERO TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION S. B. ONE
ZERO SIX FIVE. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
. AND WE WILL ALIGN THREE THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THE FUTURE MEMBERS
CALLED HOLY ABOUT HALF THE CITY
OF LONG BEACH IN THE PORT OF
WESTPAC MEADOW IN SUPPORT OKAY
THANKS. AND MISTER CHAIR NOBODY
ELSE IS QUEUED UP FOR OPPOSITION
TO THE SP INDICATE I WILL NOT
THAT IS SUPPORT KNOWN AS KID UP
IN OPPOSITION. MEMBERS WE DO
HAVE A MOTION. FROM CENTER
HERTZBERG YES OKAY THE LIGHT L.
A. CLOSE. BUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE IN A
VERY IMPORTANT WORK TO CLEAN UP
THE VESSELS ABANDONED THAT OUR
COMMERCIAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU FOR THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY CHIEF
CONSULTANTS CALL THE ROLL. FILE
ITEM EIGHT S. B. TEN SIXTY FIVE
THE MOTIONS DO PASSED TO DO JUST
SHIRI STERN ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT
JONES JONES AYE ALLEN ALLEN ALL
RIGHT EGGMAN EGGMAN ARI GROVE
GROVE I HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
HUESO. HUESO I LAYERED LAYERED I
LOAN LOAN RIGHT IT'S OKAY NINE.
THAT MEASURES OUT- WILL TURN TO
OUR LAST ITEM ON FILE HERE TO
ITEM TEN IS B. THIRTEEN NINETEEN
CENTER GROVE WELCOME. YOUR CHAIR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IN
MEMBERS EACH YEAR CALIFORNIANS
CONSUME ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
BARRELS OF OIL EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THAT'S ROUGHLY SIX HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION BARRELS A
YEAR. BUT ONLY A HUNDRED AND
FORTY TWO MILLION BARRELS ARE
PRODUCED HERE IN THIS STATE BY
CALIFORNIA WORKERS FOR
CALIFORNIANS. WE IMPORT THE REST
OF THAT OIL- WHICH IS
TRANSPORTED HERE MOSTLY BY HUGE
OIL TANKER SHIPS. THE AMOUNT WE
SPEND ON IMPORTED OIL IS
ENORMOUS IF OIL IS PRICED AT A
HUNDRED DOLLARS A BARREL
CALIFORNIANS PAY FIFTY MIL SKEWS
ME FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
TO IMPORT THE OIL THAT WE NEED
TO USE EVERY SINGLE DAY. EVERY
SINGLE DAY TRULY THE STATE'S
CURRENT ENERGY POLICY MAKES NO
SENSE WITH FOREIGN IMPORTS WE
HAVE PLACE CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY
SECURITY INTO THE HANDS OF
COUNTRIES THAT ARE ACTIVELY
HOSTILE TO CALIFORNIA'S VALUES.
IN IT COMES WHEN IT COMES TO
HUMAN RIGHTS VIOLATIONS LABOR
RIGHTS AND ENVIRONMENTAL RIGHTS.
THE TOP THREE COUNTRIES THAT WE
DO BUSINESS WITH ACCOUNT FOR TWO
THIRDS OF FOREIGN OIL THAT WE
IMPORT FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY
pHUNDREDS- SHE'S REPORTED TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND BARRELS A DAY AND A
HUNDRED FIFTY TWO MILLION
BARRELS A YEAR. THESE COUNTRIES
ARE ECUADOR SAUDI ARABIA AND
IRAQ. CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA'S
NUMBER ONE SOURCE OF FOREIGN
CRUDE OIL IS ECUADOR. WHICH IS
BEEN STRONGLY CRITICIZED BY
ENVIRONMENTAL AND INDIGENOUS
GROUPS FOR ITS PRACTICE OF CLEAR
CUTTING OR BULLDOZING DOWN THE
AMAZON RAINFOREST ONE STATE THIS
STATE CALIFORNIA IMPORTS HALF.
51% OF ECUADOR'S CRUDE OIL.
SAUDI ARABIA AND IRAQ OR
ANNUALLY HIGHLIGHTED BY THE U.
S. STATE DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS
GROUPS LIKE HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH
AND AMNESTY INTERNATIONAL FOR
THEIR DEPLORABLE HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS IN THESE TWO
COUNTRIES. WE IMPORT FIFTY TWO
MILLION WHEN I SAY WE I MEAN
CALIFORNIA IMPORTS FIFTY TWO
MILLION BARRELS OF OIL FROM
SAUDI ARABIA THIS IS A COUNTRY
THAT WERE BEING GAY OR PART OF
THE LGBT COMMUNITY IS PUNISHABLE
BY DEATH. WOMEN DON'T DRIVE AND
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO VOTE IN
TORTURE IS USED AS A PUNISHMENT
FOR CRIMES. ALL THIS IMPORTED
OIL BROUGHT TO CALIFORNIA BY SIX
HUNDRED TANKER SHIPS. EVERY
SINGLE YEAR THESE TANKER SPEW
MILLIONS OF POUNDS OF CARBON
INTO THE ATMOSPHERE EVERY YEAR
WITH BUNKER FUEL THAT THEY
CONSUME AND THE POWER THAT THEY
NEED TO OFFLOAD THE SOIL. I
UNDERSTAND THAT MY COLLEAGUES ON
THIS ENERGY- SEE INTER ON THIS
COMMITTEE SEE ENERGY DIFFERENT
THAN I DO. BUT TODAY AND FOR THE
C. BUT FORESEEABLE FUTURE
CALIFORNIANS ARE CONSUMING ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION BARRELS OF
OIL EACH AND EVERY DAY THAT WE
DESPERATELY NEED. THAT'S BECAUSE
OIL TODAY IS USED FOR MORE THAN
JUST GAS THAT MOST PEOPLE PUT IN
THEIR CARS. MORE THAN SIX
THOUSAND EVERYDAY PRODUCTS ARE
MADE FOR PETROLEUM SUCH ISSUES.
PHONES TOOTHBRUSHES. VISIT WINE
PLASTIC LINERS THAT YOU PUT IN
YOUR MOUTH AND HOLD ON TO YOUR
HATS BECAUSE TOOTHBRUSHES I
GLASSES HEART VALVES AND
DISPOSAL SPITZ DISPOSABLE BUT
DIAPERS. ARE ALSO A BY PRODUCT
OF PETROLEUM. I WANT YOU TO
THINK ABOUT INC OIL THERE'S A
ORGANIZATION HYPO A LEASE IN MY
DISTRICT THAT 85% OF WHAT'S
PRODUCED FROM THAT LEASE
PRODUCES IN COIL THAT MEANS
ANYTHING THAT'S PRINTED ON THE
OUTSIDE OF A CARDBOARD BOX.
MEMBERS IT TAKES FIFTY OR SEES
ME THIRTY FIVE GALLONS OF OIL TO
TAKE THAT TO MAKE TIRES ON A
PREVIOUS AND EVEN MORE TO MAKE
THE PLASTICS THE WIRE INSULATION
AND OTHER CAR PARTS. THAT
REQUIRE OIL EVEN IN A FULLY
ELECTRIC VEHICLE. MUCH OF THE
OIL WE IMPORT COULD BE REPLACED
BY CALIFORNIANS IN STATE
PRODUCERS PROVIDING CALIFORNIA
JOBS IF WE WERE ALLOWED TO
EXPAND PRODUCTION. THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCER OPERATES
UNDER THE MOST STRINGENT
ENVIRONMENTAL AND REGULATORY
RULES IN THE IN THE WORLD. OIL
IN MY DISTRICT KERN COUNTY.
WHICH PRODUCES 70% OF THE
STATE'S FOSSIL FUELS. IS
EXTRACTED FROM WHAT'S
ESSENTIALLY A DESERT THERE'S NO
AMAZON RAIN FORESTS BEING
DESTROYED AND JOBS ARE CREATED
IN THE INDUSTRY AVERAGING A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR. THAT'S ALMOST
TWICE THE AVERAGE CALIFORNIA
SALARY. THESE EMPLOYEES GET
EXCELLENT BENEFITS AND
RETIREMENT PROGRAMS AS WELL. SB
THIRTEEN NINETEEN WHEN SIMPLY
IMPLORE THE LEGISLATURE TO
PROHIBIT THE IMPORT OF CRUDE OIL
INTO CALIFORNIA IF THE SOURCE OF
THE OIL IS A FOREIGN NATION THAT
IS DEMONSTRATED. THAT HAS
DEMONSTRATED HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES
LIKE SAUDI ARABIA WHICH INPUT
IMPRISONS AND BEATS AND HANGS.
ANYONE IN THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY
WHICH DOESN'T EVEN ALLOW WOMEN
TO VOTE OR DRIVE OR A FOREIGN
NATION WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS THAT ARE LOWER THAN
THOSE OF CALIFORNIA. THE MEASURE
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE CAL JIM TO
REPORT ON ITS WEBSITE THE AMOUNT
OF PARTICULAR MATTER CARBON IT'S
RELEASED INTO THE AIR ON OIL
TANKER SHIPS AND EMISSIONS. IN
AN EFFORT TO HIGHLIGHT THE AIR
QUALITY IMPACT OF THIS STATE'S
DEPENDENCE ON FOREIGN OIL AND
HOW WE TRANSPORT THAT OIL TO THE
STATE. LET ME SHOW YOU A KEY FEW
QUICK EXAMPLES OF WHAT THE BILL
WOULD ADDRESS. PERMISSION TO USE
A PROPER. PERMISSION GRANTED
WITH RECOGNIZING ARE VERY
LIMITED TIME VERY LIMITED TIME
THIS IS JUST TWO MONTHS AGO A
PIPELINE BURST IN THE KOCHER
RIVER IN ECUADOR SPILLING SIX
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED BARRELS OF
OIL THIS BILL CONTAMINATED
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND SQUARE
METERS AND PROTECT A PROTECTED
NATIONAL. PARK IN POLLUTED RIVER
WITH THE INDIGENOUS TRIBES LIVE
AND DO THEIR LAUNDRY AND DRINK
THAT WATER. WE PAY FOR THIS TO
HAPPEN. THIS IS INDIGENOUS
TRIBES THAT CONSISTENTLY ARE IN
CONFLICT WITH THE ECUADORIAN
GOVERNMENT OVER THE LACK OF
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS THESE
INDIGENOUS INDIANS HAVE FILED A
LAWSUIT AGAINST THE ECUADORIAN
GOVERNMENT TO STOP BULLDOZING
DOWN. OUR RAIN FOREST. THIS IS A
SPILL ON THIS POSTER WITH
1-400-100-0401 THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTEEN OIL SPILLS
RECORDED IN ECUADOR IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO FROM TWO
THOUSAND TO TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
WE DON'T HAVE THOSE RECORDS
BILLS WE HAVE SEEPAGE IS IN A
NATURAL FLOW BUT THERE
IMMEDIATELY ADDRESSED.
EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENS IN
ECUADOR THAT WE PAY FOR GETS
BROUGHT INTO THIS STATE AGAIN
51% OF THE OIL IS PRODUCED FROM
ECUADOR. IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN A DAMAGED PIPELINE
BECAUSE EIGHT THOUSAND BARRELS
OF OIL TO SPILL INTO THE AMAZON
RAINFOREST. NOT AND KNOW THAT
THERE'S LESS SURROUNDINGS IN THE
JUNGLE AND THAT THESE INDIGENOUS
INDIANS WHERE WE PRODUCE WORK WE
PURCHASED THIS PRODUCED OIL IS
COMING TO CALIFORNIA. THIS IS A
TYPICAL KERN COUNTY OIL. IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE 70% OF THE
STATE'S OIL IS PRODUCED YOU CAN
SEE THERE'S NO TROPICAL
RAINFOREST THERE'S NO INDIGENOUS
INDIANS. THE BARRELS OF OIL CAN
BE EXTRACTED SAFELY UNDER THE
MOST STRINGENT ENVIRONMENTAL
REGULATORY PROCESSES IN THE
WORLD. WHERE SHOULD CALIFORNIA
GET ITS OIL KERN COUNTY OR
ECUADOR. THESE ARE JUST A FEW
HEADLINES OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF MONTHS HERE'S A COUPLE OF
ARTICLES SATELLITE IMAGES
THROUGH THE AMAZON RAINFOREST IS
HURTLING TOWARDS THE TIPPING
POINT. DISASTER BURST PIPELINE
SPREE'S CRUDE OIL INTO THE F.
ECUADORIAN AMAZON RAIN FOREST
ANNUALLY OCEAN CROSSING TANKERS
AMID A HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION TONS OF CO TWO. IRAQ'S
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WAS
MARRED BY THE WIDESPREAD REUSS A
USE OF TORTURE FOR THE LGBT
COMMUNITY SAUDI ARABIA'S HUMAN
RIGHTS PROBLEMS ARE NOT GOING
AWAY ACCORDING TO BBC NEWS.
COLLEAGUES I CAN TELL YOU THAT
THESE COUNTRIES THAT PROVIDE OIL
FOR CALIFORNIANS THAT WE CONSUME
EVERY SINGLE DAY. ARE A DISASTER
AND THE POLICIES THAT WE HAVE IN
THIS IN THIS STATE THAT ALLOW
PURCHASING OF THAT OIL TO
DESTROY OTHER COUNTRIES WITHOUT
PRODUCING IT HERE IN THE MOST
DAVIS ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
REGULATORY PROCESSES. THAT EXIST
IN THE WORLD- IS JUST
UNACCEPTABLE. CALIFORNIA
PRODUCERS IN CALIFORNIA WORKERS
ARE READY TO MEET THAT DEMAND
FOR CALIFORNIA OIL MORE THAN A
THOUSAND DRILLING PERMITS
CURRENTLY SIT AT CAL JAM ALONG
WITH FIFTY FIVE YOU I SEEK
PERMITS THAT HAVE BEEN SITTING
THERE FOR OVER FOUR YEARS-
BELIEVE THESE PERMITS WOULD
EXPAND PRODUCTION IN THE STATE.
REDUCE OUR FOREIGN IMPORTS
GENERATE THOUSANDS OF HIGH
PAYING JOBS IMPROVE OUR STATE'S
ENERGY SECURITY AND DONE AND
AGAIN UNDER THE MOST STRINGENT
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS. THE
QUESTION I'M ASKING YOU TODAY'S
IF WE CONTINUE TO DEFEND THE
STATE'S CURRENT ENERGY POLICY.
IS SENDING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OVERSEAS TO SUPPORT GOVERNMENTS
THAT DON'T AGREE WITH. YOUR
CONSISTENT WITH YOU ARE ARE THEY
CONSISTENT WITH OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL SOCIAL STANDARDS
AND VALUES. SB THIRTEEN NINETEEN
WOULD START A PROCESS TO BRING
BACK TO CALIFORNIA THE THOUSANDS
OF JOBS THAT HAVE BEEN LOST TO
FOREIGN COUNTRIES THAT DO NOT
SHARE OUR DEMOCRATIC VALUES ARE
RESPECT THE ENVIRONMENT. BEFORE
WE MOVED TO MY WITNESSES I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
CHAIR AND THEIR STAFF FOR THE
FEEDBACK ON THIS BILL. AS
MENTIONED IN THE ANALYSIS CAL
JIM IS NOT THE AIR QUALITY
REGULATOR- MODELLER IT MAKES
MORE SENSE TO HAVE A LINK
PROVIDED FOR THEIR INFORMATION
TO BE PROVIDED ON THE WEBSITE.
THAT'S ASSOCIATED WITH THE
TRANSPORTATION OF OIL IMPORTED
IN THE STATE AND I BELIEVE THAT
AMENDMENT TO ONE THAT YOU
MENTIONED IN THE ANALYSIS- I'M
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THAT AMENDMENT
WITH MEDIA HAIR TESTIFY HERE
TODAY- FOR SB THIRTEEN NINETEEN.
IS THE MAYOR OF TAFT AND
SOMEBODY WHO HAS WORKED IN THE
OIL INDUSTRY- FOR SEVERAL
SEVERAL YEARS AND SHAUN WHELAN
TINE WITH CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND MISTER MIRACLE
YOU'RE ON THE LINE OR OR YOU'RE
YOU'RE HERE IN PERSON SO.
RECOGNIZING THE LATE HOUR OF DO
APPRECIATE MAKING THE TRIP.
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR AND
SENATORS THANK YOU SENATOR GROW
FOR BRINGING THIS STUFF TO LIVE
WHERE WE SPEND OUR MONEY SAYS A
LOT ABOUT WHO WE ARE. RESULT
DECISIONS FOR ALL DECISIONS HAVE
LOCAL IMPLICATIONS AND THAT IS
TRUE ABOUT THE OIL INDUSTRY. SO
SHE'S ALREADY TALKED ABOUT HUMAN
IMPACTS OVERSEAS AND WHAT WE'RE
DOING SO IT'S TALK ABOUT BRIEFLY
WHAT ARE POLICIES DO HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. BY INCREASING THE
COST OF ALL FORMS OF ENERGY. AS
A MATTER OF EXAMPLE. INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIA YOU LIVE HERE YOU PAY
A DOLLAR A DOLLAR FIFTY MORE PER
GALLON FOR EVERY GALLON OF GAS
AND DIESEL COMPARED TO EVERY
STATE THAT BORDERS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IF YOU LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA YOU PAY BETWEEN THREE
AND FOUR TIMES AS MUCH. FOR
EVERY KILOWATT HOUR OF ENERGY AS
YOU DO IF YOU LIVE IN ANY STATE
BORDERING. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THIRTY CALIFORNIA'S
THIRTY NINE MILLION PEOPLE OF
THOSE THIRTY NINE MILLION PEOPLE
ABOUT 36% LIVE NEAR OR BELOW THE
POVERTY LEVEL THEY ARE HANGING
ON. BY THEIR FINGERNAILS. THE
UNNECESSARY INCREASED COST OF
THOSE CRITICAL FORMS OF ENERGY.
ARE GOING TO DRIVE THEM BELOW
THE POVERTY LEVEL 36% THAT'S
FOURTEEN MILLION CALIFORNIANS.
RIGHT NOW. SO WE'RE GONNA BE
OKAY WITH 40% OR FORTY TWO OR
FORTY FOUR PERCENT. WE DON'T
NEED THAT THAT IS NOT NECESSARY.
AND AS FAR AS THE JUST
TRANSITION I DON'T BELIEVE ANY
OF THOSE FOURTEEN MILLION PEOPLE
WOULD THINK DRIVING THEM DEEPER
INTO POVERTY. IS VERY JUST THAT
ALL. MISSTATED CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE AN ABUNDANCE OF ENERGY AND
WE HAVE THE TALENT. THE THOUSAND
PLUS PERMITS ARE BEING HELD
HOSTAGE OR DELAYED MOSTLY OF
THEM ARE FOR INFIELD DRILLING
THAT MEANS GOING IN AND DRILLING
ADDITIONAL WELLS. LIKE IN THAT
PICTURE SHOULDN'T CENTER GROVE
SHOWED YOU SO THESE ARE NEW
WELLS ON EXISTING OIL FIELDS IN
KNOWN RESERVOIRS. THAT WOULD BE
DRILLED USING- PERFECTED
TECHNIQUES BY PROFESSIONALS AND
AS WELL AS THE OIL COMING OUT
THERE WILL GOING IN EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO MAKE ITS WAY
TO MARKET IT IS THE LEAST
EXPENSIVE. SAFEST MOST THE LEAST
INTRUSIVE METHOD TO GET
ADDITIONAL BARRELS OF OIL TO
MARKET. ITS CALIFORNIA'S WAY OUT
OF THE MESS YOU'LL HEAR THE
PHRASE GLOBALLY AND THAT IS
ENERGY POVERTY ENERGY POVERTY
MEANS THE ADDITIONAL COSTS FOR
CRITICAL FORMS OF ENERGY. IT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN IT DOESN'T HAVE
TO CONTINUE TO HAPPEN HERE WE
CAN AVOID IT. I THANK THE CHAIR
AND CENTERS FOR THE TIME. THANK
YOU MR MAYOR OF TO TWO IN TWO
MINUTES AND SOME TAKEN SO PLEASE
BE BRIEF IF YOU DON'T MIND THIS
ORDER MEMBERS. ON WALL.
STROLLING ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA'S
INDEPENDENT OIL AND GAS
PRODUCER'S- SERVICE AND SUPPLY
COMPANIES AND ROYALTY OWNERS
MEMBERS THIS IS YOUR OIL
INDUSTRY WE OPERATE UNDER THE
REGIME THAT YOU HAVE CREATED AND
VARIOUS ADMINISTRATIONS HAVE
CREATED OVER YEARS WE DO IT
RIGHT WE PRODUCE CRUDE OIL UNDER
THE STRICTEST ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS AND WORKER PROTECTIONS
ON PLANET EARTH. WE HOPE YOU'RE
PROUD OF YOUR IN STATE OIL
PRODUCERS WE DON'T DO IT ECUADOR
DOES WE DON'T LIVE LIKE SAUDI
ARABIA AND IRAQ WE CAN PRODUCE
MORE CRUDE RIGHT HERE UNDER THE
WATCHFUL EYE OF CALIFORNIA'S
REGULATORS AND WE OUGHT TO DO
MORE I DO WANNA IN CLOSING POINT
OUT TO THE SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT HAS
A SCIENTIFIC GROUP REPORT YOU
ALL OUGHT TO READ AND IT SAYS
THAT BY TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
PORT SHIPS WILL BE THE NUMBER
ONE POLLUTER IN THE LA BASIN
OKAY WE OFTEN OIL PRODUCERS IN
THE STATE GET BLAMED FOR THAT SO
WE REALLY HOPE YOU WILL RANK YOU
WILL SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION OKAY
VERY GOOD- OTHERS IN SUPPORT I
HEARING HEARING ROOM SEEING
NONE- ANY ON THE LINE- WE'VE
GONE WAY OVER TIME HERE FOLKS SO
IF ANYONE WANTS TO TESTIFY ON
THE LINE PLEASE MAKE IT BRIEF IN
JUST YOUR NAME- WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO RECESS AND HEAR THE BILL AT
THE NEXT HEARING IF WE CAN'T GET
THROUGH THIS IN A TIMELY MANNER.
SO MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES. THANK YOU DO I TRUST
SUPPORT OF S. B. NINETEEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE
FILED BY ZERO TO FIND SUPPORT
FOR SB THIRTEEN NINETEEN. LINE
THREE FIFTY YOU ARE OPEN. YES
LASSEN PARK WEST SIDE RECREATION
AND PARK DISTRICT. A DISTRICT
ADMINISTRATOR ALSO- THE-
CONTRACT YOU'RE A MANUAL BUT
WILL RECORD PARK DISTRICT. AND
THE PRESIDENT KERN COUNTY
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION-
IS IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK
YOUNG- SO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU WE HEARD YOU THANKS A
LOT SORRY FREE PRE BRIEF FOLKS
WE GOTTA KEEP MOVING NEXT. LINE
TWO SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. THEY TOOK THEMSELVES OUT IF
YOU LIKE TO NINETY THREE YOU ARE
OPEN. YES I'M PAMELA BRILL IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN
NINETEEN THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALL
RIGHT NEXT WE WERE LYING FORTY
YOU ARE OPEN. ONE FORTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES. HI MIKE UMBRO MASTER OF
ENVIRONMENTAL MANAGEMENT DUKE
UNIVERSITY AND KERN COUNTY OIL
PRODUCER IT IS RIDICULOUS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANKS FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY OIL PRODUCTION
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU SO MUCH NO COMMENTS FOLKS
JUST YOUR NAME IN SUPPORT. ONE
THREE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RUSSELL JOHNSON
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT- WINE ONE FORTY THREE YOU
ARE OPEN. AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CAROLYN MCLAUGHLIN A MEMBER OF
THE KERN COUNTY I HIGHLY
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT. A LINE
ONE NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. THE CATCHER IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN NINETEEN THANK YOU LIKE
TO ALL SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK TO ALL SEVEN PLEASE ON
MUTE. SANDY SHEPHERD IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN NINETEEN
THANK YOU. ONE TO THIRTY FIVE
YOU ARE OPEN. VETERANS WITH-
MAKE CALIFORNIA OIL AND GAS
WORKER- IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S.
B. THIRTEEN NINETEEN. THANK YOU
NEXT AND IF ANYONE DOESN'T WANT
TO TESTIFY WE DO HAVE ALL OF
YOUR NAMES SO FAR IN SUPPORT
THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM SO IF
ANYONE STOPPED OFF THE LINE.
THEY'RE WELCOME TO. BUT YOU'RE
WELCOME TO KEEP TESTIFYING AS
WELL NEXT. ONE TWO SEVENTY FOR
YOUR OPEN. BY TWO SEVENTY FOUR
NOT EVEN AFFORDED THE SAME
AMOUNT OF TIME THIS YEAR COLLEGE
. YOU'RE YOU'RE OPEN. TO SEVENTY
FOUR. LIVING A LOT MORE ALIGNED
ONE NINETY NINE. ERIC LAWSON
KERN COUNTY RESIDENT IN SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTY NINETEEN. THANK YOU
. ONE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WE'LL GO TO LINE. I'LL GO AHEAD
MIKE. MICROVISION BULGING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT. MY THREE
NINETEENTH PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU
ARAMBULA COUNTY RESIDENT IN
SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN NINETEEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT. ONE
THREE TWENTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN
. RIGHT AT THE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT IN SUPPORT. LINE THREE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TERAGO YOU GOES MARIN COUNTY
RESIDENT THIRD GENERATION OIL
FAMILY OR AT THIRTEEN NINETEEN
THANK YOU. TWO FORTY TWO FORTY
EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. THE COMPANY
WITH MY FACE AN OIL COMPANY AND
I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT SYSTEM.
THANK YOU. NINE THREE THIRTY
EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. HI LAURA
BARNES WITH ABC CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER STRONG
SUPPORT EVENT THE THIRTEEN
NINETEEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT. ONE THREE THIRTY NINE YOU
UP FOR. JERRY HARMER CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT AND I THINK FOR. THANK
YOU NEXT ONE TWO OH ONE YOU ARE
OPEN. CAPTION KERN COUNTY
RESIDENT IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN NINETEEN. THANK YOU.
ONE THREE FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER COUNTY
RESIDENT I'M IN SUPPORT. THANKS. TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THREE FORTY TWO YOU
ARE OPEN TO DANIEL. MOVING ALONG
HERE HERE REPORTER THIRTEEN
NINETEEN THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
. WHY ONE NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL IN. THANK YOU. WHY
TO SEVENTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN.
ARGENT COURT FIGURE MUCH NEXT.
THREE THREE FORTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RAINY SPEAKER RATHER
THAN A- BURKE COUNTY IN SUPPORT
. THANK YOU NEXT. TWO SEVENTY
FOUR LEGAL PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHY
EARLY CONSULTANT I'M IN FAVOR OF
IT THE BILL THANK YOU NEXT. TWO
FIFTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN. JEFF
RIMMER AND I MEANT THE COURT
THANK YOU NEXT. NINE THREE
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS DANIEL DOLLARS- WILL
WORK. FOR FIFTEEN THIRTEEN
NINETEEN THANK YOU NEXT. I THREE
THIRTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN. RIGHT
NOW ALL YOUR PRODUCTION COMPANY
RED RESIDENT I'M IN FAVOR OF
THREE THIRTY THIRTEEN NINETEEN
THANK YOU NORRIS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT. ONE THREE FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ADAM HERE I'M
IN FULL SUPPORT OF SB THREE
NINETY THIRTEEN NINETEEN OKAY
THANK YOU NEXT. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. IDITAROD LINE THREE OH
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS DANIEL KIRK CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN NINETEEN. THANK YOU
NEXT. ONE THREE FORTY SEVEN YOU
ARE OPEN. THREE FORTY SEVEN YOU
ARE OPEN. I'M MOVING ALONG WE
WILL GO TO LINE NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JOHNNY CASH IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT. NEXT WE
WILL GO TO LINE EIGHTY YOU ARE
OPEN. THAT'S OKAY EITHER KERN
COUNTY RESIDENT AND WORK THANKS
NEXT. THREE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THREE FORTY EIGHT YOUR
OPEN. ARE MOVING ALONG LIKE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD-
COMMITTEE ON RESIDENTS KERN
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIRTEEN NINETEEN THANK YOU NEXT
. LINE ONE FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. KERN COUNTY I'M IN FULL
SUPPORT THANKS NEXT. MIKE THREE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CRICKETERS THE TRUTH MAYBE
FIFTEEN FOR CALIFORNIANS SHOPS
FOR THE BEST BE DISCONNECTING
OKAY THANKS NEXT. ONE THREE
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
BRITAIN DOLLARS KERN COUNTY
RESIDENT AMPLE SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN NINETEEN THANK YOU NEXT
. THREE FIFTY FIVE EUROPE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THREE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OVERLYING THREE
FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR DRUMMER ANY RESIDENT IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT.
ONE THREE TWENTY YOU ARE OPEN. I
WILL LIKE THREE THIRTY YOU ARE
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. OUR GROWTH
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT. WHY
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THERE BURKE COUNTY RESIDENTS
READ THE FROM WHICH FOR THANK
YOU NEXT. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE-
CONCLUDED ALL THE PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THIS TIME OKAY- THANK YOU FOR
THAT. SO SEEING NO MORE IN
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM WILL TURN
OPOSITION WE'VE NONE LISTED ON
FILE AND IN THE HEARING ROOM
SEEING NONE WILL TURN THE LINES
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION ONLINE'S
MODERATOR. YOU LIKE TO. TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTEEN
NINETEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME WHEN NOBODY ZERO.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE FORTY
SEVEN THE GO AHEAD. THREE FORTY
SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. ARE YOU
MUTED THREE FORTY SEVEN. BRUCE
HEY THERE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
WERE TAKING- OPPOSITION AT THIS
POINT BUT THANK YOU. ANY OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
NOBODY ELSE FIGURE OUT OKAY- I'M
SEEN ON OTHERS IN THE ROOM WILL
BRING BACK TO THE DIETS AND I'LL
JUST SAY BRIEFLY. PRESHEAF THE
POINT MADE ABOUT AN OIL IMPORT
EMISSIONS AND- TAKING THE FIRST
AMENDMENT RECOGNIZING THAT ARE
THE AUTHORS NOT INTERESTED IN
REMOVING SECTION ONE ITS
ENTIRETY THE COMMITTEE.
DEVELOPED THE- THE BED A
DIFFERENT APPROACH TO NOT STRIKE
IN ITS ENTIRETY BUT TO ADOPT THE
LANGUAGE- THAT SITTING BEFORE
YOU HERE- IT IS THE INTENT OF
THE LEGISLATURE THAT THE STATE
ENERGY RESEARCH CONSERVATION
DEVELOPMENT COMMISSION. UNDER
FOREIGN COUNTRIES THAT EXPORT
OIL AND IDENTIFIED ITS WEBSITE
THE COUNTRIES WITH DEMONSTRATE
HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES AS
DOCUMENTED BY THE- US
DEPARTMENT. OF STATE OR BY HUMAN
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS- I WOULD I
WOULD BE WILLING TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON. BOTH THAT AMENDMENT
AND THE FIRST AMENDMENT- OR ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS AT THIS
TIME. SO THE MOTION FROM
SENATOR- SENATOR EGGMAN
COMMENTER QUESTIONS ON AROUND I
MEAN I THINK YOU MAY LET'S AGREE
POINTS- SENATOR I THINK THAT THE
AMENDMENT- THAT YOU'RE OFFERING
BOTH ADD SOME- COULD TRUTH TO
THE COMMUNITY DEALS WITH THE
FACT THAT YOU KNOW TELL HIM IT'S
NOT THE APPROPRIATE IT TO. TO
DEAL WITH THE SUN- AIR QUALITY
ISSUES WHICH YOU SAID YOURSELF
CENTER AND THEN IT ALSO. MAKES
THE- THE BILL CONSTITUTIONAL-
BUT STILL GETS THE SOME OF THE
KEY ISSUES EVEN RAISING ABOUT
THE VERY TROUBLING HUMAN RIGHTS
RECORD- THAT EXISTS IN SO MANY
OF THESE COUNTRIES THAT. WERE
IMPORTING OIL FROM SO- I THINK
THAT- I'LL SUPPORT THE THEM THE
BILL AS AS- MOVED OKAY. ZANIMA
THANK YOU AND YOU KNOW AS CENTER
GROVE YOU AND I'VE HAD AN
EXTENSIVE AMOUNT OF
CONVERSATIONS ON THIS AND THE
ONLY THING I WANT TO GO ON
RECORD YOU KNOW ONE THING ABOUT
THIS IS THAT THERE IS A CALL
COMMENT MADE ABOUT OUR
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
AND THAT THEY'RE NOT IN KERN AND
I JUST WANTED TO GO ON RECORD
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS HAD A LOT OF
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE AND THEY NO
LONGER OWN THEIR LAND- AND SO-
WHAT WE ARE SEEN IN ONE COUNTRY-
IS DIFFERENT TO- HERE BUT BUT
THE FACT THAT INDIGENOUS PEOPLE
AT ONE. POINT THEIR LAND WAS
ALSO A DECIMATED I THINK JUST
NEEDS TO GO ON RECORD- BECAUSE I
THINK THAT THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO ME TO RECOGNIZE THAT AND I
THINK ALL YOUR VISUALS ARE VERY
KEY IN- HIGHLIGHTING WHAT CAN
HAPPEN ANYWHERE AT ANY PART OF
THE GLOBE WHEN THIS BILL LOOKS
LIKE THAT IT WILL STILL BE
PROBLEMATIC IN KERN COUNTY IN
ANY OTHER COUNTY OR IN ANY OTHER
PART OF THE WORLD. SO WITH THAT
. THANK YOU- SEE NO OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. LATER
CLOSE I APPRECIATE THAT SIR AND
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA BARBARA-
THERE WAS NO OFFENSE MEANT TO
INDIGENOUS INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD
LOST THEIR PROPERTY- OBVIOUSLY.
WITH THE TRIBES THAT I REPRESENT
THEIR TRYING TO REGAIN THEIR
PROPERTY- I DO A- TAKE. A LITTLE
OFFENSE TO THE FACT THAT WHAT
HAPPENS IN ECUADOR. YOU THINK IS
EQUALLY TO WHAT HAPPENS HERE
BECAUSE IT IS IT IS NOT. AND
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF BARRELS
OF OIL GOING TO FRESH WATER
STREAMS IN ECUADOR WE PURCHASED
THAT. OIL FROM ECUADOR TO
CALIFORNIA. WHERE WE MIGHT HAVE
A- SEEPAGE- THE LATEST WHEN WE
HAD THE GOT NATIONAL RECOGNITION
OR NATIONAL ATTENTION. WAS ABOUT
THE SIZE OF A HALF OF A WALMART.
AND IT WAS ON DRY BEDS AND DRYLY
QUIDS IN A DESERT AREA. AGAIN ON
THE SAME. AREA WHERE ALL THESE
OTHER WELLS ARE IN THE WE GET A
PERMIT LIKE THE PERMITS THAT ARE
WAITING ON THE ONE THOUSAND ONE
PERMITS. THEY'RE ASKING TO DRILL
A WELL RIGHT HERE. AND THEY
STILL HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
ENTIRE PROCESS SEE WHAT PROCESS.
DO AN ESTIMATED. IT EXAMINATION
ON THE WATER AQUIFER IT IS
WITHIN THIS WHOLE AREA. SO
THAT'S WHAT I'M JUST TRYING TO
DO IS BRING REALITY TO HOW WE
PRODUCE CALIFORNIA OIL HERE FOR
CALIFORNIANS. WITH FOR
CALIFORNIA JOBS. I'M HERE. AT
THE BEST AND MOST HIGHEST
QUALITY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS ANYWHERE. WHAT HAPPENS
IN ECUADOR AND OTHER COUNTRIES
DOES NOT HAPPEN HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I DO ALSO
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENT THAT YOU SAID
EARLIER IF THERE'S NOT A BILL
THERE'S NOT A CONVERSATION. YOU
AND I HAVE IT A DISTANCE OF
CONVERSATIONS. ON THE FIXES THAT
NEED TO HAPPEN IN CALIFORNIA OIL
INDUSTRY ALONG WITH THE CHAIR.
ABOUT THE INEQUITY ON- THE WAY
THAT WERE FOUND IN ABANDONED
WELLS ARE TAKING CARE OF. AND I
THINK THAT IF YOU HAVE A BILL
AND YOU HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT IT THEN THOSE THINGS CAN
COME TO REALITY. AND. IT'S
OBVIOUS THAT. ARE MAJOR PRODUCE
. DON'T ARE NOT EQUALLY TREATED
LIKE ARE SMALLER BUT- ADVICE
PERCENT OR SMALLER PRODUCERS ARE
NOT EQUALLY TREATED LIKE ARE
MAJOR PRODUCERS WHEN IT COMES TO
ORPHANED AND ABANDONED WELLS.
THERE ARE SERIOUS ISSUES IN OUR
STATE THAT WE DO FACE. NONE OF
THESE THAT I SHOWED ON THIS
BOARD OF WHAT HAPPENS IN ECUADOR
IS SOMETHING THAT WE FACE HERE.
BECAUSE WE DO THIS UNDER THE
ENVIRONMENTAL STRICT IN THE MOST
STRICTEST ENVIRONMENTAL
REGULATORY PROCESSES. IN THE
WORLD AND WE SHOULD PRODUCE
CALIFORNIA OIL HERE. UNDER THOSE
RESTRICTIONS WHERE WE OVERSEE
IT. AND PROVIDE CALIFORNIA JOBS
AND STOP THIS NONSENSE COMING
FROM OTHER COUNTRIES SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND I THINK YOU. FOR AND MAKING
SURE THAT YOU UNDERSTAND THAT
YOU MADE THAT COMMENT THAT WITH
THE BILL THERE'S ALWAYS A
CONVERSATION. SO THE MOTION IS-
IS TO PASS IF YOU MISTER CHAIR
ONE MORE THING YES USUALLY BILLS
ARE THOUSANDS OF PAGES LONG.
MINUS TWO PAGES THE DIGEST IS A
ONE AND A HALF PAGES. THE ACTUAL
BILL LANGUAGE IS A NINETEEN
LINE. I'M ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENT THAT STRIKES LAW. THE
IN IN ITS ENTIRETY LINES ONE
THROUGH THIRTEEN AND ADDS AN
ADDITIONAL SECTION TO MAKE THE
BILL PROBABLY SIX LINES LONG.
FOR FIVE LINES LONG SO. JUST TO
BE CLEAR THE MOTION COMMENT YEAH
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENT THE
MOTION BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
THOUGH JUST TO BE CLEAR ON WHAT
EVERYONE'S VOTING ON IS.
AMENDMENT ONE WHICH IS IN THE
ANALYSIS THE LINK ON THE WEBSITE
FOR CAL GENESIS WITH AIR QUALITY
EMISSIONS AROUND TRANSPORTATION
OF OIL IMPORT INTO THE STATE.
BUT AMENDMENT TO WILL NOT BE TO
REMOVE SECTION ONE ITS ENTIRETY
BUT INSTEAD SUPPLANT THAT WE
HAVE THE LANGUAGE YOU HAVE
BEFORE YOU SAID THAT WAS THE
MOTION MADE- BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE AT THIS POINT- YOU'VE
CLOSED. CHIEF CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM TEN S.
B. THIRTEEN NINETEEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY STERN.
STERN ALRIGHT JONES. JONES ALL
RIGHT ALAN. ALLEN ALL RIGHT
EGGMAN EGGMAN ON A GROOVE. GROVE
I HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG AYE
HUESO. HUESO AYE LAYERED.
LAYERED I LOAN. LOAN ONLINE NINE
OKAY NINE AM MEASURES OUTLETS
LIST THE CALLS ON THE- I'LL JUST
EGGMAN ORDER YEAH LET'S GO RIGHT
IN ORDER AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO
WAIT FOR ME JUST KEEP IT ON FILE
ITEM ONE S. B. TWELVE NINETY
FIVE THE CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE
ZERO JONES. JONES NOEL ALAN.
GROVE. WHAT WHAT WE WANNA FILE.
ONE FOR TWELVE NINETY FIVE. SO
HAVE THE OPTION TO LET ME MAKE A
COPY AND COMMENT ON PLAY WITH.
OKAY GREAT- I SEE OKAY OKAY.
HUESO ALL RIGHT HUESO RIGHT THAT
HAS ONE TWO THREE ALLAH ALLAH.
OKAY THREE FOUR FIVE SIX. SEVEN
ONE ZERO SEVEN ONE ONE THE BILL
CAME OUT ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THAT IS- FILE ITEM TWO SB EIGHT
THIRTY TWO FILE ITEM SEVEN S. B.
TEN TWENTY EIGHT FILE ITEM
ELEVEN SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY TWO
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ZERO JONES.
JONES AYE ALLEN. ALLEN ALL RIGHT
GROVE. HUESO HUESO HI THAT HAS
EIGHT THAT'S OUT OKAY MEASURES
OUT- FILE ITEM THREE S. B. TEN
SIXTY TWO- THE CURRENT VOTE IS
SIX ZERO JONES. JONES I ALLEN.
ALLEN RD HUESO HUESO EYES THAT
THAT BILL HAS NINE THAT ONE'S
OUT. OF FILE ITEM FOR SPC A
LEVIN TWENTY THREE THE CURRENT
VOTE IS FIVE ZERO EGGMAN.
HERTZBERG SORRY ONE IS REPEAT
THE MEASURE TO THE NIGHT
HERTZBERG. HUESO HUESO HI LIMÓN
LIMÓN ALL RIGHT THAT'S NINE ZERO
THAT ONE'S OUT. YET YES YOU OKAY
THAT'S FILING FOR CORRECT YES
THE MEASURES OUT FILE ITEM FIVE
S. B. TWELVE NINETEEN THE
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR ZERO. JONES
YES ALAN. THIS IS LOOKING AT
THAT WE'RE GONNA. TRY TO DO ALL
IN ALL RIGHT EGGMAN. GROVE HUESO
. HUESO HI. TWO FOUR FIVE SIX
ZERO THAT ONE'S OUT OKAY VERY
GOOD SIT FILE ITEM SIX THIS IS
THE CONSTITUTIONAL MENTOR FROM
NIELSEN THAT'S RIGHT FILE ITEM
SIX IS CA EIGHT THE MOTION I'VE
BEEN ASKED TO RE READ THE MOTION
BE ADOPTED AS AMENDED IN FIRST
REFER TO ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS THE
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ZERO. ALLEN
HERTZBERG. HUESO LIMON. OKAY IT
HAS FIVE THAT WAS A FIVE ZERO
THAT ONE'S OUT OKAY- AND THEN WE
MOVED TO THAT'S IT. OKAY.
PROBABLY- ELEVEN TWENTY THREE
ARE YOUR AYE VOTE ALL RIGHT I
WITH THAT ALL MEASURES DROUGHT
APOLOGIES TO LEADERSHIP AND
EVERYONE ELSE WAITING ON THE
LINE. THANK YOU THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED.
WE'RE SORRY YOUR CONFERENCE IS
ENDING NOW PLEASE HANG UP.